jamais vu en accueil aujourd'hui bonjour
à toutes et à tous merci de nous avoir
rejoint dans cette salle Médicis pour
cette nouvelle journée des entreprises
c'est la sixième édition déjà alors nous
allons travailler toute la matinée sur
les deux thématiques prévues vous les
avez vu évidemment sur le programme je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver pour
animer ces débats pour une
rencontre qui se veut interactive bien
sûr puisque il va y avoir débat autour
de cette tribune et puis nous attendons
également beaucoup de vous toutes et
tous car cette journée vous appartient
également donc en fonction de ce que
diront nos intervenants le panel vous
pourrez intervenir mais dans la dernière
partie du débat nous consacrerons le
temps nécessaire pour écouter vos
questions vos témoignages puisque je
pense que vous avez beaucoup de de
choses à nous dire également sur les
différentes expériences que vous vivez
au quotidien et puis pourquoi pas faire
des propositions parce que c'est aussi
l'objectif de cette journée de travail
alors la transition environnementale des
entreprises comme levier de
compétitivité la transmission et la
reprise d'entreprise au cœur des
territoires alors traditionnellement
nous sommes chaque année accueillis ici
même au Palais du Luxembourg par le
Président Monsieur Gérard Larcher
monsieur le Président qui n'a pas pu
être des nôtres physiquement ce matin
car retenu par
déplacement en région monsieur l'archet
qui a tenu quand même à nous adresser
ces quelques mots à travers un message
que je vous propose d'écouter et de
regarder tout de suite
[Musique]
monsieur le président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises cher Serge
babary chers collègues sénateurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les chefs
d'entreprise
mesdames et messieurs
je vous souhaite la bienvenue pour cette
sixième journée des entreprises
organisées ici au Palais du Luxembourg
par notre délégation aux entreprises
dont je salue le président
ainsi que ses membres
je regrette vraiment de ne pouvoir être
en votre compagnie ce matin et vous prie
demander mais aujourd'hui même je
participe au congrès de l'Association
des départements de France à Agen
monsieur le Président bavary je souhaite
profiter de cette occasion pour saluer
votre engagement personnel à la tête de
la délégation engagement qui est
régulièrement sollicité à la fois par
nos collègues et les entreprises dans
tous les territoires et dont les travaux
je parle des travaux de la délégation
sont toujours attendus et très appréciés
je ne citerai pour exemple que le
dernier rapport de la mission conjointe
de contrôle sur la revitalisation des
centres villes et des centres bourgs que
vous avez rédigé avec nos collègues
Gilbert Luc de village et Sonia de la
pauvreté ce rapport constitue comme vous
aimez le dire un service après-vente 4
ans après l'adoption de la loi Elan dont
les mesures de revitalisation doivent
beaucoup d'ailleurs au Sénat
depuis sa création
c'était dans 2014 la délégation aux
entreprises est guidée par un objectif
cardinal
enrichir les réflexions et les travaux
du Sénat à travers une approche concrète
pragmatique de la vie des entreprises
dans leur diversité il s'agit d'informer
le Sénat sur la situation et les
perspectives de nos PME et de nos PMI
d'identifier les obstacles à leur
développement et bien sûr de proposer
des évolutions du cadre législatif et
réglementaire en s'inspirant de bonnes
pratiques et d'expériences locales
réussie afin d'encourager la croissance
et de l'emploi dans les territoires
aller à la rencontre des entrepreneurs
partout en France observez le tissu
économique local pour mieux comprendre
les problématiques de terrain oui cela
fait partie des fondamentaux de la
délégation
dans cet esprit nous avons renouvelé au
mois de juillet dernier notre
partenariat avec le réseau des Chambres
de Commerce et d'Industrie
présidé par Monsieur Alain des crescendo
cela permet au sénateur qui le souhaite
de passer quelques journées en immersion
dans les entreprises
cette nouvelle convention prévoit
également un échange régulier
d'informations économique sur les PME
qui alimenteront utilement les
réflexions et les propositions du Sénat
pour défendre la croissance dans les
territoires pour défendre l'emploi ce
dialogue approfondi essentiel pour la
bonne compréhension des enjeux
économiques locaux et des attentes des
entreprises
constituent à mon sens la meilleure des
garanties quant à la pertinence de nos
travaux
ce matin
au débats vont porter sur deux sujets
d'importance pour les entreprises et le
dynamisme économique de nos territoires
tout d'abord la transition
environnementale comme levier de la
compétitivité des entreprises il l'a
transmission et la reprise des
entreprises
la transmission environnementale qui
sera l'objet de la première table ronde
est assujée de grande importance
nombre d'entreprises sont confrontées à
une forte hausse de leur coût de
production
particulièrement de leur
approvisionnement énergétique et cela
menace directement leurs compétitivité
voire parfois leur existence même
d'ores et déjà certaines ont dû se
résoudre à réduire leur production au
profit de concurrent
extra-européens ne subissent pas la même
envolée du prix de l'énergie
c'est notamment le cas dans le secteur
du verre de la métallurgie ou encore de
l'alimentation
d'autres entreprises pourraient être
tentés de délocaliser si les difficultés
venaient à persister nous conduisons à
une nouvelle vague de
désindustrialisation
dans ce contexte la transition vers des
systèmes de production décarbonée plus
économes en énergie et plus respectueux
de l'environnement
constitue un impératif de premier ordre
nous permettra tout à la fois de lutter
contre leur dérèglement climatique de
renforcer notre souveraineté énergétique
et servir notre objectif de reconquête
industrielle en faisant de nos
entreprises les pionnières mondiales de
la transition environnementale et en les
deux temps ainsi d'un avantage
compétitif qui peut être décisif pour
affronter la concurrence je ne doute pas
que vos échanges inspireront les travaux
que mène actuellement nos collègues
Florence blatrix compta Jean agréé
Vincent Segoin dans le cadre de la
mission sur les difficultés des ETI et
les PME en matière de commerce extérieur
la seconde table ronde sur la
transmission d'entreprise fait que la
mission de suivi conduite par nos
collègues Michel canevres Rémy Cardon et
Olivier Rickman le rapport à adopté tout
récemment c'était la semaine dernière
montre que malgré plusieurs avancées
législatives largement inspiré des
travaux de notre délégation des
difficultés persistent pour organiser la
transmission d'une entreprise dans de
bonnes conditions qui garantissent sa
pérennité
moderniser la transmission d'entreprise
constitue un enjeu vital pour l'économie
et l'emploi de nos territoires et de
manière plus générale pour notre
souveraineté économique grâce au
maintien de certaines productions sur le
territoire national
que ce soit à l'occasion de ces travaux
de contrôle et de l'action du
gouvernement
ou au travers de l'examen et le vote des
projets de loi le Sénat porte un regard
attentif sur la vie des entreprises qui
font la force et la vitalité de nos
territoires
mieux comprendre l'environnement des
entreprises pour les aider à relever les
défis qui sont devant elle telle est la
raison d'être de cette délégation de
notre délégation aux entreprises vous
allez en avoir je crois ce matin une
nouvelle démonstration au cours de ces
échanges que je souhaite riche et
fructueux je sais que le président
bavary et nos collègues de la délégation
reçoit d'apporter une suite concrète et
utile aux idées que vous ferez éclore
aujourd'hui vraiment je vous souhaite
une très belle et agréable journée des
entreprises au Sénat merci de votre
présence
merci à vous monsieur le Président qu'on
peut applaudir pour cette intervention
voilà bien camper le décor et sans
attendre et bien j'invite à présent
Monsieur Serge babary sénateur
d'Indre-et-Loire président de la
délégation c'est natorial aux
entreprises qui nous accueillent
aujourd'hui donc pour cette journée de
travail président
merci
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
présents nombreux dans l'assistance
également après cette ouverture à
distance par le président du Sénat
producerait quelques mots d'accueil pour
vous dire combien nous nous réjouissons
de vous accueillir aujourd'hui pour la
sixième édition de notre journée des
entreprises
vous êtes plus de 150 chefs d'entreprise
je lutte 44 départements nous battons je
crois les records cette année en termes
de représentation territoriale
vous incarnez donc le dynamisme
économique des territoires français donc
toute leur diversité
organisées par la délégation sénatoriale
aux entreprises cette journée l'occasion
de poursuivre le dialogue établi sur le
terrain entre sénateurs et dirigeants de
PME et ETI
comme indiqué par le président Larcher
qui est à l'initiative de la création de
notre délégation fin 2014
celle-ci rassemble 42 sénateurs de toute
sensibilité politique elle est chargée
d'informer le Sénat sur la situation des
entreprises de recenser les obstacles à
leur développement et de proposer des
mesures visant à favoriser l'esprit
d'entreprise et à simplifier les normes
applicables à l'activité économique en
vue d'encourager la croissance et
l'emploi dans les territoires
vache ce programme
la délégation est allée à la rencontre
de centaines d'entrepreneurs français
dans 35 départements à ce jour c'est son
ADN être à l'écoute du terrain
sur le fondement des témoignages à
circuler à l'intervient de diverses
manières je pense en premier lieu aux
interpellations et questions
gouvernement nous avons ainsi par
exemple fait remonter les problèmes les
fameux trous dans la raquette Z pendant
la crise sanitaire et il y en avait pas
mal au début
plus récemment nous avons saisi par
exemple il y a quelques jours le
directeur de la Caisse des Dépôts car
nous avons été extrêmement surpris
d'apprendre la décision de déférencement
de CRFA formation en tant qu'organisme
de formation reconnue pour le compte
personnel de formation alors que les
formations délivrées par le CR a cédant
et repreneurs d'affaires c'est bien dans
le sujet de la matinée aussi
est très reconnu dans la profession et
nous pouvons également intervenir par le
biais d'amendement de proposition de loi
de proposition de résolution de rapport
pour informer
préconiser des solutions sur des sujets
importants pour la vie des entreprises
en 2022 outre le suivi de l'impact de la
conjoncture économique sur les
entreprises nous travaillons plus
particulièrement sur quatre thèmes
premièrement nous avons en septembre
dernier conjointement avec la délégation
collectivité territoriale adopter des
préconisations en faveur de la
revitalisation des centres-villes et
centre bourg nous avons par ailleurs
trois co-rapporteurs qui travaillent sur
les problématiques liées aux commerces
extérieur président l'archet l'a évoqué
dans son allocation tout à l'heure nous
examinerons leur rapport début décembre
nous avons aussi travaillé sur les deux
thèmes qui font l'objet de nos débats de
ce jour en premier lieu la transition
environnementale des entreprises comment
faire un levier de compétitivité
ce sujet n'est d'ailleurs pas sans lien
avec le commerce extérieur salut nos
corps sur le thème de la RSE qui sont
dans la salle qui vont nous rejoindre en
ce début de matinée Martine Berthet
Florence blatrix compta Jacques le nez
le rapport de suivi de la mission qui
avait été conduite en 2020 sur ce sujet
sera examiné par notre délégation jeudi
27 octobre prochain
nous sommes donc très intéressés par vos
points de vue et propositions sur ce
thème notre travail concerne les trois
volets de la RSE l'environnement social
et la gouvernance mais nous avons
souhaité s'entraîner notre table ronde
de ce matin
essentiellement sur le premier volet
notre seconde table ronde apôt thème
réussir la transmission et la reprise
d'entreprise une priorité dans nos
territoires nous avons adopté le rapport
de nos collègues Michel canevec qui est
présent Rémi Cardon et Olivier Rickman
également présent sur ce sujet jeudi 6
octobre dernier vous en avez d'ailleurs
peut-être lu des retombées très
nombreuses dans la presse économique ces
derniers jours avec mes collègues je
seront également à l'écoute de vos
échanges témoignages réactions sur ce
sujet tout aussi important pour la vie
et la survie des entreprises que le
premier
cette journée sera un moment fort de ce
qui fait le cœur de métier de la
délégation sénatorial que chez l'honneur
de présider le dialogue avec les
entreprises afin que ce dialogue se
poursuive au-delà de notre rendez-vous
annuel n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
pour faire remonter d'éventuelles
difficultés liées à l'application
concrète de texte législatif ou
réglementaires
notre mobilisation en faveur de la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
guidera toujours notre action quel que
soit la source de complexité ou de
difficultés et vous avez toujours
apporter de main
président l'archet dit à apporter
l'engueulade un sénateur sur votre
territoire n'hésitez pas à le contacter
je salue et remercie bien sûr mes
collègues sénateurs également présents
dans la salle ou à distance puisque nos
travaux sont retransmis en direct sur le
site du Sénat donc maintenant la parole
à Emmanuel kuni notre modérateur que je
remercie chaleureusement ainsi que vous
tous pour votre présence et votre
participation bonne journée à tous merci
président
merci beaucoup alors là la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises très actives
grâce à vous toutes et tous tout au long
de la session parlementaire mais aussi
tout au long de l'année alors rapport
adopté en cours d'adoption c'est un long
et intense travail que je vous propose
de découvrir à travers une très courte
vidéo un reportage avec les
co-rapporteurs sur le projet justement
de notre premier sujet la responsabilité
sociétale de l'entreprise
le RSE est en effet au cœur de la
transformation profonde de l'entreprise
depuis la crise sanitaire certaines
questions sont apparues dans le débat
public nous avions soulevés dans le
rapport de 2020 la première et la
sincérité de la démarche RSE avec le
foisonnement des labels que nous avions
dénoncé un rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances sur le label
public investissement socialement
responsable de décembre 2020 rejoint
notre rapport en demandant une évolution
radicale de ce label pour qu'il reste
crédible et pertinent
l'écho blanchiment cela existe c'est
pourquoi on pourrait envisager que les
entreprises qui s'engagent dans la RSE
public un rapport de durabilité aligné
avec la directive
CSRD dans un souci de simplification
dans le rapport de 2020 la délégation
aux entreprises avaient demandé un
moratoire sur de nouvelles les
informations extra-financières qui
pourraient être demandée aux entreprises
mais la loi climat est résilience de
2011 prévoit un nouvel affichage relatif
aux impacts environnementaux et au
respect de critères sociaux l'affichage
social alors qu'un dispositif proche
existe déjà il faut donc l'articulation
entre ces deux exigences soit claires et
qu'elles ne soient surtout pas source
d'insécurité juridique pour les
entreprises
l'affichage social fera l'objet d'une
expérimentation pour une durée maximale
de 5 ans son coût par contre pour les
PME reste à préciser et bien sûr nous
suivrons tout particulièrement ce
dossier pour l'Europe la RSE est aussi
un outil différenciation ce sont en
effet les normes européennes qui sont
les plus avancées cela doit conférer un
avantage compétitif aux entreprises
européennes
l'accord conclut le 21 juin dernier sur
la directive CSRD devrait booster la
diffusion de la RSE non seulement dans
les 50000 entreprises européennes
concernées 5 fois plus qu'actuellement
dont 2000 en France mais également et
indirectement dans les ETI PME intégrés
dans leur chaîne de valeur cela renforce
la crédibilité des informations et c'est
une bonne chose toutefois certains
demandent la publicité la plus grande
possible des données extra financières
mais les entreprises font valoir le
risque de devoir divulguer des
informations commercialement sensibles
alors que leurs concurrents non européen
ne sont pas contraints au même degré de
transparence cette directive constitue
un changement de paradigme et inscrit la
durabilité comme mesure de performance
des entreprises c'est une avancée
considérable pour ancrer la RSE au cœur
du modèle économique des entreprises
mais son efficacité est conditionnée à
son applicabilité concrète par les
entreprises
voilà donc pour je dirais l'envers du
décor et qui est une excellente entrée
en matière je crois que cette vidéo oui
voilà nous venons de la voir nous
enverrons d'autres tout à l'heure parce
que les travaux sont nombreux comme vous
le savez donc excellente entrée en
matière pour notre matinée et je
rappelle pour celles et ceux qui sont
arrivés il y a quelques minutes qui nous
ont rejoint qui n'étaient pas forcément
au début de la présentation de cette
journée cette journée se veut
interactive et vous aurez la parole
vous-même tout à l'heure il suffira de
demander je rappellerai la procédure à
suivre vous demanderez la parole et vous
l'aurez bien sûr pour échanger avec nos
intervenants alors transitions
environnementale des entreprises comment
faire un levier de compétitivité nous
allons aborder toutes ces questions avec
nos invités que je vous présente à ma
droite Madame Véronique de gotex
directrice générale du groupe cheval
spécialisé dans l'urbanisme
l'aménagement
urbain le paysagisme également avec nous
Madame Catherine Guerniou qui dirige la
fenêtrière fabricant de fenêtres sur
mesure et chef de file RSE au sein de la
Fédération française du bâtiment au
centre de ce de cette table Vincent
Wisner qui est directeur général délégué
du cabinet conseil profil et puis
Monsieur Thomas courbe qui est directeur
général des entreprises au ministère de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle sans oublier
le numérique alors chacune et chacun
vous allez avoir trois quatre minutes de
propos liminaire pour mettre en avant
votre thématique générale votre approche
du sujet de cette table ronde et puis
ensuite nous nous débattrons madame de
gotex de gotex je vous propose de
commencer je me tourne tout d'abord vers
vous avec peut-être une rapide
présentation de votre entreprise avant
de nous dire comment vous vous voyez
cette problématique de la Table Ronde
les sénatrices bonjour messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour et puis surtout
messieurs et mesdames et messieurs les
dirigeants à responsables entreprise
bonjour et merci on se sent nombreux à
partager les mêmes préoccupations si
nous sommes là donc le groupe cheval en
quelques mots c'est un groupe familial
comme beaucoup de TI dans les 5500 ETI
du territoire national avec la troisième
génération est toujours avec une
préoccupation parce que ETI familial
j'imagine que c'est le cas de nombreuses
PME et ETI
très très investis sur l'ADN
fort autour du social de
l'environnemental et du territorial
alors en ce qui nous concerne nous
sommes dans les métiers effectivement
d'urbanisme mais pas la construction
l'élévation plutôt les aménagements
avant autour de l'eau de terrassement et
puis tout ce qui est embellissement
paysagisme
urbanisme de manière un peu globale et
nous sommes déjà depuis pas mal d'années
par conviction en économie circulaire et
vous allez voir que ça rejoint et que on
a essayé d'en faire un vrai levier de
compétitivité économie circulaire ça
veut dire qu'on produit nos matériaux
qu'on les transforme et qu'on les on
s'en sert pour nos divers travaux et
qu'après on va jusqu'au recyclage pour
donner une seconde vie au matériau de
manière à servir des des enjeux globaux
que sont la décarbonation le climat
éventuellement si le stress hydrique
parce que c'est un enjeu
et donc on a orienté face à la crise
alors on a pris la tous vécu les
difficultés de la pandémie là maintenant
on fait face à une crise qui est
beaucoup sur les coups sur l'énergie et
qui contraint pas mal de secteurs donc
on essaye de se transformer et on a pris
des orientations stratégiques très
fortes en mettant comme gros relais de
croissance l'urbanisme vert pourquoi
parce qu'il va servir les enjeux d'une
part de de décarbonation mais aussi de
climat et on reviendra peut-être dessus
parce qu'on sait que si on plante bien
la végétation on est capable de baisser
la température et ce à court terme donc
on a les moyens d'agir on n'est pas
acculé la page d'après elle elle peut
être beaucoup moins sombre on a aussi on
en s'oriente aussi vers le recyclage et
c'est vrai qu'on est dans un secteur
initialement c'était du TP donc vous
imaginez que c'était un peu pollueur
payeur et et donc on est capable de
travailler de manière beaucoup plus
vertueuse alors bien sûr en travaillant
sur les équipements mais aussi sur la
manière
de travailler surtout de réutiliser les
matériaux et il y a plus de 90% des
matériaux qui peuvent être réutilisés
donc on essaye de donner une seconde vie
à la matière on voit que toutes les
répares qui arrivent vont se sens donc
ça va être un vrai levier de
compétitivité là aussi on est allé pour
cela et
toujours investi dans la RSE on a été le
premier groupe à être alors on est un
groupe mais je dirais plutôt je nous
qualifierais de fédération de PME donc
c'est vraiment un ensemble de
d'activités nous sommes implantés dans
la majoritairement on aura mais le siège
dans la Drôme très jolie départements
demeurant très actif et vert et on
essaie de le garder vert comme ceci et
on s'est lancé dans une démarche de
société à mission mais parce que c'était
déjà dans l'ADN ça a permis
d'officialiser et d'orienter la
stratégie avec comme trois grands
piliers évidemment le social nos
collaborateurs en premier lieu mais
aussi l'environnement les riverains les
habitants du territoire le
environnemental bien évidemment comment
est-ce qu'on préserve les ressources
naturelles et puis le territorial pour
travailler localement et au lieu non pas
de relocaliser mais développer les
industries sur notre territoire national
voilà on aura l'occasion de revenir dans
les détails justement je vous titillerai
sur certains points très intéressants
parce qu'il mérite d'être d'être
approfondie merci pour ce témoignage
madame de gotex Catherine guernoud donc
je rappelle dirigeante de l'entreprise
la fenêtre hier alors là on a le prisme
d'une PME justement qui a décidé ça sa
transition écologique jusque dans les
process de fabrication alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer la
philosophie générale de l'action
peut-être très rapidement un petit mot
de votre entreprise et puis donc comment
vous le pratiquez au quotidien très bien
merci beaucoup bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors je vais essayer de vous
expliquer effectivement comment je m'y
suis prise en fait moi je suis fabricant
de menuiserie extérieure donc de
fenêtres en PVC en aluminium et je
commercialise du bois
et petite PME en 12 salariés donc
vraiment petite PME voilà basé en
Île-de-France et en fait il y a une
dizaine d'années on a eu une très très
forte concurrence des pays de l'Est et
là je me suis dit comment devons-nous
faire parce qu'en fait clairement au
niveau des prix on n'arrivait pas à s'en
sortir et donc toute ma philosophie a
été de dire on va regarder notre ADN et
notre ADN en fait l'entreprise à la 40
ans c'est une entreprise familiale donc
il y a une transmission également et en
fait on a tout misé sur l'économie
circulaire comme Véronique mais
également sur le circuit court 95% de
mes menuiseries sont diffusés à Paris et
en Île-de-France donc en fait c'est
vraiment pour nous hyper important et
également le choix la traçabilité de nos
produits nos matières premières sont
100% française on vient d'ailleurs
d'être certifié au régime France
Garantie et donc vraiment aujourd'hui on
a décidé de passer à notre transition
écologique à travers une baisse de nos
émissions de CO2 que l'on retrouve sur
la consommation sur le la façon dont on
fabrique nos menuiseries mais également
sur l'usage de nos de nos locaux mais
aussi sur la manière dont on va
fabriquer nos menuiseries voilà donc
après je vous en dirai un petit peu plus
sur comment on s'y prend compter sur
nous pour vous vous interroger
effectivement c'est une
des initiatives très très précises qui
méritent d'être développé et approfondie
alors Vincent wissner vous dirigez vous
êtes directeur général délégué du
cabinet conseil profil là vous êtes je
dirais un observateur privilégié puisque
les dossiers vous les voyez tous les
jours alors vous vous dites si une
entreprise aujourd'hui n'anticipe pas ça
valait mal pour elle finalement c'est un
petit peu l'idée que vous souhaitez
faire passer à travers cette table ronde
aujourd'hui alors que je vais étendre
tenter de faire passer effectivement
bonjour à toutes et tous peut-être un
mot sur le cabinet profil on est
également une petite PME une vingtaine
de collaborateurs avec une raison d'être
une croyance au démarrage de de la
structure il y a à peu près 10 ans qu'il
était nécessaire de promouvoir de
nouveaux imaginaires entrepreneuriaux
mettant la question la maximisation du
profit la création de richesse
certains portants mais à côté d'autres
enjeux environnementaux et sociaux et
les premières interventions montrent
qu'évidemment c'est ces imaginaires sont
déjà présents au sein d'un certain
nombre d'entreprises en préparant mon
intervention je me suis assez
naturellement penchée sur le le thème de
cette table ronde donc transition
environnementale comment faire un levier
de compétitivité pour les entreprises je
me suis demandé si ce thème là était
n'était pas plutôt un peu dépassé un peu
obsolète si la question devait encore se
poser en ces termes de différenciation
de compétitivité si de fait cette
transition un environnemental elle était
pas impérieuse pour tout un chacun et
que la question qui se posait c'est ce
qu'elle est la laisse faire de gré ou de
force pour l'ensemble des entreprises et
des acteurs de nos territoires
je crois et le président l'archet l'a
évoqué à l'heure où certaines
entreprises mettent à l'arrêt comme
Duralex mettent à l'arrêt certains fours
de production de verre du fait du coût
de l'énergie trop importante quand
certaines entreprises du fait de tension
sur les matériaux l'acier le bois
connaissent des retards de livraison
importantes et mettent à mal leur
chiffre d'affaires l'organe de commande
quand on voit la flambée des matières
premières agricoles on peut se
questionner si on peut encore parler de
compétitivité il me semble aujourd'hui
que la question qui devrait être
formulée je mets un peu les pieds dans
le plat la question qui devrait être
formulée c'est transition
environnementale n'est-elle pas la
condition et bien la condition à la
pérennité
aux entreprises
bien voilà le décor campé effectivement
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir à leur
Thomas courbe je rappelle directeur
général des entreprises au ministère de
l'économie et des finances on le sait
évidemment la transition énergétique et
déjà à l'oeuvre transition
environnementale écologique quelle
tableaux peignez vous de la situation
aujourd'hui merci bonjour à tous Le
tableau général je pense c'est d'abord
celui en ce début d'année d'une d'un
accroissement de l'ambition européenne
en matière de réduction des émissions de
carbone un accroissement très important
avec le paquet de législation européenne
dit prêt pour -55% qui est une avancée
majeure dans le rehaussement de nos
objectifs ensuite le fait que ce
atteindre cet objectif extrêmement
ambitieux va nécessiter de mobiliser
tout un ensemble d'actions à différents
niveaux on veut d'abord avoir une action
partenariale à travers des feuilles de
route avec les grands secteurs pour
convenir ensemble avec les entreprises
avec chaque filière des moyens concrets
d'atteinte de ces objectifs on l'a déjà
fait avec les quatre principales
filières de l'industrie qui
à L4 représente 80% à peu près des
émissions de l'industrie on continue à
le faire avec les autres et puis on va
on l'étend aussi progressivement aux
autres secteurs autres que l'industrie
pour avoir d'abord une approche
partenariale ensuite et bien convenir de
des feuilles de route réaliste ensuite
on a des actions également à mener sur
le terrain au plus proche des
entreprises pour convaincre chaque
entreprise pour l'accompagner dans dans
la transition c'est notamment le cas
pour les PME qui auquel on veut proposer
une gamme d'accompagnement d'outils qui
vont permettre de mettre en oeuvre très
concrètement cette cette transition et
puis ensuite sur la question qui vient
d'être posée et la question du rapport
entre des car et compétitivité notamment
qui est le sujet de cette table là je
pense qu'il y a il y a deux enjeux et
finalement vous avez dit tous les deux
aspects de la réponse le premier c'est
bien que il y a un impératif de
décarbonation et on l'a adopté au niveau
européen il faut maintenant le mettre en
œuvre et ensuite la question de
permettre cette décarbonation des
entreprises tout en maintenant leur
compétitivité et un impératif et un
impératif qui s'impose tout autant que
celui de réussir la décarbonation et là
on voit qu'il y a plusieurs plusieurs
éléments le premier c'est d'abord des
investissements de bicarbonation qui
sont rentables et donc qui permettent
d'accroître directement le la
compétitivité des entreprises ça on a un
retour d'expérience
utile sur sur ces configurations on a
des investissements qui sont presque
rentables ou pas tout à fait et pour
lequel l'État a mobilisé beaucoup de
moyens dans le plan de relance dans
France 2030 pour finalement apporter
l'aide qui permet d'enclencher ce cet
investissement et de le rendre rentable
on a plus globalement évidemment des des
enjeux le président Larcher la
mentionnée qui des anges simples qui
sont que réindustrialisés c'est
décarbonée on a en France une intensité
par exemple de l'industrie carbone qui
est le quart du reste du monde au CDE
donc tout ce qui est fait en France et
favorable au climat en termes de
réindustrialisation et puis il y a des
évidemment un deuxième volet d'action
qui est tout le cadre réglementaire et
la nécessité que ce cadre réglementaire
soit compatible avec le maintien de la
compétitivité merci Thomas courbe alors
vous restez avec nous bien sûr pour
débattre dans quelques instants et puis
répondre aux questions de l'assistance
le cas échéant Véronique de gotex là on
va rentrer dans la cuisine si vous le
permettez
une entreprise c'est une aventure
humaine ce sont des collaboratrices des
collaborateurs comment ça se passe en
termes de gestion de masse salariale les
objectifs que vous nous avez expliqué
tout à l'heure comment vous gérez ça
avec vos équipes
alors on le gère pardon alors évidemment
comme tout le monde et ça fera partie
peut-être des propositions qu'on
pourrait avoir avec toutes les parties
prenantes on a beaucoup de mal à
recruter alors que les ETI et les PME
ont toutes le potentiel à développer à
développer l'emploi donc ça c'est aussi
un des sujets c'est qu'il y a
l'intention mais après c'est la mise en
oeuvre n'est pas si simple alors on a
cependant réussi en travaillant
localement et en mobilisant les gens sur
le territoire en en faisant des
ambassadeurs en essayant de travailler
le volet social avec une redistribution
alors sans vouloir aborder des sujets
très très parfois sensibles mais en
redistribuant la richesse de
l'entreprise et en la partageant avec
l'ensemble des collaborateurs et un
groupe qui était qui faisait vivre 450
familles parce qu'un collaborateur fait
vivre en partie sa famille on est
maintenant 800 et on est toujours en
phase de croissance et c'est pas croître
pour croître et faire se faire plus gros
que le bœuf pas du tout c'est pour créer
plus économie plus de richesses sur le
territoire faire vivre plus de monde et
de manière saine et puis évidemment il y
a le sujet donc de du volume du nombre
de collaborateurs il y a le sujet aussi
d'adresser la compétence parce que quand
on parle de cette transformation de
l'entreprise et je rejoins tout ce que
vous avez dit d'une nécessité avant nous
dans nos métiers en tout cas qui étaient
fonctionnels esthétique et surtout
économique on est passé face à ces
enjeux climatiques dont on a tous mesuré
les impacts du dérèglement et on est
acculé à réagir aussi on est passé à une
nécessité vitale cependant cette
nécessité vitale elle peut être adressée
avec aussi de l'esthétique et c'est là
où il faut se creuser et de l'innovation
pour en faire un modèle économique
pérenne parce que l'idée c'est on
travaille le durable et moi je rajoute
toujours la performance durable il faut
aussi que nos modèles économiques et que
nos entreprises soient durables et
comment le faire et ben en allant
chercher les compétences alors on les a
pas toujours on essaye les développer en
interne il y a un sujet de formation sur
certains métiers de transformation de
ces métiers avec beaucoup de nouveautés
et puis on va chercher la ressource là
où là où elle est et les idées et on
embauche des gens à haut niveau parfois
parfois
au contraire très terrain mais des gens
en tout cas qui vont avoir une vision
différente qui vont être capable de
piloter des projets différents il faut
oser se remettre en question et comme on
ne peut pas avoir de la R&D à tout va
pour adresser tous ces nouveaux sujets
on va chercher la compétence là où elle
est hier j'étais à station F avec des
startupeurs il y a beaucoup
d'innovations d'un pays qui est riche en
innovation on ne la retient pas toujours
dans les territoires vous avez la
possibilité vous avez la possibilité
vraiment dans le territoire de
travailler avec ces jeunes pousses c'est
start-up comme on dit ça a été un gros
effort de conviction vous avez raison de
le mentionner parce que ces startups
elles ont les idées elles n'ont pas
toujours la maturité managériale que
nous on peut avoir et puis la
structuration donc c'est un bon moteur
et dans l'absolu non le groupe cheval
dans la Drôme on n'attirait pas les
foules c'est clair et du coup il a fallu
séduire attirer alors en disant qu'on a
un beau département mais il y a le
sénateur de la Drôme que je salue mais
qui ne suffit pas donc on a beaucoup
travaillé l'image de l'entreprise la
communication de l'image notamment avec
ce statut de société à mission où on a
communiqué on a fait valoir ce que ça
voulait dire cette responsabilité
sociale et on essaye donc après derrière
de faire des partenariats quand on est
petit on est on est un petit groupe on
est 800 collaborateurs aujourd'hui on
essaie de continuer à croître mais on
reste petit face à tous les enjeux
adressés et bien il faut être encore
plus malin encore plus agile et surtout
en situation de crise on va pas
s'arrêter au milieu du tunnel sinon on
en sortira pas donc on essaye d'avancer
et de trouver les partenariats j'allais
dire pertinent efficace et
gagnant-gagnant mais alors concrètement
pour revenir sur la question de
l'entreprise à mission
détaillez nous un petit peu en quoi
c'est un levier alors deux compétitivité
bien sûr mais un levier d'action
supplémentaire pour vous à travers cette
entreprise à mission comment les
collaborateurs encore une fois j'insiste
sur le côté humain comment intègre-t-il
ce phénomène enfin ce principe alors on
peut maintenant on peut en parler sans
ni voyer aucune aucune arrogance c'est
un partage parce que plus on sera
nombreux à les là dedans et plus on fera
la trace et plus on pourra transformer
c'est pas l'échelle d'une de quelques
entreprises que c'est possible alors
dans un premier temps d'abord c'est un
vrai parcours c'est un vrai
investissement
où on doit transformer en interne
beaucoup de communiquer et embarquer
comme dans toute conduite du changement
une petite partie de collaborateurs
ultra motivée et puis avoir des pilotes
et montrer les effets donc 1 on fait des
choix de travailler très concrètement
localement avec des fournisseurs que
l'on va essayer de choisir en
travaillant sur du du National c'est un
peu protectionniste mais mais voilà on
essaye de tenir la promesse et puis de
faire confiance à ses collaborateurs une
fois qu'on les a embarqués c'est aussi
de travailler main dans la main si
possible avec les clients pour sortir de
la relation juste de vie pris et choix
sur la ligne du bas donc qu'est-ce qu'il
y a d'autres derrière qui peut être mis
en place là aussi en terme de
partenariat il faut démontrer on a passé
la je suis fier de dire qu'on a passé
l'audit c'est plus une validation mais
avec zéro observation dans notre secteur
qui est quand même contraint comme quoi
c'est possible et on embarque et là on
commence à mesurer les effets auprès des
clients auprès des fournisseurs et
surtout auprès des des plus jeunes ou
des candidats qui se sont présentés
venant de de toutes parts on n'aurait
pas imaginé de tout niveau parce qu'on
avait ce statut et que la promesse qui
était derrière c'était que on agissait
comme on le disait il y a les paroles
c'est bien mais ça ne suffit pas donc
aujourd'hui on commence à mesurer des
effets bénéfiques je vais juste prendre
une seconde de plus pour dire que
l'autre est bénéfique et c'est là où
c'est bien d'avoir le lien avec les
instances les gens qui qui décident qui
font les textes et puis les pouvoirs
publics c'est qu'il serait bien qu'on
travaille avec les parties prenantes
parce qu'on travaille encore avec des
normes des réglementations des cahiers
des charges qui sont un peu issus du
passé et sur lesquels il y a pas tous
ces volets clairement c'est en train ça
se transforme
largement bien sûr puisque là on a
justement la puissance publique non non
mais c'est très bien de prendre de
prendre le temps et de bien expliquer
les choses que l'on va approfondir
d'ailleurs alors Catherine garniou vous
nous expliquez votre problématique tout
à l'heure donc la PME qui a décidé sa
propre transition écologique je dirais
quels sont les premiers résultats si on
dresse un bilan votre action aujourd'hui
alors vous allez parler bilan
énergétique les locaux la production etc
quel est le résultat aujourd'hui
alors on est au début de notre travail
disons que le résultat déjà c'est une
culture d'entreprise il faut déjà à
culturer l'ensemble des collaborateurs à
comprendre pourquoi on va vers cette
transition écologique et je rejoins tout
à fait ce que disait Vincent c'est qu'en
fait c'est une on peut pas passer à côté
de ça en fait et donc notre première
action ça a été en tout cas de faire
notre fresque du climat pour embarquer
le plus grand nombre d'une façon facile
rapide et efficace parce que le monde de
la PME c'est ça en fait il faut qu'on
soit efficace il faut qu'on soit rapide
il faut qu'on ait des résultats la
première chose que l'on a fait au niveau
de notre bâtiment on a fait notre bilan
énergétique donc c'est concret on a su
exactement comment on consommait
60 54% étaient dédiés à l'usage des
locaux et 46% dédiés à la fabrication en
tant que tel donc à partir de là on a vu
différents scénarios donc on a été aidé
grâce à aux énergéticiens avec lesquels
on a travaillé et donc ça nous a permis
de se dire comment on va établir notre
plan d'action donc en fait on fait un
phasage de de travaux donc on a commencé
cette année par l'isolation de la
toiture voilà je vous dévoile tout en
fait de comment nous sommes pris et on a
changé par exemple tous les néons en LED
alors ça semble comme ça vous en aviez
combien il y en a 80 à peu près donc
vous avez le nombre
précisé
quoi c'est moi qui signe les factures
donc derrière je sais exactement ce que
ce que je paye donc voilà on change tout
ça et en fait l'impact sur la première
phase déjà on l'a fait juste avant l'été
et nous on a besoin de travailler dans
un milieu qui est tempéré déjà pour la
matière et puis surtout pour les
collaborateurs on va pas travailler
surtout quand il faisait 40 degrés à
l'extérieur vous pensez bien dans un
atelier de production on peut vite
monter en température et bien là
concrètement on avait un confort un
confort un rafraîchissement de l'atelier
avant il fallait souvent que je mette en
route la clim pendant une nuit et donc
c'était de la consommation et bien là en
deux heures de temps j'ai 1000 m² de
locaux qui sont rafraîchis donc c'est du
pratico-pratique c'est du concret je
consomme moins et j'apporte vraiment un
confort de travail à mes collaborateurs
j'ai même été obligé d'éteindre un
moment la clim parce que je me suis
quand ils vont sortir dehors ils vont
avoir froid donc chaud plutôt donc vous
voyez un peu le le voilà c'est des
résultats concrets ensuite bien entendu
on travaille aussi sur la matière parce
que la matière on en parlait les
ressources elles sont de moins en moins
présentes et donc on s'est dit comment
allons-nous faire donc on a on travaille
en fait sur le Lean Management je pense
que vous en avez entendu parler on
rationalise en fait et on essaye du coup
de consommer moins donc ça c'est aussi
très important par rapport à notre
impact carbone on est bien bien entendu
en train de faire notre bilan carbone ce
copain SCOP 2 escope 3 parce qu'il faut
bien entendu voir l'environnement aussi
dans lequel on travaille
des équipes amateurs vous vous allez
chercher des compétences à l'extérieur
parce que je vais dire il y a un coup
quand même tout ça pour une PME c'était
énorme quand on est 12 clairement vous
n'avez pas forcément les compétences en
interne donc il faut savoir bien
s'accompagner donc au niveau du Lean
management on est accompagné par un
consultant
qui qui nous ça fait un an et demi à peu
près qu'on a une formation de l'ensemble
des équipes donc ça aussi c'est
important c'est tout le monde doit être
formé c'est pas uniquement la direction
c'est à tous les niveaux de l'entreprise
au niveau du bilan énergétique nous
avons payé notre bilan énergétique parce
que même s'il y a beaucoup d'aides qui
sont données pour ma part je trouve que
les dossiers sont beaucoup trop
fastidieux et donc je n'ai pas trop de
temps à perdre à remplir des dossiers
parce que mon temps est limité et de ce
fait j'ai préféré investir et me dire je
paye mon bilan énergétique j'ai
également un accompagnement sur le bilan
carbone que je finance aussi à 100% et
des ordres de grandeur le bilan
énergétique il faut compter 5000 euros
pour notre structure le bilan carbone à
peu près la même chose et
lean a été pris en charge à 100% par
notre eau donc bien entendu qui est
constructif dans le domaine du bâtiment
donc bien entendu en fait on fait appel
aussi aux ressources que l'on a autour
de nous Fédération française du bâtiment
CPME qui m'accompagnent en fait dans à
rencontrer les bons les bons
interlocuteurs et par rapport à notre
RSE puisqu'on a aussi nos engagements
qu'on souhaite vraiment formaliser on
est en train de se lancer dans une
labellisation qui est bicorp donc c'est
une labellisation qui quand même est
structurante qui demande beaucoup pour
une petite structure comme nous et donc
on a aussi un l'accompagnement qui est
de l'ordre à peu près de 10000 euros
c'est aussi beaucoup de temps j'imagine
pour les collaborateurs et pour la
patronne que vous êtes oui c'est
beaucoup de temps surtout que je suis
conseillère environnement au Conseil
économique social environnemental donc
ça me prend la bonne nouvelle ça me
prend aussi beaucoup de temps
et c'est pour ça aussi que les
collaborateurs il est important de les
impliquer parce que forcément ça me
prend du temps mais ça leur prend
également du temps mais si tout le monde
est conscient et comprend pourquoi il
fait les choses parce que le tout c'est
de donner du sens si on impose les
choses sans donner du sens et je rejoins
ce que disait Véronique par rapport à
l'entreprise la mission c'est ça aussi
derrière c'est c'est en fait on les
emmène et du coup ils sont tous moteur
et quand vous avez 12 collaborateurs qui
sont moteurs qui se disent on sait
pourquoi on fait ça pour nos familles
parce que pour l'entreprise mais c'est
aussi pour nos familles pour notre futur
et bien sincèrement ça se fait j'ai
envie de dire dans la bonne humeur
c'est parfait j'imagine que vous aurez
aussi des propositions à formuler tout à
l'heure un peu comme Véronique de gotex
vous avez abordé la sensible aux
questions de la simplification
administrative et des démarches je crois
que le terme va revenir beaucoup dans
nos dialogues Vincent wissner donc je
disais ce cabinet conseil tous les jours
vous voyez ces dossiers et vous
accompagner les entreprises alors dans
la droite ligne de Catherine de guernoud
est-ce qu'on peut bon là on était dans
le cas de la PME vous accompagnez des
groupes plus importants est-ce que la
problématique est la même finalement
quels sont les résultats pour les
entreprises qui s'y sont mis
alors la promette problématique
évidemment pas la même je dirais pas que
l'une est plus facile que l'autre en
tout cas les deux suffisent à leur peine
nous on travaille essentiellement avec
des PME et des ETI parce qu'on estime
notamment que à partir du moment où on
peut avoir un accès plus facile au
actionnaires on a un pouvoir de
transformation de l'entreprise qui est
beaucoup plus importante travailler avec
des entreprises côté rend la chose la
transformation beaucoup plus complexe
que que ça ne l'est avec avec d'autres
types de d'actionnaires parce que les
actionnaires regardent un peu plus près
freinent un peu sur les investissements
nécessaires parce que nécessairement il
y a un émettement de la décision qui
rend évidemment plus complexe
l'alignement
globale de de l'actionnariat vers une
réelle transformation du modèle
économique des modes de gouvernance du
partage de la valeur qu'on évoquait un
peu en filigrane à l'instant
j'aimerais juste rebondir sur ce qui est
voté ce qui évoqué madame de gotex
aujourd'hui on a à peu près 800 ou 900
entreprises qui sont engagées dans une
transformation en société à mission
telle que imaginez au travers de la loi
pacte alors évidemment c'est une
certaine manière une paille au regard de
du nombre d'entreprises que qu'on compte
en France mais pour autant la dynamique
est là et je voudrais vraiment
essayer de vous faire percevoir la
différence entre l'engagement vers une
politique de RSE et l'engagement vers
une transformation en société à mission
l'engagement va une politique de RSE
pour moi ça renvoie une approche de RSE
normative c'est une manière de montrer
patte blanche sur un certain nombre
d'aspects l'engagement vers une société
enfin une transformation sociétale
mission on se donne véritablement d'une
boussole stratégique
l'idée indépendamment des actions que
vous pouvez mettre en place
indépendamment des actions très
prosaïques mais qui ont leur importance
ça permet d'aligner l'ensemble des
composantes de votre entreprise vers un
dessin vers une mission vers une raison
d'être que vous vous êtes
assigné et je crois que ça c'est
véritablement important et
indépendamment des actions qui vont qui
vont évidemment c'est important en
termes de contribution des entreprises
aux enjeux environnementaux et sociaux
ça permet véritablement de commencer à
vous inscrire dans un modèle contributif
dans un modèle d'affaires contributif et
ça me paraît essentiel au regard des
enjeux qu'on a rappelé
une fois que j'ai dit ça et puis parce
qu'il est plus vraiment l'heure d'être
pessimiste voilà on peut quand même
mettre en avant un certain nombre de
d'entreprises qui ont fait un véritable
tournant qui sont sortis de cette
logique du tout volumes de la croissance
à tout crin de la croissance pour la
croissance comme vous voulez vous
l'évoquez on peut citer des noms voilà
on est entre nous donc il y a aucun
problème je citerai trois noms peut-être
que vous connaissez probablement assez
bien qui sont
plutôt relativement connus la première
c'est l'enseigne de jardinage qui
s'appelle botanique très présente dans
le Grand Est en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
peut-être un peu moins dans les régions
de l'Ouest qui depuis quasiment 20 ans
en tout cas une bonne quinzaine d'années
à véritablement enclenché un vrai
Tournon de son modèle économique en
supprimant l'ensemble des pesticides ou
des engrais de synthèse de de ces
produits l'entreprise c'est également
engagée dans la volonté de de développer
certaines de valorisation une recyclage
notamment des peaux horticole en faisant
de cette filière d'une certaine manière
un nouveau relais de croissance pour
pour la structure et puis elle s'est
engagée pour maîtriser davantage chez
les dépenses énergétiques qui sont
relativement importantes au regard du du
nombre de magasins et des serres école
dont elle disposent dans une chasse ou
gaspillage énergétique mais qui date
bien d'avant la crise énergétique que
l'on connaît avec également la volonté
d'équiper d'équiper ces bâtiments d'un
certain nombre de panneaux
photovoltaïques pour être sur des
logiques d'autoconsommation d'auto
d'auto-production mais ça finalement une
entreprise d'une taille inférieure peut
le faire finalement c'est ça demande de
la volonté à quelques moyens mais non ça
demande nécessairement quelques moyens
évidemment le coûtait ce n'est pas la
hauteur de tout le monde vous voulez
dire c'est pas ce que je dis je pense
que ça renvoie davantage et surtout à
une vision et un courage entrepreneurial
ou en tout cas à une vision un rapport
aux outils de contrôle de gestion à la à
ce qu'on met derrière le terme de profit
un petit peu différent je pense qu'on a
besoin et ça ça fait peut-être un peu
écho en tout cas c'est comme ça que je
traduis certains thèmes qui étaient
utilisés dans la vidéo
précédente pour moi on a besoin de
changer d'alphabet comptable
il est essentiel important de compter ce
qui compte vraiment
autrement dit de changer un peu de
système d'information et de gestion de
nos entreprises et ça ça me paraît
relativement essentiel alors je vais pas
vous parler de comptabilité
multicapitaux je pense que c'est encore
relativement récent un peu difficile à
éprouver je suis pas certain
qu'aujourd'hui les méthodes
véritablement sont à mettre à la entre
les mains de tous mais en tout cas il y
a un enjeu à penser certains
investissements de manière différente
telle qu'aujourd'hui
on les imagine avec un besoin de retour
sur investissement de court terme alors
il y a d'autres exemples vous me situez
celui de Darty notamment Darty donc du
groupe Fnac Darty vous connaissez tous a
mis en place il y a peut-être trois
quatre ans un système d'abonnement
visant à lutter contre l'obsolescence
programmée des produits électroménager
alors évidemment on reste sur une part
encore mineur de leur chiffre d'affaires
pour autant c'est
l'essentiel de leur relais de croissance
aujourd'hui avec évidemment l'enjeu de
digitalisation d'un certain nombre de
leurs services donc c'est un exemple
Décathlon est un autre bon exemple ils
font le tournant ils ont beaucoup
communiqué ces derniers jours sur leur
volonté de s'engager vers une stratégie
d'économie circulaire la volonté d'aller
davantage vers l'économie de la
fonctionnalité davantage de location
d'équipements d'équipements de camping
de vélo de développer des ateliers de
réparation de proposer des des produits
de seconde main etc etc ce sont des
exemples il y en a bien d'autres dans
des produits cosmétiques dans d'autres
types de secteurs que ce soit lié voir
l'entreprise sceptique et probablement
un acteur que vous connaissez qui ont
véritablement questionné leur modèle
économique leur modèle d'affaires de la
conception à la commercialisation et
encore une fois avec cette volonté de
sortir du tout volumes du tout croissant
en faisant fi des enjeux
environnementaux et sociaux ce sont des
exemples très précis et très précieux
effectivement qui illustre bien notre
problématique alors Thomas courbe
[Musique]
la transition énergétique on a vu vous
nous l'expliquait tout à l'heure est
déjà à l'oeuvre là on vient de voir des
exemples que peuvent faire concrètement
les entreprises pour gagner en
compétitivité en contribuant justement à
la transition environnementale et
écologique
alors il y a effectivement plusieurs
plusieurs niveaux d'action le premier
qui est très général c'est qu'une partie
de l'investissement productif de la
modernisation de l'outil de production
l'animé la numérisation sont des
éléments qui en général favorisent la
décarbonation puisque les équipements
modernisés en général des bilans
meilleurs le deuxième c'est
de s'engager justement dans un plan
d'efficacité énergétique et on a de ce
point de vue un exemple très concret qui
fonctionne très bien qui est le
diagnostic ecoflux réalisé par BPI et
l'ADEME et qui donne des très bons
résultats
94% de taux de satisfaction un gain une
rentabilité de l'investissement au bout
de trois ans en moyenne et à partir de 3
ans en moyenne 45000 euros des bits de
2BE générés par ce diagnostic donc ça
c'est des mesures dans toute la partie
efficacité énergétique qui sont
rapidement efficaces qui nécessitent
effectivement un investissement au début
mais qui sera finement efficace
évidemment dans le contexte actuel des
prix de énergie ils le sont encore plus
ensuite et ça rejoint ce qui a été dit
par Monsieur wissner c'est on peut avoir
aussi des entreprises qui ont une
démarche de décarbonation qui n'est pas
nécessairement mue par des objectifs de
compétitivité ou en tout cas pas de
compétitivité prix on a l'exemple et
c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur la relocalisation c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises relocalisent alors dans le
plan de relance on a financé 700 projets
de relocalisation en France
on a par exemple les bottes aigles qui
relocalisent en France dans une logique
de décarbonation de valorisation de
leurs produits de responsabilité de
l'entreprise d'image de leurs produits
et ça ça peut être aussi un vecteur
évidemment très important notamment dans
les biens de consommation et puis le
dernier élément c'est c'est toute cette
partie de projet qui ne génère pas
directement de gains de compétitivité
mais dont l'entreprise se saisit parce
qu'elle veut participer à cette à cette
et que l'État aide en finançant une
partie de l'investissement on l'a fait
pour 200 projets à peu près dans France
relance on va le refaire dans France
2030 avec 5 milliards d'euros en tout de
crédit dédiés à
en fait permettre que ces projets se
réalisent et donc en les mettant à
l'équilibre grâce au financement et donc
on a toutes ces catégories de situations
dans lesquelles les entreprises peuvent
à la fois participer à cet effort de
décarbonation et en même temps améliorer
ou en tout cas ne pas dégrader leur
compétitivité alors on va voir ce qu'on
peut faire de plus mais je vois votre
voisine qui est en train de de réagir
bon là on débat évidemment rien n'est
préparé en amont vous n'êtes pas
forcément d'accord avec ce que dit
Monsieur courbes
effectivement qui est un qui est un très
bon mécanisme mais qui est pour les plus
de 20 salariés donc en fait je peux pas
en bénéficier donc c'est toujours le
problème des seuils donc
je peux pas bénéficier parce que j'ai
plus de 10 je peux pas bénéficier parce
que j'ai moins de 20
donc en fait je suis vraiment au mauvais
endroit donc d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé à
Bruno Le Maire lors des Assises du
bâtiment je lui dis qu'est-ce que je
fais est-ce que je repasse sous la barre
des 10 par exemple pour avoir le
bouclier énergie ou voilà je voyais
c'est c'est il faut arrêter les seuils
enfin si on veut faire une transition
efficace arrêtons les seuils ça c'est
fini les seuils enfin c'est voyez on va
on va nous mettre dans une salle là
alors enfin voilà c'est
Véronique Véronique de gotex est
visiblement un peu sur la même ligne en
tant que chef d'entreprise
mais on est toujours alors c'est pour ça
que je rejoins le un club le club été de
la région mais aussi le mais aussi
pardon le métier pour être un peu plus
fort parce qu'on était toujours les les
etines étaient pas reconnus il y avait
les petites les grandes maintenant c'est
fait ça a changé mais c'est pareil nous
on ne rentre jamais dans les appels à
projets on ne rentre soit c'est parce
que on prend que notre petite entité la
filiale soit c'est parce qu'on nous
considère comme un groupe donc du coup
on est toujours en dehors des clous
c'est marrant je reconnais un petit peu
aussi les situations personnelles
parfois de collaborateurs qui ne rentre
dans aucune case et qui sont toujours
exclues des dispositifs donc ça c'est je
vous rejoins c'est vrai à tous niveaux
donc oui on existe et oui on a la
capacité toutes ces petites moyennes
grandes etc bref les entreprises du
territoire français on a la capacité à
développer à faire vivre mais il faut
qu'on se mobilise tous ensemble je vais
profiter et vous m'arrêter quand vous
voulez hein sinon c'est je ne change pas
de sujet on reste sur le même parce
qu'après ça va partir dans tous les
jours
c'est parce que enfin j'allais rebondir
sur les toutes les mesures au-delà du
diagnostic flux de BPI c'est que après
bah quand on ne peut pas bénéficier
d'aide ou de soutien on le fait par
nous-mêmes et on embarque alors les
collaborateurs et je vous rejoins on les
embarque donc on a fait toute une
démarche projet qu'on a démultiplié avec
les collaborateurs pour créer et il y a
eu plein d'idées d'une part on a
transformé c'est pour revenir sur les
livrets transformations donc on
transforme les flottes en véhicule
hybride ou électrique mais aussi les
poids lourds avec du gaz vert et on va
faire nos stations et la production
alors c'est pas de la grosse rentabilité
c'est même pas de rentabilité du tout
c'est de l'investissement mais c'est la
préparation du du futur on a acheté des
doudounes pour baisser la température
d'abord sur le terrain ils en ont donc
on a dit bah les gars du bureau c'est
pareil on a des doudounes sans manche et
on n'a pas copié le gouvernement on
l'avait fait avant
on a mis des plateaux repas il y a plein
de petites mesures pour que les
collaborateurs ne prennent pas leur
voiture et ne gâchis pas des sens etc
très important je vous relancerai tout à
l'heure sur la question des jeunes parce
que moi vous avez beaucoup de choses à
nous dire là-dessus je reviens à Thomas
Cook qui effectivement a eu raison de se
déplacer aujourd'hui donc la parole est
à la défense la parole à la défense par
rapport à ce que disait madame garniou
par exemple sur le sur les effets de
seuil mais sur les effets de ça je pense
il y a quand même deux sujets différents
il y a il y a les seuils et là on
évoquait la loi pacte tout à l'heure qui
ont quand même permis de beaucoup
avancer sur ce sujet même si il en reste
mais on a on a quand même beaucoup
simplifié et puis ensuite la question
des des aides c'est je pense moi une
question de seuil qu'une question de
de capacité d'action et là on se rejoint
il y a 2 millions d'entreprises en
France qu'il faut emmener dans la
transition écologique donc évidemment on
va pas faire des diagnostics ecoflux
pour 2 millions d'entreprises mais il
faut avoir des solutions adaptées pour
chaque catégorie d'entreprise adaptée à
ses besoin à sa taille et à l'enjeu de
simplicité qui est essentielle et et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de
construire dans la planification
écologique c'est de réussir à passer de
beaucoup d'actions qui ont été menées
actuellement on accompagne président
Larcher à cité tout à l'heure le réseau
des CCI qui est notre partenaire pour
accompagner 20 000 entreprises dans la
transition écologique donc on a déjà un
effet un effort de volume il reste
encore beaucoup à faire pour passer à
l'échelle et c'est l'un des enjeux et
cette question sur les seuils je pense
c'est plutôt la question de comment dans
la transition écologique on passe à
l'échelle pour offrir finalement à toute
entreprise en fonction de ses besoins
des solutions simples et accessibles
donc vous porterez la nouvelle la parole
à Bercy vous défendrait le dossier on
compte sur vous alors Thomas court
toujours un peu dans le même esprit
d'ailleurs les incitations du marché de
l'énergie ne se fieront peut-être pas
finalement à atteindre les objectifs de
la transition écologique comment on peut
aller plus loin con disant qu'elles sont
qu'est-ce qui est dans les tuyaux
aujourd'hui à vos niveaux pour pour
booster alors toujours plus loin
évidemment sans pénaliser les
entreprises comme on vient de le voir
alors il y a d'abord des évolutions
réglementaires importantes j'évoquais le
fait pendant la présidence française de
l'Union européenne on a mis en œuvre un
certain nombre de nouvelles
réglementations qui vont permettre
d'orienter cette transition écologique
des entreprises on a des sujets vous
l'avez vu dans les dernières décennies
on a une partie de la décarbonation qui
s'est fait par la délocalisation et ça
on veut évidemment ce qu'on appelle les
flux de carbone on veut évidemment
l'empêcher et de ce point de vue le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières qui a été décidée pendant la
présidence française est un mécanisme
qui doit permettre progressivement
d'abord pour cinq secteurs et puis
ensuite en l'étendant d'éviter ces
situations
et donc les fuites de carbone et
finalement restaurer des conditions de
compétition égales entre les entreprises
européennes qui font des efforts très
importants on ne le dit pas assez
de l'Union européenne est quand même
l'ensemble qui fait les efforts les plus
importants pour la décarbonation les
entreprises européennes sont très loin
devant toutes les autres pour la
décarbonation et donc il faut garder un
traitement équitable avec les
entreprises non-européennes donc ça
c'est l'une des finalités du mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone on a également
pendant un président françaises mis en
œuvre ou lancer de nouvelles
réglementations sur l'éco-conception
pour avoir plus de dès la conception des
produits plus de prise en compte des
enjeux environnementaux c'est l'une des
manières aussi de répondre à ces sujets
et puis toujours dans l'idée de de
lutter contre une concurrence qui serait
déloyable sur le plan environnemental on
a initié une démarche qui doit permettre
que progressivement les produits qui
entrent sur le marché européen
bénéficient d'une évaluation
environnementale et que cette évaluation
environnementale puisse conduire à une
différenciation on l'a fait c'est un cas
sur les batteries de véhicules
électriques vous savez qu'on
réindustrialise l'Europe en termes de
batterie de véhicules électriques en
parallèle on a négocier pendant la
présidence française un règlement qui va
faire qu'à partir de 2027 les batteries
dont la production aura émis beaucoup de
carbone seront interdites en Europe et
donc en particulier un certain nombre de
batterie asiatique alors là on est dans
les dans les outils à proprement parler
il y a la France la dimension européenne
pardon Vincent Wisner est-ce que les
outils de gestion dont disposent
aujourd'hui les entreprises permettent
de faire les choix effectivement dont on
parle aujourd'hui à moyen terme et puis
surtout dans l'intérêt collectif est-ce
que la batterie d'outils est-ce que la
boîte à outils est complète aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors si tu me veste question
je dirais évidemment non enfin complète
pas par son par l'absence d'outils mais
peut-être par une une bataille qui n'est
toujours pas
terminée entre différentes structures de
standardisation
des normes comptables et en particulier
d'énormes extra-financières il existe
pas aujourd'hui pour les entreprises
qui sont à l'international il n'existe
pas aujourd'hui de normes irrs
extra-financière
et je pense que il est nécessaire
dans disposer de façon à être réellement
en capacité encore une fois de disposer
de d'outils de gestion pour reprendre
votre terme qui permettent de valoriser
également les engagements
environnementaux sociétaux des
entreprises de faire des choix tout ça
et de faire des choix en conscience et
en conséquence
aujourd'hui il existe un certain nombre
de référentiel de belle
il n'a pas été arrêté ni à l'échelle
européenne ni à l'échelle internationale
un référentiel qui véritablement
permettrait aux entreprises que vous
représentez de en toute sécurité de
travailler à l'international ou en tout
cas de faire valoir un international un
certain nombre de vos choix stratégiques
entre
l'Algérie le CSRD
le CD SD l'ISO 26000 et je pourrais en
donner encore davantage on est encore
dans un dans un flou qui ne permet pas
aux entreprises mais quelle qu'elle soit
et encore moins a fortiori au PME et TPE
de de s'engager assez fermement vers une
orientation et vers des investissements
allant dans ce sens
voilà il y a encore une fois je pense
que si l'Europe peut évidemment se
targuer d'être en avance je pense que au
travers notamment des travaux de
l'ephrague mais qu'on attend encore
aujourd'hui
mais qui devrait sortir dans les deux
trois prochaines années
elle ne pourra pas évidemment
travailler dans son coin d'autant plus
pour des entreprises qui encore une fois
une ambition de travailler à
l'international alors justement réaction
des chefs d'entreprise autour de cette
table Catherine garnioud votre réaction
alors à la boîte à outils là que
j'évoquais à l'instant est-ce que vous
vous estimez vous-même avoir tout ce
qu'il faut pour prendre les bonnes
décisions au bon moment et anticiper les
choix
[Musique]
déjà en train de me dire il va falloir
que je change mon économie on est tous
sur une économie de volumes en fait
aujourd'hui et il faut qu'on soit sur
une économie à impact quand on parle un
pacte c'est à dire que on doit avoir les
choses différemment en se disant ben
comment je vais réduire certes on
parlait de notre énergie on parlait et
réduire les émissions de CO2 je voulais
pas dit mais avec mes scénarios par
exemple je vais réduire de 15%
l'émission énergie et de 45% nos
émissions de CO2 donc c'est vraiment
efficace mais il faut aller encore au
delà aujourd'hui on en parlait vous
savez peut-être entendu ce matin à
France Inter il parlait de la
biodiversité il y a un rapport de WWF
qui vient de sortir c'est une
catastrophe donc il faut aussi qu'on
intègre dans nos entreprises justement
ces enjeux de biodiversité Véronique la
la dit justement
et par exemple vous voyez dans ma phase
2 de rénovation des bâtiments je vais
intégrer la récupération de l'eau
l'autre je pense qu'il y a plein de
ressources en fait que l'on a et qu'on
n'utilise pas qu'on ne s'est pas utilisé
mais c'est vrai que par rapport à tous
les dispositifs je pense qu'on est
encore perdu c'est pour ça qu'il faut
simplifier c'est pour ça je le redis il
faut arrêter ces seuils il faut vraiment
que ça devienne quelque chose que ça
soit fluide or qu'aujourd'hui une PME
quand on nous parle des enjeux européens
on en est bien conscient mais si vous
voulez dans notre quotidien on les a pas
quand on travaille sur le territoire
français on les a pas forcément
on les manipule pas mais c'est vrai que
par exemple sur tout ce qui est matière
de recyclage je m'aperçois que il y a
pas un endroit comptable où on peut le
valoriser donc le plan comptable par
exemple n'est pas du tout adapté
aux investissements que l'on fait
régulièrement la compta me dit ah bah
oui mais alors là vous êtes partis sur
un truc je sais pas où le mettre bah oui
mais en même temps c'est quand même de
nos entreprises donc il y a vraiment en
fait toute une culture il y a tout un
c'est systémique en fait et c'est pour
ça quand on fait notre bilan carbone il
faut pas simplement s'arrêter à sa
propre production il faut aussi voir
l'écosystème qu'on a autour de nous et
en fait on s'aperçoit que l'écosystème
il est dur à bouger donc c'est c'est et
je l'état bien entendu doit nous
accompagner mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est aussi à nous de nous transformer
ça nous le monde de l'entreprise et je
rejoins mes collègues il y a des
innovations qui sont magnifiques et je
pense qu'on a vraiment de belles années
devant nous il faut arrêter le le côté
défaitiste bien que pourtant entre la
grève du carburant et puis j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une grève qui va
aussi se qui s'annonce pour la semaine
prochaine le quotidien est dur le
quotidien il dure parce que on a des
augmentations de matière mais justement
je pense qu'il faut continuer à faire
face et alors peut-être que je suis
peut-être un peu boostée à la transition
écologique c'est possible mais je suis
pas dans un monde de bisounours voilà je
vis au quotidien dans mon entreprise et
et justement il faut simplifier au
maximum de façon à ce qu'on embarque le
plus grand nombre de d'entreprises et
d'entrepreneurs c'est bien d'être dopé à
la transition écologique c'est
l'actualité
Véronique de gotex vous êtes dans la
même configuration là encore une fois je
m'adresse à la chef d'entreprise vous
partagez ce que Madame vient nous vient
de nous expliquer complètement et puis
en passant quand on veut faire de la RSE
ou société à mission et puis on ne fait
qu'anticiper ce qui nous attend là avec
la taxonomie et tout le reporting
extra-financier et si on veut piloter se
donner des objectifs aux mesurer si on
mesure pas on peut pas le piloter sauf
que pour le mesurer il faut que ce soit
prévu et les systèmes d'information
effectivement les très grandes peuvent
se doter de de système de pilotage donc
nous on est en train de transformer mais
c'est encore une fois c'est un surcoût
j'ai même pas envie de dire que c'est un
investissement parce que c'est vraiment
pour satisfaire à des exigences et à du
pilotage donc autant souvent je vois le
côté investissement là c'est un simple
surcoût alors on va le faire parce que
on est de bons élèves et surtout des
responsables qui se sentent concernés
mais il y a un vrai sujet là-dessus et
là non plus il y a pas de dispositif on
n'est pas en train de réclamer des aides
partout mais par exemple sur il y aurait
peut-être des mesures c'est peut-être
pas le moment
il y aurait peut-être des mesures très
très simples c'est d'encourager bah
voilà si on disait tout ce si on se
lance là dedans pas grave pas grave il
m'attaque à l'eau
c'est peut-être de dire ben on va
baisser certaines taxes pour encourager
certaines initiatives sur des des
investissements comme ça sur des
investissements vers des mais vraiment
je parle d'investissement qui touche à
cette transition qui nous est chère on
entend et qui nous échappera tous si
vous êtes là c'est que oui il y a la
transmission aussi qui a un sujet qui
concerne tout le monde monde mais mais
on est aussi mobilisé par cette
transition donc on veut faire des
investissements mais je vais prendre un
exemple tout simple vous les transformez
vos véhicules au gaz ça coupe en te 30 à
40% plus cher qu'un véhicule normal qui
coûte déjà assez cher donc comment on
fait alors on n'est pas quémander des
des subventions mais si éventuellement
mettez en place des systèmes pour
encourager ça de suramortissement majeur
sur des périodes par exemple de deux ans
ont sur amorti en deux ans comme ça il y
a que ceux qui ont investissent qui en
bénéficient c'est pas de l'argent qui
est distribué et de ses prix sur le
résultat et la fiscalité c'est un gain
pour l'entreprise et ça veut dire que on
a créé de la valeur puisque c'est pris
sur ça un impact sur le résultat fiscal
donc il y a des surement des moyens si
on réfléchit ensemble on est pratico
pratique nous les responsables
d'entreprises on a comme vous disiez
Catherine on voit les factures on voit
tout passer on voit les salaires et on
préfère
peut-être certaines actions sur les
collaborateurs plutôt que sur des
systèmes d'information qui finalement
plus efficaces et plus pragmatique
finalement catherine gariau est ensuite
on donne la parole à Thomas courbe oui
moi je suis je suis entièrement d'accord
je pense que par exemple le crédit
d'impôt c'est quelque chose de
d'efficace et rapide parce que toutes
les aides les ecoflu et tout ce que tout
le dispositif qui est mis en place bon
vous avez compris je peux pas y
bénéficier mais il y en a d'autres ce
sont des dossiers qui faut remplir alors
en plus quand vous rentrez dans le
dossier vous en avez à peu près pour une
heure une heure et demie si toutefois
vous avez le téléphone qui sonne et que
vous êtes dérangé parce que vous devez
faire autre chose et bien tout ce que
vous avez donné comme données et perdu
donc vous devez reprendre sincèrement au
bout d'un moment qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous le faites vous-même or que
et donc c'est de l'argent qui est mis de
côté apparemment il y a des sommes
faramineuses de de on entend de millions
et ainsi de suite alors que il serait
beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup plus
efficace de faire un crédit d'impôt sur
présentation des factures avec bien
entendu des gens qui sont homologués
pour faire des des commandes des bilans
énergétiques des bilans carbone enfin ça
on a aussi tout ce qu'il faut au niveau
batterie homologation et et donc ça
serait efficace rapide et on
s'embêterait pas je voulais pas dire un
autre terme on s'embêterait pas en fait
à faire des dossiers à non plus finir et
c'est ça que les entreprises on n'a pas
le temps de le faire on n'a pas la
ressource en interne pour le faire ou si
on l'a c'est quand même des beaucoup
plus grosses structures que en tout cas
que moi mon entreprise et je pense que
on est beaucoup à le vivre en fait et ça
c'est efficace c'est rapide et un gain
de temps un gain de temps considérable
Thomas courtes c'est vrai que la
simplification administrative on en
parle depuis des années et on voit que
bon bah sur le terrain chez les
principaux acteurs c'est loin d'être une
réalité ou parliez tout à l'heure de la
dimension européenne de l'action mais
tout ça c'est pas au niveau européen
c'est au niveau français qu'est-ce que
l'État français lui sans aller à
Bruxelles
encore mettre en oeuvre pour simplifier
est-ce qu'il y a une réelle volonté de
le faire ou oui et qu'est-ce qui est
dans les tuyaux
je crois qu'on a des résultats le sujet
c'est
si on entre un peu dans le détail parce
que sur le on est là pour ça sur les
outils sur les outils financiers on a un
sur amortissement ou des crédits
d'impôts qui en fait dans récemment
donne des des résultats variables on a
fait par exemple en 2018 un crédit
d'impôt pour la numérisation des
entreprises qui nous semblaient répondre
à un enjeu il y a eu extrêmement peu de
demandes on l'a arrêté parce qu'il y
avait peu de demandes parce que vous
avez tout à fait raison le crédit
d'impôt des avantages il a aussi des
inconvénients c'est que pour le chef
d'entreprise qui investit il a pas une
visibilité immédiate sur le résultat et
le résultat financier est souvent
différé par par construction donc il y a
des avis un peu partagés sur ces sujets
sur les le suramment on a soit des
dispositifs très transversaux mais qui
sont extrêmement coûteux pour les
finances publiques
et si ils sont ciblés ils deviennent là
aussi assez complexe à justifier parce
qu'il faut justifier il y a un travail
du coup de justification des factures de
de l'expert comptable oui mais ça peut
être efficace mais ça n'est pas non plus
dénué de complexité donc c'est
simplement pour montrer que et à
contrario j'évoquais le diagnostic
ecophiles c'est un exemple qui est connu
donc je j'y reviens pour un diagnostic
ecophile il y a pas de dossier complexe
c'est une démarche très simple à mettre
en oeuvre et ce dont on parle d'ailleurs
c'est à la fois des accompagnements et
ces accompagnements ils sont justement
il y a pas de il y a pas de dossier
complexe pour un accompagnement et c'est
même on va vers les entreprises pour
leur proposer des accompagnements et là
c'est plutôt des prestations de type
consultants qui aident à l'entreprise à
exactement comme vous l'avez très bien
décrit on propose des choses
équivalentes et là c'est très simple et
c'est au contraire c'est au contraire
c'est c'est même plus qu'une démarche de
simplification c'est à dire qu'on va
vers l'entreprise en lui proposant un
consultant qui va l'aider à faire par
exemple un plan d'efficacité énergétique
ou de ou de décarbonation et puis sur
les aides c'est ce que j'évoquais c'est
que il faut il faut trouver les
dispositifs il y a beaucoup de
dispositifs on essaie de simplifier en
permanence on a besoin
quand une situation des finances
publiques que les aides soient ciblées
sur des finalités donc nécessairement il
faut y associer des justifications par
l'entreprise et il y a un peu cette
contradiction apparente entre le fait
d'avoir des aides ciblés et donc
justifier et l'objectif de simplicité
c'est ça qu'on essaye de
se faire quoi on essaie de converger en
tout cas je vois la conclusion de l'une
des conclusions de nos discussions c'est
que on a besoin de tout se parler les
uns les autres vraiment c'est une chaîne
ininterrompue de de discussion on le
verra également tout à l'heure vous
parliez de la taxonomie Véronique de
gotex peut-être un petit point sur sur
ce sujet
Vincent wissner c'est bien ou pas
la taxonomie dont on parle beaucoup et
alors là bon on sait pas
les chefs d'entreprise qui sont
directement concernés mais aux yeux du
conseil en tant que tel
alors je saurais pas dire si c'est bien
ou pas je suis pas forcément le mieux
placé pour pour non mais c'est les
voyages en fait alors je suis pas
certain que ça soit un réel moyen de
coercition je pense que c'est un moyen
de de transparence qui contribuent à la
transparence en tant que tel ça ne tord
le bras à personne de changer réellement
son son mode de
production ou ou sa manière de de
produire on peut peut-être appeler en
deux mots d'ailleurs ce qu'est la
taxonomie telle qu'elle est envisagée là
au niveau européen pour lui la taxonomie
c'est des enfin pour faire simple la
taxonomie c'est une manière de taxonomie
verte c'est une manière de qualifier la
part des activités d'une entreprise qui
contribue à des enjeux environnementaux
et sociaux donc il y a là aussi des
seuils
auxquels cette taxonomie
enfin quelles entreprises cette axe mine
devra s'adresser donc son on est sur un
premier seuil à terme de de d'entreprise
qui compte plus de 500 collaborateurs
pour faire simple il y a également
d'autres seuils à considérer en termes
de chiffre d'affaires et puis à terme
évidemment ça a vocation assez large un
petit peu plus donc on est moins sur une
réelle coercition une réelle
et des membres différenciation qu'un
travail de transparence de reporting un
petit peu un petit peu structuré mais
qui est encore une fois à mettre en
regard
d'outils de comptabilité
extra-financière qui me paraissent
essentielle et donc le travail encore
une fois de l'ephrague qui vient qui
vient en parallèle me semble extrêmement
important pour pour nourrir un peu cette
réflexion à l'échelle à l'échelle
européenne donc c'est en résumé c'est
une brique qui est relativement complexe
qui aujourd'hui s'adresse pas encore à
l'ensemble des secteurs
mais qui a vocation évidemment à
l'ensemble des entreprises mais qui a
vocation assez Largère c'est une
première pierre qui a certains manque de
d'atout mais également de défauts comme
tout engagement oui alors tobaccourbe et
Madame non peut-être simplement pour
rebondir ce sujet je pense que la
taxonomie au-delà du mécanisme
bruxellois ça matérialise le fait qui a
été très bien illustré par les deux
chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui qui est
que de plus en plus de contreparties des
entreprises vont demander à voir et à
conditionner leur décision sur la
démarche environnementale des
entreprises évidemment les les prêteurs
c'est c'est les investisseurs ça ça va
c'est ce qu'incarne la taxonomie et on
voit que ça va être de plus en plus
important y compris pour le coup pour
des entreprises qui peuvent être plus
petites pour les collaborateurs vous
l'avez dit pour
les relations entre d'honneur d'ordre et
sous-traitants on voit que beaucoup de
grands donneurs d'ordre français
demandent à leur sous-traitants des
plans de décarbonation pour avoir
l'ensemble de leur scope couvert par
leur démarche de décarbonation et c'est
ça qu'incarne c'est ce mouvement profond
qui incarne
et c'est le thème de cette table ronde
c'est d'arriver à ce que toutes ces
exigences qui sont formulées aux
entreprises se fassent à un rythme et
dans des conditions en tenant compte des
de la taille des entreprises qui soient
compatibles avec le maintien de leur
compétitivité c'est bien ça tout le
l'enjeu de ce tout dans le dialogue
encore une fois on insiste Catherine
garniot dans le dialogue et dans le
temps il y a une notion de temps aussi
par exemple il y a eu une aide sur le
tertiaire pour la rénovation des
bâtiments l'aide à la durée six mois
c'est pas possible enfin on peut pas on
peut en plus c'était l'année de covid
alors c'était encore plus compliqué on
n'était pas trop en train de penser à la
rénovation de nos bâtiments il fallait
déjà qu'on ouvre nos boîtes mais mais
c'est ça en fait il y a cette notion de
temps et généralement le problème du
législateur c'est que c'est limité à une
période donc là en l'occurrence on sait
qu'on a un point qui est 2030 et je
pense qu'il faut prévoir l'ensemble des
accompagnements
sur cette durée jusqu'à 2030 et pas
simplement moi je le vois avec ma prime
rénove dans la menuiserie on est très
concerné bon bah c'est reporté d'une
c'est prolongée d'une année sur l'autre
et encore péniblement donc vraiment il y
a aussi cette notion qui est hyper
importante il nous faut quelque chose
dans le temps et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on nous demande les entreprises on
nous demande d'avoir une vision à moyen
long terme il nous la faut pour nous
pour nos salariés pour l'ensemble de nos
activités c'est pas simplement ça
s'arrête à la fin de l'année c'est c'est
bien bien plus que ça donc ça c'est ça
serait vraiment une aide importante
aussi on est voilà dans le moment des
des propositions et des suggestions
chose promise chose due dans un instant
on va discuter avec la salle Véronique
de gotex sur ce plan justement sur ce
point par rapport la taxonomie enfin
tous les je crois qu'on peut tous
reconnaître si on dit que les
responsables d'entreprises sont
courageux résilient on l'a montré et
puis d'ailleurs on est là alors que on
aurait beaucoup pas faire sur le terrain
mais c'est parce qu'on veut partager
donc voilà on se met dans différents
groupes que sont alors je moi je pousse
vraiment avec le métier mais c'est
pareil avec les PME on nous a je vais
être un tout petit peu non pas
impertinente mais c'est pour pour
adresser des sujets qui nous impactent
la CVAE a été promise annoncé là
maintenant on revient en arrière sur des
promesses en parallèle ça va être étalé
c'est remis en cause quand même
c'est deux ans qui sont précieux le
temps de l'entreprise en crise c'est pas
toujours le temps des administrations
non plus quoi c'est c'est aussi
compliqué et puis on parle de la
taxonomie mais n'y voyez aucune c'est
pas une attaque c'est pour construire la
taxonomie on voit bien ce que ça peut
apporter de vertueux mais j'allais dire
et pourquoi derrière pour l'entreprise
une fois qu'elle a montré pas de blanche
qu'elle travaille bien est-ce que il
pourrait pas y avoir à terme et
l'annoncer ça encouragerait beaucoup
plus dire il y aura peut-être des règles
fiscales différentes pour le résultat
fait sur ce rapport là et puis le
résultat fait autrement et ça ça serait
une vraie levier de compétitivité parce
que c'est celle qui agirait dans le bon
sens validé etc qui bénéficierait d'une
d'un système fiscal un petit peu plus
favorable sinon on subit les contraintes
on s'efforce aujourd'hui toutes nos
entreprises petite moyenne grande nous
sommes le bras armé du gouvernement pour
agir mais encore faut-il nous donner
nous laisser quelques armes
bon la sacoche de Monsieur cours va être
très lourde en reparte avec des
propositions très rapidement et après
elles sont toutes notées je voudrais
juste rebondir sur sur CVAE simplement
pour dire mes factuellement que depuis 5
ans il y a eu la baisse du taux d'impôt
sur les sociétés 10 milliards d'euros de
d'impôt sur la production la CVAE en
deux ans et il y a un engagement sur
deux ans et donc une baisse globalement
de fiscalité des entreprises très
significatives voilà on a entendu cette
parole merci beaucoup alors nous avons
environ une demi-heure nous pour prendre
un petit peu plus aussi puisque nous
sommes ensemble jusqu'à 13h il y aura
une autre table ronde derrière mais
c'est important de d'entendre votre
point de vue donc je vous rappelle si
vous souhaitez prendre la parole
échanger avec les intervenants poser des
questions précises et techniques
peut-être voir partager votre expérience
ou faire des propositions car c'est très
important vous demandez la parole
surtout vous ne vous n'appuyez pas sur
le parce que vous vous avez l'avantage
d'avoir des micro automatique ce qui
n'est pas le cas je crois que des
personnes qui sont dans une autre salle
donc qui ont le droit aussi à la parole
et vers lesquels nous allons aller avec
des micros et à la tribune également
donc vous vous demandez simplement la
parole et puis j'essaierai dans l'ordre
de vous passer cette parole dans l'ordre
des demandes alors nous avions déjà une
pré j'ai vu monsieur Ferrari tout à
l'heure je crois qui souhaitait
s'exprimer Lionel Ferrari de lugap où et
Monsieur Ferré voilà exactement est-ce
que vous pouvez monsieur intervenir
alors il vous suffit d'appuyer sur le le
bouton rouge qui est face à vous voilà
oui bonjour à tous Lionel Ferrari
d'achat publique alors le sujet de la
commande publique n'a pas été
spécifiquement abordé jusqu'à présent
mais bon plutôt que de faire une
intervention j'allais dire un petit peu
hors sol peut-être l'essentiel c'est de
laisser les chefs d'entreprise ici
présent s'exprimer et si vous le
souhaitez j'interviendrai sur sur le
sujet peut-être simplement pour lancer
ce volet du débat Thomas court va très
bien exprimé tout à l'heure le fait
qu'aujourd'hui la réglementation non
seulement au départ en opposition avec
la démarche RSE et avec sa promotion par
la commande publique mais complètement
alignée puisque depuis le projet de loi
climat est résilience 100% de nos
marchés doivent comporter au minimum une
disposition environnementale d'ici à
2025 donc c'est une transformation y
compris pour nous et pour tous les
autres acheteurs publics parce que nous
sommes un petit poucet dans le vaste
monde
très multiple de la commande publique en
France donc voilà nous souhaitons
répondre aussi présent et accompagner
également les entreprises sur ce sujet
là mais bien évidemment avant toute
chose à votre écoute
merci pour ce propos monsieur chapusos
souhaitait intervenir également de vous
être là Monsieur donc de equacentre oui
bonjour mais je voudrais parler aussi
d'une autre d'entreprise que nous avons
qui est le dernier fabricant de
chalumeau français à la flamme qui est
une petite PME 38 personnes et
industrielles et il y a un sujet qu'on
n'a pas abordé c'est l'export c'est
entreprises fait 60% de son chiffre
d'affaires en France et dans l'Union
européenne et 40% en dehors de l'Union
Européenne et notamment l'Afrique
l'Amérique du Sud etc le problème je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour la
démarche RSE et on investit tous il y a
des investissements on peut avoir un
retour sur investissement il y a des
investisseurs on en a pas mais dans le
cas de l'Union européenne c'est pas très
gênant parce que après tout nous avons
tous les mêmes règles en compétition et
ça pose pas de souci et c'est même bon
pour l'image de l'entreprise parce qu'il
y a une clientèle qui la comprend quand
vous exportez en Afrique vous êtes dans
une démarche totalement différente parce
que la population et la clientèle n'a
pas du tout le même même comment dire
état d'esprit par rapport à ça et nos
seules compétiteurs sont chinois
évidemment les Chinois n'ont pas les
mêmes règles nous sommes déjà 20% plus
cher que et on va se battre sur la
qualité et l'innovation mais évidemment
il y a un moment où c'est surcoût de RSE
deviennent un embêtant dans la
compétitivité sur ces marchés là et je
pense que la France a besoin elle a un
commerce extérieur qui est plutôt
faiblard a besoin de de grandir
d'exporter et là je pense qu'il faudrait
essayer de réfléchir ensemble à des
règles différentes pour les sociétés qui
exportent en dehors de lieu où là les
règles ne sont pas les mêmes parce que
je vous rappelle que la Chine n'est pas
du tout du tout dans le même état
d'esprit que l'Europe
merci beaucoup est-ce que quelqu'un
souhaite réagir Thomas combe peut-être
je pense que c'est une très bonne
question la réponse à apporter n'est pas
évidente je voudrais simplement redire
que on a quand même fait un progrès qui
est l'inverse du problème que vous citez
qui est tout ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure pour permettre de mieux
différencier les produits qui ont un
contenu environnemental
important un effort environnemental sur
le marché intérieur déjà et ça c'est
déjà quand même un gros progrès vous
êtes à 60% sur le sur le marché
intérieur et le fait qu'on arrive à
faire cette différenciation notamment
avec les produits chinois va quand même
déjà être une première réponse à
l'export c'est plus complexe puisqu'on a
évidemment aucun levier sur les
réglementations locales mais mais c'est
une bonne question c'est une très bonne
question
de la part export du chiffre d'affaires
ou une fiscalité différente ou une aide
différente mais de façon nous redonner
des de la compétitivité par rapport à
ces marchés là qui peut-être viendront
certainement mais au moins une démarche
plus lente que l'Europe voilà
et je crois qu'il faut y réfléchir parce
que il me semble que c'est bon pour le
pays
d'exporter en dehors de lieu et bien le
propos est bien enregistré bien noté en
tout cas pour ces suggestions merci
Monsieur alors monsieur vous avez la
parole et ensuite nous passons de
l'autre côté madame je vais venir aussi
vers vous monsieur rapide présentation
et nous vous écoutons
bonjour à toutes et à tous Antoine
pontellier je suis le président de du
groupe next qui est un groupe qui
fabrique des emballages dessiner au
secteur agroalimentaire
et qui appartient au club des ETI de
nouvelle-aquitaine cher à Alain Rousset
puisque les ETI doivent être le faire de
l'anse de l'économie en France on peut
l'espérer
entrer dans derrière elle derrière elle
des PME donc j'emploie environ 120
personnes sur trois sites industriels un
mur de cela une dans la région Centre
un autre site à côté de Chambéry et le
site principal à Nersac alors je vais
l'évoquer rapidement pour interpeller
monsieur Ferrari monsieur courbe et
donner suite aux propos tenus par mon
prédécesseurs sur les règles du jeu
en mars 2020 pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent les accents solennelles du
chef de l'État sur le fait qu'on devait
s'affranchir d'une tutelle sur des
produits exotiques notamment en matière
de produits de santé à conduit un
certain nombre d'acteurs à lancer des
projets industriels qui et c'est ma
remarque pour rebondir sur les propos de
Monsieur courbes
permettent finalement une décarbonation
relocalisant et ça c'est une c'est
quelque chose d'effectif direct et
directement mesurable donc pour répondre
à cette injonction présidentielle j'ai
œuvré
en investissant 10 millions d'euros
dans ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
patriotisme économique donc j'ai créé la
plus belle usine du monde pour fabriquer
des masques et nous fabriquons des
masques FFP2 des masques chirurgicaux et
de façon à minima être le champion
néo-acquitain de cette production pour
des acteurs néo-acintains mais bon il y
a pas d'interdiction d'aller plus loin
j'observe que deux ans et demi après et
ça je m'interroge sur la capacité à
tirer les leçons du passé nous ne sommes
toujours pas destinateurs par exemple de
marché public
et Dieu sait que
les interventions furent nombreuses j'ai
rencontré Roland Lescure vendredi matin
vendredi dernier et je fais état
notamment des distorsions de concurrence
récemment et je vais illustrer ça très
rapidement par une anecdote des
Allemands nous demandent est-ce que on a
appris que vous aviez les mêmes machines
que nous est-ce que vous pourriez
produire 7 millions de masques oui bien
sûr on se met d'accord sur le prix etc
48 heures après coup de fil alors nous
sommes désolés voilà ce qu'on va vous
proposer on démonte la machine qui est
chez vous on la remonte en Allemagne on
produit 7 millions de masques et on les
réimplante avec l'appui du constructeur
sur votre site de production
vous vous rendez compte ça a coûté un
pognon de dingue la réponse est rapide
c'est pour honorer les marchés publics
en Allemagne il faut produire sur le sol
allemand et ça tombe bien parce que j'ai
documenté depuis avant-hier et hier est
tombé l'appel d'oeuvre de santé publique
France qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on se tire des balles dans le genou on
se tire les ballons le pied on veut
continuer à importer 97% de masques
chinois alors là si vous voulez qu'on
fasse l'empreinte carbone entre mes
masques produits à Nersac et ceux qui
sont produits en Chine sans compter le
nombre de masques non conforme qui sont
livrés acheter avec de l'argent public
alors il y a un une réflexion
à une époque de Maria sutcher c'est pas
vraiment ma tasse de thé c'est le cas de
le dire mais qui disait il n'y a pas
d'argent public il n'y a uniquement que
des taxes payeurs OK et bien je pense
que il faut penser écosystème on est en
train de dire les entreprises sont
mobilisées pour quand on parle de
patriotisme économique c'est pas anodin
voilà c'est vraiment un geste de
patriotisme économique qu'en est-il
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on bouge
les lignes et comment cette compétition
ensuite les règles du jeu sont les mêmes
est-ce que l'administration française ce
que j'ai dit à Roland Lescure vendredi
matin et moins courageuse ou moins
vertueuse que l'administration allemande
merci Monsieur pour votre témoignage
merci
[Applaudissements]
et le cas se pose aussi avec les
États-Unis par exemple le l'America
first qui est dans la même dans la même
veine quelque part Thomas Coppe
peut-être la parole oui
simplement pour dire que donc enfin se
redire parce que je crois je crois pas
que ce soit une question de courage ce
que vous dit l'acheteur allemand c'est
illégal illégal
au terme du droit français et du droit
européen donc c'est une question plutôt
de l'égalité que de courage ensuite pour
justement rester dans le cadre légal de
la commande publique à la fois au niveau
européen et et français et pour répondre
exactement à votre enjeu votre enjeu il
est il est très bien décrit et c'est on
a bien
l'objectif d'y répondre on a
adressé à tous les acheteurs publics de
masques donc notamment les hôpitaux une
circulaire leur demandant d'organiser
leur cahier des charges pour que tout en
respectant évidemment le cadre légal on
maximise les chances que des producteurs
comme vous puissent y répondre et donc
on a fait cette circulation ça
exactement cette finalité elle a été
diffusée je pense que ce qui est
important c'est que vous parliez de
l'appel d'offres santé publique France
il faut que on ait un échange pour que
vous nous disiez ce qui dans sa tête cet
appel d'offre ne vous permet pas de
répondre ou ne vous permet pas de
différencier votre offre puisque c'est
bien comme ça qu'on procède par la
loutissement par les clauses sociales et
environnementales qu'on différencie
votre offre par rapport à l'offre
chinoise c'est bien le l'objectif et
donc là il faut que il faut qu'on s'en
parle il faut qu'on voit ce qui dans
cette circulaire qui avait d'ailleurs
été cette circulaire elle a été écrite
avec beaucoup de représentants du
secteur et donc elle a été conçue avec
les représentants du secteur il faut
qu'on se dise si elle est efficace ou
pas et sinon la modifiera et l'objectif
il est exactement ce que ce que vous
dites en restant dans la légalité
il y avait une question de Monsieur et
après on vient vers madame bonjour
bonjour à tous Sylvain Baudry donc je
dirige des PME en Bourgogne dans cette
belle région de Bourgogne Franche-Comté
voilà qui représente au total 300
salariés pour 100 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires dans différents
secteurs d'activités d'abord moi je vous
remercie de l'intervention de vos
interventions et de la qualité bien sûr
on est tous persuadés qu'on doit
s'orienter vers vers la RSE et on le
fait
contrairement à ce qui a été dit je
pense que
simplification et administrative c'est
antinomique enfin pour ça ça fonctionne
pas dès que c'est administratif c'est
forcément complexe à l'image de nos PME
il n'y a pas d'attaque dans ce que je
dis mais à l'image de nos organisations
à l'image de nos PME c'est forcément
complexe les dossiers sont très
complexes à remplir et à suivre et si on
fait si on veut vraiment faire évoluer
nos entreprises rapidement parce que moi
je ne crois pas que on soit dans une
période de crise dans laquelle on va
sortir je crois qu'on est dans une
période de mutation qui va se faire de
crise successives et que nos entreprises
doivent être doivent être hyper réactifs
pour répondre à ça on n'est pas au même
au même tempo j'allais dire que
l'administration mon propos principal
est surtout en termes de stratégie
pour diriger mon entreprise notamment
une entreprise de transport j'ai besoin
de savoir
de connaître la stratégie du
gouvernement notamment en termes
d'énergie nos investissements se font à
long terme entre 5 et 10 ans pour nos
véhicules entre 10 et 15 ans pour nos
machines de production pour d'autres
entreprises au moment du choix de
l'investissement doit avoir une vision à
long terme sur quelle énergie dans quel
process allons-nous investir on peut pas
être aujourd'hui sur une énergie dans un
an pour une raison géopolitique sur une
autre dans deux ans sur une troisième là
par contre on n'est pas au rythme de nos
entreprises nous on a besoin d'une
stratégie
gouvernementale à long terme pour
appliquer la stratégie de notre
entreprise et être accompagnée après
nous ferons chacun et j'en suis persuadé
nos boulots d'entrepreneurs on sait le
faire on sait faire vivre nos
entreprises il s'agit et je rebondis sur
ce que vous avez dit Monsieur de
patriotisme économique et si on est là
alors qu'on a tous beaucoup de boulot
c'est qu'on y croit mais on a besoin de
vision à plus long terme et pas d'un CAP
qui change tous les trois mois au rythme
des crises
je le répète on est dans une société qui
mute et qui vivra des cris successives
sur des pas de temps qu'ils le sont
reconnaissons le puis une vingtaine
d'années de plus en plus court et donc
on doit adapter nos entreprises à ça et
on a besoin de stratégie et vraiment de
simplification j'insiste c'est compliqué
on doit passer nous plus d'énergie avec
nos collaborateurs avec nos
investissements avec nos clients qu'avec
l'administration merci
merci Monsieur pour ce témoignage qui
appelle peut-être un commentaire de l'un
ou applaudir
pas spécialement en tout cas tout est
tout est bien noté madame ne vous
écoutons
oui bonjour
Sandra gallisso je suis entrepreneur à
Aix-en-Provence et je suis à la CPME
également
je voudrais rappeler mais je sais que
vous le savez mais je trouve que c'est
toujours important de le rappeler que
l'essentiel des entreprises en France
c'est des TPE c'est même pas des PME
c'est des TPE et la transition
qu'on évoque les concernes en premier
lieu également et là aussi les
dispositifs sont parfois cruellement
manquants alors effectivement c'est
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est peut-être
plus facile de cibler quelques
entreprises pour échafauder des
dispositifs mais ça me paraît important
de le rappeler je voudrais souligner ça
l'a été à plusieurs reprises rappelées
l'importance d'avoir une vision une
certaine durabilité c'est quand même le
cœur une durabilité des accompagnements
des dispositifs
d'aide
on a parfois l'impression qu'on est
presque dans une campagne marketing avec
des soldes pendant six mois il y a tel
prix bon c'est un peu déstabilisant quoi
et ça ne correspond pas aux attentes des
entrepreneurs
et je voudrais terminer peut-être plus
positivement par une une question une
finalement une suggestion tout à l'heure
on va parler de reprise de transmission
est-ce qu'on a imaginé est-ce qu'on a en
réflexion des dispositifs
d'accompagnement à la création à la
reprise à la transmission pour que les
entreprises deviennent des entreprises à
mission merci alors c'est effectivement
un sujet une question à laquelle nous
pourrions répondre dans la table ronde
suivante vous assisterez toujours à la
table ronde suivante bon je vous propose
de de d'entrer dans le sujet tout à
l'heure plutôt que en restant sur sur le
sujet qui est le nôtre actuellement une
réaction ou alors oui madame de gotex
juste pour répondre à ce point
bien transmission c'est que nous on
fonctionne beaucoup avec des
partenariats et puis de la croissance
externe parce qu'on n'a pas adressé le
sujet du recrutement de la formation et
qui est un sujet majeur dans toutes nos
entreprises et on a beaucoup de dossiers
là qui nous sont soumis pour des
croissances externes de gens qui veulent
transmettre et qui veulent transmettre
parce que des entreprises à taille
humaine qui veulent transmettre avec des
valeurs et de l'ADN il y a plus juste le
sujet économique évidemment il faut le
sujet économique et voilà ça fait le
lien aussi avec le deuxième sujet mais
c'est
je suis complètement en phase avec cette
démarche
nous approfondirons tout à l'heure
effectivement oui
un élément de réponse par rapport à
cette question là
de plus en plus de dirigeants qui se
pose assez honnêtement c'est ces
questions s'orientent vers la création
de fondation actionnaire je sais pas si
alors en tant que tel d'un point de vue
juridique ça n'a pas d'existence ce sont
dans l'effet la plupart du temps des
fonds de dotation et puis de manière un
peu usuelle on appelle ça des fondations
actionnaires ça permet de transmettre
tout ou partie de son capital à un fonds
dotation qui derrière a évidemment un
objectif philanthropique philanthropique
côté RER des dividendes mais au-delà de
ça permet de rendre pour partie
incessible l'entreprise et de l'orienter
vers un certain nombre de valeurs que
vous avez défini vous en tant que
dirigeant et je vous invite à jeter un
oeil à la communauté des facto qui est
une communauté composée aujourd'hui d'un
tout petit nombre de dirigeants il y en
a une vingtaine qui ont lié affirmation
des valeurs au travers du statut
d'entreprise à mission ou non parce que
c'est pas en tant que tel une fin en soi
et ce sont posés cette question de la
transmission de ces valeurs et de quelle
héritage je donne
véritablement à la fois mes salariés
mais également à la société dans son
ensemble au travers de ces réflexions
autour de la création de fondation
maximale
Thomas courbe
merci trois points rapides sur sur le
point sur la stratégie sur l'énergie
j'ai l'impression vous évoquez les
évolutions géopolitiques
j'ai l'impression qu'il c'est pas ces
évolutions géopolitiques ne changent pas
la stratégie on a une stratégie qui a
été présentée par le président en
matière d'énergie le 12 février à
Belfort on a quelques mois plus tard la
Russie qui coupe le gaz évidemment il
faut
avoir une réponse adaptée à cet
événement géopolitique mais les deux
vont dans le même sens qui est
d'accélérer la transition d'améliorer
notre autonomie en manière et notre
souveraineté en matière d'énergie et ça
ça passe par le nucléaire et le
déploiement plus rapide des ENR et il y
a un projet de de loi sur le sur le
sujet et donc les deux il me semble ne
sont pas contradictoires mais au
contraire la crise géopolitique que nous
vivons nous incite à aller plus loin
dans la souveraineté énergétique et
c'est de ce point de vue on garde ce cap
sur les TPE
madame vous avez vous avez raison c'est
c'est le l'enjeu que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est plus d'un million de TPE à
accompagner c'est simplement une
question pour en tout cas ce qui ressort
de la puissance publique d'effet
d'échelle et qui est complexe on
exactement comme vous l'avez dit on
raisonne aussi par priorité dans par
exemple dans l'économie de proximité la
somme des émissions des PME est
supérieures à la somme des émissions des
TPE donc il y a effectivement simplement
une question d'efficacité qui fait que
commencer par accompagner les PME sera
plus efficace mais ça n'enlève rien à la
nécessité aussi de trouver des solutions
adaptées pour pour les TPE c'est c'est
bien ce à quoi on travaille dans le
cadre de la planification écologique
et puis sur la sur la durée des aides
qui est un sujet qui est revenu
plusieurs fois
et c'est du cas par cas évidemment mais
il faut aussi intégrer le fait que
parfois on lance une aide qu'elle se
révèle peu efficace et que quand elle
est pas efficace il faut l'arrêter et
c'est plutôt
urgent de l'arrêter en général quand
elle l'est pas et donc ça peut donner
l'impression de d'aide à durée limitée
mais c'est parfois il y a ça que qu'il
faut le faire alors il nous reste un
petit quart d'heure et trois questions
et une quatrième donc qui vient de
s'annoncer à la tribu de monsieur ne
vous écoutons rapid présentation et
rapidement bonjour Jérôme Sicile de
d'Aix-en-Provence également de Rousset
et entreprise pro viridis qui veut dire
pour le vert en latin nous sommes les
premiers en France avoir conçu construit
et exploiter des stations multi-énergie
décarbonées à l'attention des transports
de marchandises de voyageurs et les
transports particuliers nous proposons
du biogaz GNC GNL et également des super
chargeurs électriques et nous préparons
l'arrivée de l'hydrogène qui est une
filière encore non mature extrêmement
chère j'ai également passé à la dame
j'étais chargé de la transition
énergétique transport immobilité dans la
région PACA ceux-ci pour dire que la
mutation des entreprises le choix des
flottes de véhicules les obligations
réglementaires qui poussent les flottes
publiques privées à muté alors à quel
coup à quel échéance quelles sont les
bonnes filières il s'agit d'un
mixgétique pour les transports lourds la
réponse et le gaz vous l'avez cité le
gaz ne le vendions à 80 centimes du kilo
l'équivalent d'un litre à peu près il y
a une quinzaine de mois il est à 3 euros
3 euros 60 nous conservons simplement
notre marge nous sommes pas producteurs
de gaz mais c'est comme ça et le biogaz
français est indexé au gaz fossile nous
sommes prisonniers Les Lecques est
indexée au gaz en France etc etc donc il
y a tout un tas de mécanismes aussi
c'est en cours de révision les ministres
européens il travaille la France
également en interne le lobby du lobby
les
l'écosystème du biogaz aussi fait son
travail mais là nous sommes réduits
une difficulté nous-mêmes qui sommes 550
salariés nous devons réduire les
effectifs puisque nous étions en
croissance nous sommes sur un plateau
maintenant donc les difficultés
environnementales comme acteurs de
premier plan une PME nous y sommes
confrontés et c'est difficile donc le
choix sur les énergies la stratégie du
gouvernement elle est sur le mix à
certains usages correspond une énergie
et le GNV gaz naturel véhicule est une
très bonne réponse l'électricité arrive
à grands pas et enfin pour finir sur les
sur la défiscalisation il existe le sur
amortissement pour les pl- GNV et
électrique parce que les poids les poids
lourds électriques arrivent ils sont
quand même à 300.000 euros le pour citer
Renault parce que vive la France
exactement le Sexton de Renault et la
défiscalisation de 50 000 puisque le
bonus vous avez 100000 euros quand même
pour vous équiper d'un point électrique
plus les aides pour les irve
infrastructures de recharge véhicule
électrique avec le formidable programme
advenir financé par les C2E merci
oui vous avez raison mais même avec ces
mesures on parle de levier de
compétitivité on reste pas compétitif et
quand vous avez des fournisseurs
asiatiques qui viennent et qui vous
disent c'est disponible c'est moins cher
c'est fiable il y a les pièces détachées
je vous jure qu'il faut vraiment faire
passer des messages auprès des
collaborateurs et de temps en temps on
se dit on va peut-être gérer le court
terme pour pouvoir parce que c'est bien
les super ambitions à moyen terme mais
faut déjà survivre à court terme pour
avoir la chance de vivre le moyen terme
donc et puis je repensais parce que j'ai
retrouvé quelques infos tout à l'heure
sur l'exportation monsieur qui parlait
de l'exportation de chalumeau et j'ai
entendu les TPE etc les ETI
représentent une grosse partie des
exportations un tiers avec seulement une
petite minorité d'acteurs donc il faut
pas oublier qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se bougent aussi pour aller exporter
donc c'est vrai qu'on a besoin d'être
soutenu un peu de partout c'est pas
notre cas mais je porter la parole des
autres
voilà ça sent le vécu comment on dit
alors monsieur vous avez la réponse à
votre voilà Monsieur souhaitait
intervenir très bien on va venir vers
vous après monsieur ne vous écoutons
Bernard boulanger donc moi je suis un
peu particulier parce que j'arrive de
Guyane et j'ai deux petites entreprises
là-bas où on fait de l'agroalimentaire
et on s'intéresse aussi au RSE et je
voulais juste m'en on parle beaucoup
parce que nous on a été accompagné par
notre CCI pour tout notre bilan
énergétique et ce qui nous a permis et
comme vous madame on est passé tout de
suite au LED parce qu'il nous a permis
de faire une première économie mais je
suis étonné quand on parle de transition
environnementale des carbonations
transition énergétique on parle pas du
tout de l'autoconsommation nous on a eu
la chance d'avoir répondu à un appel
d'offre de l'ADEME et on a été retenu et
c'est une économie énorme tout de suite
c'est 15 100% et quand on voit le coût
de l'énergie je suis étonné que au
niveau gouvernemental on ne prend pas
des actions fortes pour aider les
entreprises les industriels qui ont des
bâtiments à mettre des panneaux solaires
pour pouvoir faire de l'autoconsommation
directe c'est de l'économie d'énergie et
c'est de la baisse de consommation pour
pour l'État
Thomas
vous avez tout à fait raison et il y a à
la fois donc les aides les aides de
l'ADEME qui vont dans le sens le
décrétaire par exemple prévoit
l'équipement panneaux solaires d'un
certain nombre de structures pour
justement faire de l'autoconsommation on
a par ailleurs dans dans les actions que
je mentionnais tout à l'heure sur le
plan de relance au-delà de
l'autoconsommation les projets
d'écosystèmes par exemple de
récupération de chaleur fatale par un
acteur dans un écosystème cher fatale
produit de par l'autre donc on est
d'accord que c'est moyen sont également
importants et notamment le décret
tertiaire va permettre de massifier le
recours au panneaux photovoltaïques pour
l'autoconsommation
on part à la tribune madame je vais vous
demander donc d'être concis parce que
finalement les questions se multiplient
et nous avons encore cette 7 minutes
je précise quand même que vous aurez
l'occasion de discuter après au déjeuner
donc voilà tout ne se passe pas
uniquement dans ce dans cette salle il y
aura un autre moment des changements ne
vous écoutons concision s'il vous plaît
merci
on va on va vous ouvrir le micro
normalement allez-y oui c'est parfait
parlez bien prêt parlez bien près merci
alors je m'appelle Carole Bernard je
suis coiffeuse et j'ai eu le label
développement durable de mon coiffeur
s'engage donc en Saône-et-Loire
et je voulais vous demander justement
par rapport à tous ces labels est-ce que
c'était pas possible en fait de poser
tous les labels qui existent en France
que ce soit des TPE enfin des petites
entreprises surtout parce que le cahier
des charges que j'ai pourrait être un
modèle même pour d'autres entreprises
d'autres petites structures des
commerces pour faire des économies
d'énergie déjà dans un premier temps et
par rapport à tous ces labels justement
donc déjà nous on est un peu perdu avec
tout ce qu'il y a des fois on n'est pas
au courant de tout est-ce que vous
pensez aux clients moi je suis en direct
en fait avec la clientèle tout c'est la
belle là ça ne leur parle pas du tout
donc un on est on est des entreprises on
travaille pour des clients pour leurs
besoins si les clients on ne le crée pas
aussi leurs besoins en disant ah bah
tiens cette entreprise est labellisée
elle atteint ça ça veut dire qu'elle
fait attention à l'environnement
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça peut pas
avoir plus de conséquences aussi au
niveau de l'entreprise
Catherine garniot peut-être je voyais
réagir
je pense que c'est de la communication
en fait effectivement vous avez
entièrement raison et là tous les labels
on s'y perd c'est la même chose dans le
domaine agroalimentaire je pense entre
les bio entre les abbés les enfin il y
en a il y en a il y en a pléthore donc
après
j'ai quand même eu
c'est le ministère de Monsieur mais j'ai
quand même eu un contrôle de la
répression des fraudes alors que tu es
la seule à avoir un label en
Saône-et-Loire autant dire que j'étais
un petit peu en colère mais après elle
m'a dit oui c'est pour aussi vous
protéger mais même eux sont dans le flou
ils ne savent plus elle m'a posé
énormément de questions donc il
confondent le développement durable moi
je suis je fais de la coloration
végétale et du bio mais je fais mais ça
a rien à voir on peut trier ses déchets
ces déchets on peut avoir des LED on
peut avoir une des économies d'énergie
sur le gaz et tout ça mais il y a déjà
quand même des labels en place dans
certaines structures dans l'artisanat
donc il faut s'en servir aussi le
législateur les législateur qui qui vous
écoute Thomas Thomas courtes peut-être
très rapidement
c'est pas que législateur puisque en
fait une partie de ces label sont
privées et donc son son organisés par
les fédérations professionnelles vous
étiez madame tout à l'heure
Origine France Garantie un label privé
et donc le je partage complètement et
sur le sur le made in France et c'est
aussi il y a aussi une grande
multiplicité de labels et il y a des
sujets de visibilité pour le
consommateur final
simplement il faut tenir compte du fait
que c'est à la fois du public mais
surtout du privé et donc il faut aussi
trouver des accords avec les
organisations professionnelles si on
veut les rationaliser alors je rappelle
que toutes ces entretiens sont
enregistrés bien sûr et retranscrit donc
sa cheminera dans le dans le les
différents établissements monsieur
barbus derrière voilà je pardon je fais
une différence parce que vous êtes deux
dans le même la même zone bien sûr nous
écoutons bonjour Jérémy Quentin
président de la société et Neo en Vendée
donc nous on convertit les poids lourds
thermiques en électrique et hydrogène
aujourd'hui c'est une solution technique
fiable qu'on maîtrise le seul frein au
développement de ça en France puisque ça
va surtout soutenir l'économie des
territoires c'est la législation la
vitesse à homologué les véhicules et
aujourd'hui nous on a une capacité de
s'adapter à mettre les moyens de la
transition énergétique que les effectifs
de l'État n'ont pas est-ce que l'État va
s'engager à un moment donné avec les
effectifs qu'il faut pour aller vite
homologuer ces véhicules pour assurer
une transition énergétique efficace
merci la parole est à Bercy
non sur les sur les effectifs pour
l'homologation des véhicules je vais
passer mon tour je suis désolé mais je
prends la question
monsieur devant nous vous écoutons oui
bonjour Cyril Bollier de la Fédération
du bâtiment et des travaux publics du
Var je voulais prendre la parole pour
revenir un petit peu sur la commande
publique parce que je suis pas certain
que la commande publique aujourd'hui
soit le meilleur allié du des circuits
courts et du localisme et qui sont
pourtant des des soutiens importants à
la transition énergétique et je me
posais notamment la question de enfin je
me pose pas vraiment la question j'ai je
pense qu'il faut trouver des réponses au
fait que la réglementation aujourd'hui
reste un frein à la mise en oeuvre de
solutions innovantes je pense à la
commande publique parce que dans le
bâtiment c'est 30% de l'activité dans
les travaux publics c'est 70% de
l'activité et qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
avez des freins par exemple pour
employer des matériaux recyclés comme
des granulats recyclés pour
ne serait-ce que boucher des tranchées
alors que ce serait une solution très
très valorisante
je me dis que il y a des réglementations
et notamment législateur pourrait se
pencher sur ces sujets là et je
m'interroge aussi sur le niveau de
formation des agents qui soient
techniciens ou acheteur à commande
publique parce que ils sont parce qu'on
a des relations avec régulièrement ils
sont très en demande de monter en
compétence de la même façon que les
entreprises ont besoin de monter en
compétences je pense que les acheteurs
publics ont besoin de le faire et que
là-dessus il devrait y avoir un peu plus
de
d'interaction entre les le monde
économique et les acheteurs parce que
tout ça doit beaucoup s'y Riguet et que
les montées en compétences doivent être
mutuelle voilà
des expériences là dessus avec le CNFPT
mais c'est très très inédit et c'est
encore balbutiant tout cela est bien
noté consigné pas de réponse attendue
monsieur courbe non pas spécialement
on partage et dans les à nouveau il faut
pas sous-estimer quand même
l'amélioration des cahiers des charges
de la commande publique sur la
lotissement pour l'accès au PME il reste
il reste beaucoup pas faire et j'ai
donné tout à l'heure des exemples sur
lesquels il faudra qu'on reviendra sur
certains produits qu'on essaye de
développer sur la formation des
acheteurs je sais pas si Lucas veut
répondre
oui bien évidemment nous avons tous à
nous améliorer il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites je voulais revenir
aussi sur le sujet achat innovant la
réglementation a fait l'objet là aussi
d'assouplissement très significatif
alors probablement que tout ça ne va pas
assez loin mais voilà il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui ont d'ores et déjà
été faites sur la formation des
acheteurs
là aussi des choses vont être vont être
déployées dans le cas de notamment du
plan national pour des achats durables
qui est piloté en interministériel ou
des initiatives sur la formation des
acheteurs vont être déployés mais là où
je vous rejoins complètement et là aussi
la réglementation maintenant et nous
nous aide énormément
le sourcing ou le sourcage comme on dit
en bon français de ce qui se passe dans
les entreprises et aujourd'hui quelque
chose de parfaitement autorisé et balisé
par la réglementation et bien évidemment
il faut qu'on se nourrisse de ce que
vous faites parce que bien souvent vous
nous avez pas attendu pour faire des
choses absolument admirables et donc
derrière nous nous nourrissons dans nos
cahiers des charges donc il y a encore
du boulot c'est entendu merci beaucoup
merci il ne presque deux minutes et il y
a deux questions je rappelle que vous
pourrez discuter ensemble après donc
voilà Monsieur pardon c'est vous qui
aviez levé la main et nous terminerons
avec Monsieur derrière bonjour Frédéric
Delcroix donc directeur d'usine de
jockey dans le Pas-de-Calais on est
fabriquant d'emballage tout à l'heure on
parlait de simplification
administrative il y a le dispositif
opéra qui a été mis en place donc pour
le les déclarations de consommation
d'énergie pour les bâtiments de plus de
1000 mètres carrés bâtiment
administratif et logistique ça ne
représente que un très faible
pourcentage de notre consommation
énergétique puisque nous sommes dans les
niveaux de 27 gigawatts de consommation
vous pensez bien que ça n'a pas été une
priorité pour nous d'instrumenter la
consommation de nos bâtiments par contre
opéra va nous donner des objectifs de
réduction à terme de l'ordre de 60% de
consommation d'énergie de nos bâtiments
alors malheureusement je dis
malheureusement parce que
l'environnement en fait on l'a pas
découvert aujourd'hui avec les crises
énergétiques on s'est mis en oeuvre il y
a de nombreuses années on a fait
beaucoup de choses dans nos bâtiments
isolation par l'extérieur par
l'intérieur des LEDs
on a de la récupération d'énergie de
notre usine pour chauffer les bâtiments
donc on a un très bon niveau par contre
on n'a pas instrumenté nos bâtiments
donc on ne peut pas donner d'année de
référence pour notre consommation
énergétique donc quand on parle de
simplification ça fait quasiment un mois
et demi avec deux de mes collaboratrices
où on cherche comment se sortir de ce de
ce dispositif qui est censé à terme nous
faire des économies d'énergie que nous
avons déjà faites c'est bien noté les
préoccupations sont effectivement se
rejoindre dernière question monsieur je
vous demanderai d'être très rapide oui
mettre votre micro s'il vous plaît
monsieur vous appuyez sur le bouton
rouge voilà et très rapidement s'il vous
plaît merci
de conditionnement de fruits 85% export
1200 personnes 200 millions de chiffre
d'affaires l'exploit est un gros
problème ici on parle français je trouve
que les provinces de la France qui est
ruiné endetté et qui a un commerce
extérieur catastrophique ce sont pas
manifestés ce matin merci ben écoutez
voilà l'appel est lancé en tout cas on
aura l'occasion peut-être d'y revenir
d'y revenir après dans la seconde table
ronde qui va suivre nous avons alors je
serai des reins nous avons cinq petites
minutes parce que nous avons encore une
belle séance de travail derrière le
temps de changer le plateau peut-être de
vous détendre un petit peu et de revenir
mais vraiment dans soyez là à 11h05
grand maximum merci beaucoup merci
bien mesdames messieurs je vous propose
et je vous invite à rejoindre vos places
nous allons reprendre nos travaux si
vous pouvez vous installer s'il vous
plaît reprendre vos sièges
nous avons encore une
séance de travail très intéressante
comme la précédente le fut
je vous invite à rejoindre vos
emplacements s'il vous plaît
pour que nous puissions attaquer la
session suivante
d'être à leur écoute pour tirer parti et
illustrer notre travail par le
commentaire
garantit d'être pertinent cette
proximité vis-à-vis des territoires
ce qui fait mon grand bonheur c'est que
on a toujours vous avez toujours été
auprès de nous et on a eu dans
l'histoire des chambres de commerce
quelques combats et ses combats ont les
amenés et avec vous alors je ne sais pas
si on nous entend à l'extérieur de la
salle mais j'invite toutes les personnes
qui nous écoutent éventuellement à
l'extérieur à nous rejoindre très
rapidement pour que nous puissions
attaquer la seconde table ronde merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
comme la ministre la lenteur de la mise
en place de tous ces moyens dont vous
parlez que j'entends nous fait douter
forcément de d'une volonté énergique ça
fait depuis 2015 ça fera 12 ans en 2027
bien non pas que les absents est
toujours tort mais au moins nous allons
respecter les personnes qui qui sont à
l'heure et et pointilleux sur les
horaires
madame messieurs donc je vous propose de
continuer nos travaux avant d'accueillir
et de vous présenter les intervenants
cette table ronde dont je rappelle le
thème réussir la transmission et la
remise la reprise pardon d'entreprises
une priorité dans nos territoires je
vous propose un bref reportage toujours
donc sur le travail de la mission
sénatoriale des entreprises et des
rapporteurs sur le sujet et nous
débattons ensuite
et si la région peut lever un petit peu
le son ce serait parfait merci c'est
aperçu rapidement que la question de la
reprise transmission des entreprises
était quelque chose d'essentiel et c'est
pourquoi mes collègues Claude nougins et
Michel vaspar ont produit un rapport
avec différentes propositions en 2017 et
nous avons souhaité pouvoir réactualiser
l'ensemble de ses propositions en 2022
parce que au fil des dépassements sur le
terrain nous nous sommes rendus compte
que c'était une préoccupation majeure de
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises qui
d'abord vivaient de façon assez
dramatique le fait de ne pas pouvoir
transmettre dans l'entreprise et puis
sur les territoires on s'aperçoit aussi
qu'il y a un gros attachement aux
entreprises qui y sont nées qui se sont
développés qui sont des poidsvoyeurs
d'emploi extrêmement significative et il
nous semblait important que l'on puisse
favoriser cette transmission des
entreprises et puis beaucoup d'entre
vous ont sans doute vu aussi un certain
nombre d'études notamment par le Conseil
d'analyse économique qui doutait de la
pertinence d'outils de transmission
comme
le pacte du trail par exemple or ce que
l'on entend sur le territoire c'est que
ces outils favorisant la transmission
d'entreprise sont absolument nécessaires
indispensables parce que il y va du
maintien des entreprises il y va du
maintien de l'emploi de l'activité
souvent aussi de transmission de
savoir-faire et c'est en ce sens que
nous formulons des propositions pour
favoriser la reprise transmission des
entreprises en France ce contexte est
d'autant plus inquiétant que l'on note
ces dernières années un véritable
ralentissement des transmissions
d'entreprises alors que en 2017
on note plus de 25% des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont 60 ans en plus et
pourtant en 2005 il n'était que 15%. or
malgré ce risque déjà identifié on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment
de prise de conscience d'une part de la
part des chefs d'entreprise mais
également et surtout des différentes
administrations qui à l'heure actuelle
ne sont même pas dans la capacité de
nous fournir des statistiques avérées
c'est pourquoi c'est nos travaux ces
derniers mois nous ont conduit à
formuler 11 précon qui se décrit autour
de deux axes la sécurisation des
transmissions d'une part et leur
simplification d'autre part avec pour
ambition de sécuriser les transmissions
sanctuariser le pacte du Treil qui est
essentiel pour que se développe nos
entreprises en ETI familiale simplifier
les procédures stabiliser le droit et
enfin inciter les dirigeants à anticiper
leur succession sans rentrer dans le
détail dans les recommandations je vais
faire un focus sur l'une d'entre elles
il faut absolument sanctuariser le pacte
de treuil car il est essentiel pour les
transmissions familiales et pour le
maintien du tissu productif et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il va falloir une
véritable campagne d'information
deuxième recommandation il faut
sécuriser la notion de Holdin animatrice
dans la loi mais également à travers
l'instauration d'un inscrit spécifique
troisième priorité inciter les chefs
d'entreprise à anticiper par le biais
d'un chèque conseil pour la transmission
qui sera attribué notamment aux
dirigeants entre 55 ans et 65 afin de
financer les frais de diagnostic
puisqu'on s'est rendu compte que les TPE
PME étaient les grands oubliés de cette
affaire quatrième priorité le soutien la
transmission salariée qui passe par une
véritable incitation fiscale et un
fléchage de formation à la reprise enfin
nous insistons sur la nécessité de la
simplification des démarches décédant et
des reprenants en structurant la
coordination au niveau national et
régional avec les différents acteurs
privés publics il nous semblait
pertinents de mettre un focus là-dessus
et que la délégation des entreprises
aient un rôle à jouer dans cette
coordination bien évidemment l'objectif
de cette coordination aura tout
simplement un relayé les informations de
aussi apporter des éléments des bonnes
pratiques dans les territoires auprès de
nos entreprises dans les semaines qui
suivront la journée des entreprises nous
déposerons une proposition loi reprenant
une recommandations et nous proposons
tout simplement des amendements dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance 2023
car il est urgent d'agir pour nos
entreprises
voilà pour ces témoignages et ce travail
en cours et les co-rapporteurs que vous
avez vu dans ce reportage sont parmi
nous et pourront bien sûr échanger avec
vous tout à l'heure sur ce rapport qui
concernant la transmission d'entreprise
le rapport de la commission sera examiné
le 27 octobre prochain et vous avez les
meilleures pages je dirais le résumé
dans votre sac et normalement ce
document est également consultable en
ligne alors réussir la transmission et
la reprise d'entreprise une priorité
dans nos territoires nous allons aborder
la question avec les différents invités
que je vous présente Florent boniou à ma
droite Florent bognioud dirigeant de
l'entreprise sobrefer c'est une société
bretonne de ferraillage spécialisée dans
la réalisation d'armatures métalliques à
votre droite Monsieur boniou Madame
Nelly et moi l'adjian qui est directrice
générale du groupe aladjian leader des
solutions globales dans les secteurs de
la construction des Mines et de
l'Industrie nous poursuivons avec Maître
Jean-François début quoi avocat
fiscaliste membre du Cercle des
fiscalistes et de l'Institut des avocats
conseils fiscaux et puis également avec
nous à cette tribune Frédéric parnain de
la direction de la législation fiscale à
Bercy alors comme la table ronde
précédente je vous propose un petit
propos liminaire de 3 ou 4 minutes et
puis ensuite nous débattrons ici et
échange avec la salle pour reposer les
questions alors Florent Bonnier où je me
tourne tout d'abord vers vous sobre et
faire peut-être en quelques mots nous
présenter l'entreprise et puis on
aimerait bien que vous nous expliquiez
surtout comment s'est déroulée la
reprise de l'entreprise que vous dirigez
aujourd'hui
l'histoire et les motivations sont très
intéressantes alors déjà deux mots sur
l'entreprise et après comment vous en
êtes arrivé là si je puis dire bonjour à
toutes et à tous
donc Florent boniou j'ai 43 ans
j'ai repris donc sobrifère il y a un an
donc sobrifer société bretonne de
ferraillage basé à l'augmentia Plouzané
à l'ouest de Brest donc à la pointe
bretonne l'extrême ouest nous sommes 21
collaborateurs pour une activité qui
approche les 3 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
nous réalisons des armatures métalliques
pour le béton armé c'est-à-dire qu'on va
travailler l'acier en bobine ou en barre
on va couper l'acier on va former
l'acier et on va souder cet acier pour
réaliser des poutres métalliques on ne
fait pas de béton ensuite ces poutres
métalliques vont être distribués sur le
secteur Brestois à tous les les acteurs
du gros œuvre et ces entreprises vont
ensuite couler le béton directement sur
chantier ou dans des entreprises de
préfabrication
pour réaliser
les bâtiments
du secteur Brestois
donc voilà une très belle entreprise
alors cette entreprise a une histoire
évidemment comme toutes les sociétés
quelle était les comment elles évolue
aujourd'hui alors c'est une entreprise
qui a 50 ans cette année elle a été
créée en 1972
en fait c'était une entreprise familiale
à la base c'est l'oncle
du cédant qui a créé l'entreprise et qui
a ensuite transmis l'entreprise à son
chef d'atelier et ce même chef d'atelier
et revenu vers le fondateur et
l'entreprise a été transmise en 2002 au
neveu qui me l'a transmise il y a une
année
alors je vais vous raconter un peu
comment je suis arrivé à reprendre cette
entreprise en fait j'étais dans un grand
groupe international je dirigeais une
entité de 50 personnes et ça fait en
fait j'ai toujours voulu entre prendre
dans les marchés et ça faisait 4 ans que
je voulais entreprendre et me mettre à
mon compte mais je ne savais pas par
quel bout va prendre le sujet c'était
pas il y avait pas un guichet unique qui
disait venez ici et vous allez pouvoir
reprendre l'entreprise donc
ça c'est fait par bouche à oreille j'ai
rencontré un mon conseil et depuis
quatre ans alors on parle pas de
fiscalité de choses comme ça on parle de
mes de mes goûts et de ce que j'ai envie
de faire et en fait ça a été tout un
travail
de
sur moi-même qu'est-ce que je voulais
exactement reprendre parce qu'on a plein
d'idées préconçues on veut reprendre une
entreprise dans le secteur que l'on
connaît et moi je me suis fait l'idée au
bout de plusieurs années que j'allais
pas reprendre une entreprise dans le
secteur que je connaissais les travaux
publics et est-ce que le cédant par
exemple vous a dit moi je vous laisse
l'entreprise à tel ou telle condition
alors oui est-ce que vous avez eu les
mains franche dès le début alors en fait
la transmission ça a été très simple on
s'est vu en novembre 2020 pendant une
heure on avait été mis en contact il m'a
fait visiter l'entreprise et à la fin de
la visite il me dit moi je veux deux
choses je veux première chose je veux
que l'entreprise reste à l'augmenter
Plouzané aujourd'hui 21 salariés c'est
la plus grosse entreprise de logMAR et
Plouzané 5300 habitants donc ce sont 20
familles qui habitent le 120 familles
qui habitent la moitié habile la commune
et les autres habitent aux alentours il
m'a dit je veux que ça reste là j'ai des
propositions
financières très intéressante mais ce
sont des concurrents qui sont en dehors
du département donc je ne veux pas je
veux que ça reste là et pour que ça
reste là je veux vendre les parts et les
murs et moi je lui dis ça tombe bien moi
si j'achète c'est les parts et les murs
pour pouvoir
bien réaliser mon projet donc ça je lui
dis ok on y va et il m'a dit bon
accessoirement je veux cette somme pour
l'entreprise j'ai dit ok voilà c'était
fait et après le reste n'a été que on va
dire paperasse
la confiance a été mise dès le départ en
fait c'est c'est ça le principal sujet
la confiance moi je me préparais depuis
quatre ans alors
il y a toute une préparation donc
j'avais fait la préparation dans la tête
j'avais ma cible on avait tapé dans les
dans les mains faut préparer le
portefeuille aussi voilà faut préparer
le portefeuille et le portefeuille alors
vous allez rire mais le portefeuille je
le prépare depuis 4 ans
concrètement il y a 5 ans on a changé
les deux voitures parce que je me suis
dit je vais entreprendre donc les deux
voitures seront changées j'aurais plus à
penser ça c'était les voitures de la
famille les voitures de la famille je
parle des voitures de la famille et
il a fallu sortir comme on dit les
bijoux de famille donc il a fallu mettre
de l'argent sur la table donc j'ai bien
réfléchi moi j'ai racheté tout seul
l'entreprise donc j'ai un apport je vais
vous dire qui a été de 155000 euros
dans cette entreprise ça l'a fait avec
les banques ça l'a bien fait mais
aujourd'hui le problème c'est les gens
qui sont pas forcément préparés qui
n'ont pas eu on va dire ma démarche
comment vont-ils faire cet apport alors
vous allez me dire il y a des
aides oui il y a des prêts il y a des
prêtres au zéro j'ai eu des prêts à zéro
mais c'est quand on a signé pour
l'entreprise c'est pas ça ne fait pas
partie de l'apport donc il y a un vrai
vrai sujet sur ça on y reviendra tout à
l'heure notamment la relation avec les
banques parce que c'est important on a
beau avoir un projet parfois ça suit pas
un projet séduisant c'est vrai qu'il y a
un business plan etc mais ça suit pas
toujours les exemples sont nombreux
Nelly et moi la Dion donc directrice
générale du groupe Aladdin vous allez
nous dire en quelques mots ce dont il
s'agit comme entreprise alors là c'est
une autre expérience pas de reprise mais
la transmission d'entreprise c'est un
cas un petit peu différent il y a quand
même des similitudes sur la forme et le
fond de grandes différences quand même
dans la philosophie alors madame votre
entreprise en deux mots et puis la
philosophie comment comment vous êtes en
pleine vous continuez finalement la
transmission aujourd'hui elle est faite
mais c'est un long travail vous allez
nous expliquer ça tout à fait
donc je représente le groupe palladian
le groupe palladiant propose des
solutions globales dans l'industrie les
mines et la construction donc on est
partenaire du groupe cheval par exemple
donc c'est une société qui a été créée
par mon grand-père qui était mécanicien
d'une société qui est dans le sud de la
France à Sorgues près d'Avignon on fait
aujourd'hui 100 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires on a 300
collaborateurs
250 en France le reste dans nos filiales
à l'international puisqu'on est présent
notamment sur le continent africain au
Burkina Faso au Sénégal
et en Côte d'Ivoire
voilà donc comment ça s'est passé moi je
suis rentré il y a 15 ans dans le groupe
au départ en tant que chef de projet
pour la mise en oeuvre d'un système
d'information assez important qui avait
été décidé par mon père et dont on
n'arrivait pas dont il arrivait pas à
sortir une entreprise de cette taille-là
on faisait à peu près la moitié de
chiffre d'affaires qui met un projet
structurant c'était compliqué c'était
compliqué à digérer c'était compliqué
appréhender et donc il m'a demandé de
rejoindre le groupe en tant que chef de
projet
digital au départ donc c'est ce que j'ai
fait je rentrais de faire mes études
j'étais à Grenoble j'ai fait une école
de commerce je suis parti en Chine pour
une expérience à l'international et il
m'a demandé de rejoindre le groupe j'ai
pas réfléchi j'y suis allé avec cette
mission vraiment chef de projet j'ai
évolué ensuite plutôt sur la partie
assis en pleine digitalisation pleine
transformation de notre de nos outils
puis derrière j'ai occupé pas mal de
fonctions opérationnelles durant ces
années et depuis cinq ans nous
travaillons sur vraiment la transmission
donc mon frère nous a rejoint il y a une
dizaine d'années il faut savoir que
c'était pas un projet c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué c'était pas un projet qui était
préparé c'était pas comme on peut se
dire dans une entreprise familiale on
n'était pas destiné à reprendre
l'entreprise notre père nous a toujours
dit faites ce que vous aimez faire parce
que c'est la passion de ce que vous
aimez faire qui vous fera réussir et
naturellement on est arrivé avec mon
frère à se retrouver dans cette
entreprise familiale dans le sud de la
France passionné par ce qu'on faisait et
envie de dire à notre père où il
entreprises on veut la reprendre et on
veut la reprendre ensemble donc notre
père a 68 ans donc il est pas si âgé que
ça mais ça fait déjà une dizaine
d'années que il voilà qu'il qu'il
commence à réfléchir et qu'on commence à
réfléchir parce que reprendre une
entreprise et la transmettre c'est aussi
organisé toute la gouvernance organisée
des holding animatrices pour pouvoir
démêler un petit peu toute cette toute
cette entreprise et pouvoir la
transmettre dans des bonnes conditions
il y a une holding patrimoniale c'est ça
on y reviendra tout à l'heure en détail
pour voir comment vous travaillez mais
c'est bien structurer vous-même vous
êtes directrice générale parce que vous
êtes né je crois du groupe président du
groupe
parce que vous êtes né dans la famille
comment ça se passe est-ce que je suis
né parce qu'on a on a mis en œuvre avec
mon frère une présidence tournante
trois ans trois ans effectivement pour
pour être aussi sur cette logique de on
dirige ensemble on est coéquipier dans
cette direction là alors il a fallu se
mettre d'accord faire un pacte
d'actionnaires alors c'est sûr qu'entre
frères et sœurs c'est toujours un peu
antinomique mais il était important pour
notre père et pour nous qu'on est
absolument les mêmes ambitions parce que
on le sait aussi la transmission
d'entreprises familiale peut se mal se
passer et c'est important même si on est
frère et sœur et qu'on a des liens
familiaux que des choses soient écrites
et soient structurées donc oui on a on a
transformé le groupe depuis une dizaine
d'années pour pouvoir le pour pouvoir le
transmettre en sérénité juste je précise
aussi que notre père avait pas eu cette
chance puisque lui il a dû reprendre le
groupe à la mort de notre grand-père il
y a rien n'avait été préparé et il s'est
retrouvé aussi confronté à une situation
forcément qu'il a qu'il a un petit peu
dépassé
bien exemple concret superbe témoignage
alors maître Jean-François début quoi
justement on vient de voir deux cas
différents reprises et transmission
est-ce que les deux exercices sont
réellement différents sur le fond
le second effectivement est un petit peu
plus complexe encore parce qu'il met en
jeu des relations familiales et des
relations qui font que la gouvernance se
transmet dans le temps et puis les
paramètres techniques sont un petit peu
plus compliqués parce que ça relève du
droit civil de la famille et d'une
fiscalité complètement différente d'une
session une session de titres supportent
des droits d'enregistrement un taux qui
n'est pas extrêmement élevé une
succession une donation ça supporte une
fiscalité qui est beaucoup plus lourde
et donc ça suppose une anticipation et
c'est ce que vous avez très bien écrit
on peut avoir des transmissions par des
scènes brutales malheureusement et c'est
la catastrophe quelquefois comme ça n'a
pas été anticipé et puis on a aussi
d'autres transmissions qui sont entre
vif c'est les meilleures hypothèses où
toute la gouvernance les relations
familiales etc sont traitées et il y a
un volet sur lequel je voudrais insister
qui est également important et la
délégation on a fait l'objet d'une
partie de son c'est toute la dimension
fiscale de la transmission il faut
absolument maîtriser cette fiscalité de
la succession ou de la donation faute de
quoi la transmission sera extrêmement
difficile donc le message que je
voudrais livrer mais je suis plus un
technicien c'est qu'il faut vraiment
appréhender ces questions suffisamment
tôt le plus tôt possible bien les
examiner bien les gérer dans le temps
c'est vraiment un paramètre important
pour réussir une transmission familiale
il a transmission familiale c'est la
deuxième voie de transmission quand on
n'a pas une session elle est aussi
importante pour l'économie pour la
transmission des entreprises
c'est-à-dire anticiper au maximum et
avoir cette vision et l'analyse fiscale
et juridique donc besoin de conseils et
de parler finalement oui oui puis d'être
conscient de la chose et il s'en occuper
alors je sais bien que c'est difficile
quand on est dans le quotidien du chef
d'entreprise on a plein d'autres
préoccupations mais cette question là
elle est quand même fondamentale si on
veut protéger son entreprise parce que
le décès accidentel par exemple peut
jamais être complètement écarté et ça
peut être un vrai traumatisme quand ça
n'a pas été anticipé alors dans la
droite ligne Frédéric baronin de la
direction de la législation fiscale à
Bercy transmission reprise SQD deux
options et plus avantageuse que l'autre
à vos yeux et aux yeux de Bercy je pense
que enfin pour commencer il y a pas il y
a pas d'option privilégiée par Apple
lune par rapport à l'autre il y a aussi
des choix des choix internes
effectivement à la famille
ou aux aspirations de l'entrepreneur je
vais juste peut-être auparavant recadrer
un petit peu le le mon intervention je
suis en ce qui me concerne effectivement
au dans un bureau très particulier de la
direction de la législation fiscale je
ne tout ça pour dire que en particulier
je ne m'occupe pas des mutations des
droits de mutations à titre onéreux je
suis sur le bureau de la fiscalité du
patrimoine à l'intérieur de la
sous-direction de la fiscalité des
particuliers donc effectivement je suis
assez enchâssé et par conséquent
relativement limité dans ma capacité de
réponse compte tenu de mes attributions
donc dans certaines situations je serais
amené effectivement à ne pas intervenir
cela étant dit pour pour revenir sur sur
ce que ce que vous disiez il y a en tout
état de cause au sein de notre bureau
aussi comme dans l'ensemble de la
direction de la législation fiscale des
préoccupations enfin on est assez
sensible effectivement aussi bien la
transmission sous forme de cession que à
la transmission sous forme de
transmission à titre gratuit je preuve
que dans notre bureau on a quand même
assez largement
participé effectivement à l'amélioration
du sort des transmissions des transferts
des sessions
puisque en Suisse d'avoir baissé le
d'avoir mis en place le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique
au cours de la précédente législature ça
s'est aussi accompagné du maintien de ce
qu'on appelle communément dans le jargon
l'amende l'abattement papy qui en fait
l'abattement de 500.000 euros pour les
sessions de enfin pour les sessions de
sessions d'entreprise envie du départ en
retraite qui a été maintenu alors que
effectivement il y a quand même beaucoup
d'autres dispositifs qui ont été renié
avec la mise en place du pfu donc en
fait cet abattement propre aux personnes
qui
dans un délai qui précède ou suit de
deux ans leur départ en retraite et leur
cessation d'activité a été maintenue en
plus de ça on a même poussé
pousser les préoccupations puisque dans
la période du covid effectivement les
sessions étaient compliquées donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle la loi de
finance pour 2022 a
ménager déjà une prorogation de ce
dispositif jusqu'en 2024 jusqu'à fin
2024 d'une part et puis d'autre part mis
en place une faculté pour les pour les
personnes qui sont partis en retraite
depuis 2019 de pouvoir qui est de
pouvoir céder leur entreprise dans un
délai non pas de deux ans mais de trois
ans
suivant leur départ en retraite
nous sommes également sensibles et je
crois qu'effectivement
personne ne n'ira autour de la table à
la préoccupation des transmissions à
titre gratuit puisque effectivement nous
avons notamment au cours de la
précédente les statuts
a apporté quand même bon nombre de
modifications et d'ajustement au pacte
du trail d'assouplissement
justement pour pour faciliter pour
fluidifier la réalisation de ce type de
transmission
il faut quand même avoir en tête et ça
c'est notre idée fort c'est c'est un
point si s'il y a vraiment une chose que
je que je dois que je dois prendre un
message que je dois porter c'est que
aussi monsieur perdant pour
ce propos liminaire alors effectivement
vous avez en préambule allumé un
contrefeu sur la réponse éventuellement
des questions qui seraient posées on va
faire pour le mieux mais voilà vous nous
éclairerez dans la mesure de dans les
limites de votre périmètre entre
guillemets alors Florent Benou je
reviens avec vous on va rentrer dans la
dans la cuisine vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait une âme
d'entrepreneur en fait pour vraiment
reprendre une une entreprise avec la
notion du temps qui est importante le
temps long comment on se prépare
concrètement vous avez dit tout à
l'heure l'investissement vous avez
préparé la famille etc mais on travaille
avec des avocats
comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui alors comme je disais il y a
pas de guichet unique et quand on veut
entreprendre moi j'étais un peu perdu
donc c'est beaucoup le bouche à oreille
et donc j'ai j'ai
contacté un avocat qui m'ont conseille
depuis 4 ans et
après j'ai fait partie aussi pendant
pendant deux ans du du CR a qui a permis
de m'éveiller encore plus à la à la
reprise d'entreprise
en fait c'est la discussion c'est c'est
voilà c'est c'est définir son son projet
quoi en fait et entrepreneur je pense
que alors
anecdotique mais quand j'étais dans mon
ancien travail on était dans on avait
des réunions de direction régionale et
on était 10 autour de la table des chefs
d'entreprise et notre directeur régional
disait dans la salle je sais que que
vous êtes deux entrepreneurs en fait
voilà il avait il avait cerné il avait
vu deux parce que je sais pas on
entreprenait plus que les autres on
n'avait pas peur d'y aller voilà donc
c'est peut-être pas donné à tout le
monde je pourrais pas dire mais moi ça
me voilà ça me tient à cœur depuis
longtemps parce qu'après dans
entreprendre
il y a le il y a l'humain qui est dedans
et il y a l'humain des salariés et ça
c'est très très important je sais que
moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup mes salariés
et en fait l'entreprise ben c'est pas
c'est c'est la valeur de l'entreprise ce
sont les salariés le chef d'entreprise
est là pour pour mettre un peu de
l'huile dans les rouages mais
la base c'est vraiment les salariés et
voilà j'avais vraiment moi envie de de
partager ça avec les salariés
une grande aventure humaine est-ce que
on peut dire vu votre expérience est-ce
que vous avez vécu entre guillemets pour
y parvenir peut-on dire pouvez vous dire
que la France ces institutions
ces banques
favorisent la reprise d'entreprise
aujourd'hui en France quelle est votre
regard sur l'appréhension de la reprise
la gestion de la reprise d'entreprise
aujourd'hui par les Français moi ça
c'est alors pour moi ça s'est très bien
passé mais parce que je me suis préparé
il y a des aides j'ai eu des prêts à
taux zéro donc après la reprise j'ai
bénéficié de de 50000 euros de prêt à
taux zéro donc ça ça aide à trésorerie
en Bretagne on a un programme qui
s'appelle le programme Breizh Fab qui
est développé par la Région Bretagne et
en fait pour vous décrire pendant
pendant 12 journées j'ai j'ai
droit à des à des consultants qui vont
m'aider à on va dire à suivre mon projet
à transformer l'entreprise et
ça c'est voilà c'est c'est une aide de
plus de 20000 €. donc c'est très il faut
que vous en fassiez la demande donc il
faut en faire la demande il faut en
faire la demande mais
moi je trouve que tout est tout est bien
coordonné ce que j'ai vu en France
aujourd'hui le problème à mon avis va
être pour les les petites entreprises
qui ont du mal à être reprises pourquoi
parce qu'il parce qu'il va manquer des
des sous en fait
le
moi j'ai mis 150 000 euros il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui qui
n'arriveront pas à mettre dessous dans
leur projet de reprise et on voit que et
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont pas suivies
par les banques le business plan n'est
pas bon comment on l'explique
[Musique]
des fonds propres et lui ça lui
permettrait de rester un peu en conseil
de la structure parce que bon parfois la
retraite est mal vécue par certains
quand on a consacré sa vie à une à une
entreprise donc frilosité des banques
quand même en gros en dessous de 300000
c'est pas la peine d'y aller oui c'est
malheureux mais enfin bon voilà le c'est
important je sais pas s'il y a des
banquiers dans la salle d'ailleurs mais
ce qui m'étonnerait mais bon voilà lever
la main personne n'ose bon très bien
Madame et moi ladjian dans la droite
est-ce que vous rencontrez les mêmes bon
là vous on est dans une dans une
entreprise supérieure quand même puis la
démarche est différente vous avez autant
de difficultés vous avez eu autant de
difficultés pour pour vos différentes
démarches pour arriver là où vous en
êtes aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez été aidé ou pas
vraiment
[Musique]
du mouvement des entreprises de taille
intermédiaires on a on s'est un peu
réparti les sujets avec mon frère et
notre père la chance qu'on a eu aussi
c'est d'être tous les trois ensemble et
de pouvoir chacun travailler des sujets
et aller chercher les conseils à
l'extérieur aller chercher des banques
qui pouvaient nous accompagner dans
cette démarche là et ce et ce temps long
on va dire là ensuite
je pense que le pacte du trail
voilà on l'a utilisé on l'utilise c'est
un formidable outil pour la transmission
des entreprises il a fallu qu'on nous
l'explique parce que c'est pas forcément
des choses qui sont familières pour
chacun d'entre nous
donc je salue le travail qui est fait
sur ce sur ce sujet là et qui continue
d'être fait voilà après là encore je le
dis c'est du temps long c'est de la
préparation c'est des réflexions parce
qu'il a fallu que notre père soit prêt
c'est toujours aussi une question de que
le cédant soit prêt et que les
repreneurs le soient aussi
donc on n'est pas dans le cadre de
sobrefaire mais voilà il y a aussi et un
bon nombre de transmission d'entreprises
qui se passent mal c'est aussi parce que
le cédant n'est pas prêt alors il se dit
prêt mais il est pas prêt véritablement
à céder les rênes de son entreprise
parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de
conditions aussi de direction
opérationnelles voilà et d'engagement
des titres donc c'est vrai qu'à partir
du moment où on rentre dans ces
dispositifs on cède quand même la main à
la fois les titres de la société mais
aussi les mains opérationnelles
du groupe alors justement mettre début
quoi sur de l'utilité de la transmission
familiale
transmission donc qui est l'affaire de
la personne qui est à votre gauche
est-ce qu'on peut faire une petite
Gérard benchmark enfin une comparaison
entre la France et l'Allemagne parce
qu'on sait que l'Allemagne c'est le
mittelston donc c'est vraiment le tissu
de PME est-ce que on a des exemples
concrets à prendre chez eux en fait on a
un déficit de transmission familiale en
France qui est tout à fait dramatique
puisque en fait on estime il n'y a pas
de chiffres comme ça a été indiqué tout
à l'heure par la délégation très précise
sur la transmission on n'a pas une
observation statistique précise en
France de la transmission d'entreprise
mais toutes les sources concordent pour
dire qu'on a environ 15% des
transmissions qui sont familiales et 85%
qui sont des ventes des sessions
financées avec un tiers extérieur on
estime qu'en Allemagne le taux est à peu
près de 50 à 60% de transmission
familiale et 50 à 40 de transmission par
session en Italie la transmission
familiale c'est 70% et en Suède c'est
pratiquement 90%. donc en fait on a une
transmission un mode de transmission qui
est tout à fait différent avec les pays
voisins qui sont beaucoup plus orientés
vers des transmissions familiales que
nous donc c'est un constat après les
causes sont complexes et profondes mais
sont en partie liées à notre fiscalité
alors pourquoi la transmission familiale
est vraiment importante et pourquoi il
faut quand même s'y intéresser tenter de
la développer ça peut d'abord toucher
toutes les entreprises il y a des
petites PME qui est difficile de
transmettre parce qu'elles sont dans des
zones géographiques où il est pas si
facile que ça de faire venir des
repreneurs il y a des zones qui
effectivement sont un petit peu
délicates on a marché équilibré de la
session il y a à peu près autant de
repreneurs que de vendeurs mais il est
déséquilibrés géographiquement en fait
on a plus de repreneurs en Île-de-France
et moins de repreneurs dans certaines
zones plus difficiles et donc la
transmission familiale ça peut être une
sortie en disant mais je retrouve pas un
acheteur pour ma société mais si j'ai un
enfant ou un salarié à qui je peux la
transmettre c'est peut-être une solution
après pour les très différentes
entreprises c'est aussi très important
on a quand même dans notre économie un
certain nombre de très très grandes
entreprises qui sont des piliers
fondateurs qui sont toujours familiales
depuis des générations et qui sont
détenus par des dizaines ou des
centaines de cousins
issus des fondateurs si on ne permet pas
la transmission familiale tous ces
groupes là seront vendus et c'est
considérables dans l'économie nationale
et enfin pour les PME qui peuvent être
le stand de l'ETI et on a plusieurs
exemples ici il faut du temps on ne
vient pas une ETI instantanément sauf
modèle économique et extraordinaire
c'est des choses qui se construisent
dans le temps et donc si on ne permet
pas les transmissions familiales pas sur
des sessions qui peuvent conduire à des
pertes de savoir-faire des
délocalisations d'emplois et qui en tout
cas sont plus onéreuses pour la société
puisqu'il faut financer le rachat donc
la société doit plus ou moins payer
ensuite sous forme de distribution de
dividendes le remboursement des prêts
nécessaires à son rachat donc tout ça ça
milite pour qu'on ait des transmissions
familiales
autant que possible je dirais et qui
puisse au moins couvrir tout ce qui
n'est pas possible de céder à titre des
rues parce qu'il y a pas le repreneur ou
parce qu'il y a pas le financement vous
entendre la transmission et peu
consommatrice de capital en fait la
transmission familiale en fait le seul
consommation de capital qu'on peut avoir
c'est le coût de la transmission au
niveau fiscale mais qui peut être
fortement réduit par le pack du trail on
y videra tout à l'heure et l'éventuelle
besoin du chef d'entreprise Sedan de
reconstituer un patrimoine privé parce
que très fréquemment un chef
d'entreprise un patrimoine privé
relativement modeste par rapport à la
valeur de son entreprise et quand il la
donne à ses enfants mais il a failli ne
perçoit pas de contrepartie financière
sauf à la marge donc en fait il y a pas
besoin de financement important on peut
rester sur le pacte du trait justement
expliquez-nous un petit peu les avancées
avantages inconvénients et comment on
peut faire évoluer le système alors le
pacte du trail c'est un dispositif en
fait purement fiscal qui sert à
favoriser les donations ou les
successions qui portent sur les
entreprises pourquoi est-ce qu'on a le
problème parce qu'en France on a un
barème de droit de mutation à titre
gratuit qui est absolument
considérable qui est hors de commun avec
tous les autres pays européens en fait
on a le troisième barème le plus lourd
du monde à titre d'exemple des droits de
succession en France très rapidement
pour une entreprise qui a un petit peu
de valeur on monte dans une tranche à
45%. donc évidemment si on demande à un
chef d'entreprise qui donne à ses
enfants de payer pratiquement la moitié
de la valeur sous forme d'impôts de
succession c'est généralement
strictement impossible situation qu'on a
connu dans les années 82 à 83 à 2000 il
n'y avait pas de dispositif particulier
il y a pratiquement pas eu de
transmission d'entreprises familiales et
on a eu un décroissance ou une stabilité
du nombre de pays en France on en avait
à peu près autant qu'en Allemagne en 80
aujourd'hui on en a 4500 à 5000
l'Allemagne en a 13000 parce qu'entre 80
et 2000 on n'a pas pu faire de
transmission familiale alors le pack du
trail est venu pour essayer de créer les
conditions meilleures d'une transmission
dédiée à l'entreprise alors c'est
assorti d'un certain nombre de
conditions qui permettent d'expliquer
l'écart de fiscalité avec les autres
redevables
gros il faut s'engager à conserver avec
sa famille l'entreprise pendant au moins
6 ans et que la famille de la dirige
avec un certain pourcentage du capital
donc on accompagne la transmission en
stabilisant le capital social et le
pouvoir dans la société ce qui est très
favorable d'ailleurs à la transmission
elle-même puisque c'est un temps la
transmission où on a quand même des
phénomènes un peu de bascule de
gouvernance de bascule de dirigeants
donc on stabilise les choses on oblige
les actionnaires à se parler à
l'encadrer comme vous l'avez fait avec
votre frère avec votre père et les
avantages qui sont attendus c'est une
exonération de 75% de sa valeur qui
n'est pas soumise aux droits de
succession et des avantages
complémentaires qui peut être une
réduction d'impôts de 50% ou une
réduction quand on conserve l'usufruit
alors quand on regarde ce que ça donne
pour une entreprise qui a une certaine
valeur la succession donc par décès ça
coûte 11% au lieu de 45% pour un
patrimoine qui n'est pas une entreprise
et quand on donne de son vivant ça coûte
à peu près 5 et demi pour cent alors que
pour un patrimoine ordinaire ça coûte à
peu près 45% donc on a quand même un
gain fiscal qui est extrêmement
significatif alors il faut corriger un
petit peu parce que l'entreprise
généralement payait le même à terme les
droits de donation les droits de
succession ça finit toujours par des
distributions dividendes et le dividende
lui-même est imposé donc la société
quand elle distribue un dividende génère
un impôt complémentaire donc globalement
on est pour une succession autour de 15
à 16%, et pour une donation autour de
8%. alors c'est très bien par rapport
aux 45% de droit commun qu'on a en
France c'est beaucoup moins bien par
rapport à d'autres pays européens qui
peuvent être à 0 en Allemagne par
exemple on a le équivalent d'un pack du
trail où ça coûte rien sous certaines
conditions la transmission est gratuite
alors Frédéric peronin sur cet aspect
fiscal là vous pouvez quand même
répondre
nous apporter quelques quelques
éclairages il y a beaucoup d'assaut
auxquels il faut que je réponde
alors peut-être vous savez à quoi vous
attendre un message je savais
effectivement quoi m'attendre
le premier point pour partir du début
les dmtg en France sont notablement et
notoire moyen élevés il faut quand même
remettre dans le contexte que 80/4 plus
de 80 % des successions en ligne directe
sont aujourd'hui exonérés donc non
imposé compte tenu des des abattements
qui existent par ailleurs indépendamment
de la mise en place du dispositif du
trail ce qui permet quand même aussi de
tempérer ce propos qui est très vite un
propos passionnel quand on parle de
droit de succession ou de droits de
mutation à titre gratuit dans son
ensemble ça devient très vite passionnel
mais en réalité dans les fêtes encore
une fois les transmissions en ligne
directe sont pour 80% d'entre elles non
imposées faut quand même donc en clair
sur 600 000 décès par an il y en a 480
000 qui sont pas imposés faut pas
l'oublier c'est voilà alors après il y a
eu un autre débat sur mais l'autre point
et là c'est un autre aspect qui est sur
laquelle vous pouvez vous détacher un
tout petit peu du micro voilà d'habitude
je me rapproche beaucoup c'est pour ça
l'autre point
sur lequel elle effectivement on nous
reproche qu'il nous reproche de un
manque de chiffres bah ça c'est un fait
nous n'avons nous avons peu de chiffres
nous avons aussi été assez largement
victime dans l'administration fiscale et
ça je parle pour la direction générale
des finances publiques d'un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été adoptées à
des faits d'alléger les obligations
déclaratives quand on allège des
obligations déclaratives forcément on
fait perdre de la matière de la matière
informatique à l'administration donc
effectivement ce déficit d'information
est aussi le corollaire de la
simplification de la vie des usagers
le troisième point et là je vais revenir
sur un autre aspect qui a été abordé
j'ai le souvenir dans la dans la
préférence précédente intervention du
personne qui nous rappelait
qu'effectivement les TPE
représentaient
représentait effectivement au nombre 90%
de notre effectif est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un rapprochement à faire entrer en
définitive et là je parle effectivement
l'absence de chiffres je pose une
question très ouverte est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas un rapprochement à faire entre le
nombre de de TPE et le nombre de
sessions et la part des sessions qu'on a
en France
quelque part ça fait aussi écho aux
propos de Monsieur boniou tout à l'heure
qui disait que les banques n'étaient pas
intéressés au TPE mais est-ce que les
enfants eux-mêmes sont intéressés par
les TPE de leurs parents
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas en définitive une
un lien entre la taille de l'entreprise
et la nature de l'opération qui a
réalisé quand on a effectivement une ti
ou des grandes entreprises qui est
l'essentiel de mon public tout comme
celui de maître debuquois de toute façon
on passe par la transmission donc en
fait derrière les chiffres en nombre des
15% et des 85 %, est-ce que c'est aussi
révélateur de valeur de valeur vénale et
ça effectivement j'en doute j'ai pas de
chiffres je ne peux pas vous le
corroborer mais j'en doute je ne sais
pas si en définitive sociologiquement
derrière les 85% de cession ça ne vise
pas en définitive essentiellement des
TPE
et si derrière les 15% de transmission
ça ne vise pas essentiellement des ETI
et des grandes entreprises c'est je
laisse je livre la question ouverte
parce que effectivement derrière ça il y
a aussi tout un corollaire qui tient au
fait que en ce qui concerne des droits
de mutation à titre gratuit et là on
pourra revenir sur un autre point qui a
été abordé en début de séance
le en ce qui concerne les droits de
mutations antiques gratuits il y a
effectivement pour les transmissions en
ligne directe un taux qui va jusqu'à 45%
mais une batterie davantage qui font que
la transmission en ligne directe est
comme je le rappelais tout à l'heure
exonéré dans plus de 80% des dans plus
de 80% des cas en revanche effectivement
quand on transmet à des tiers les tarifs
sont effectivement beaucoup plus élevés
les tarifs des droits de succès des
droits de mutation à titre gratuit sont
effectivement beaucoup plus élevés
puisque quand on transmet un nom par an
c'est 60%
voilà donc là effectivement tout de
suite c'est sidérant et quand on en cas
de succession après un abattement très
symbolique de 1594 euros donc
effectivement on comprend que la
transmission à titre gratuit ça
fonctionne assez peu alors maintenant on
va parler effectivement des dispositifs
qui sont ciblés notamment s'agissant des
transmissions à titre gratuit
d'entreprise il y a effectivement des
dispositions qui ont été adoptés je le
pacte du trail était effectivement
on va y revenir après mais le pacte du
Treil est effectivement un levier
extrêmement puissant
il y a aussi un autre dispositif qui
existe parce que il est nous avons un
dispositif d'abattement en faveur des
transmissions à titre gratuit opéré au
profit des salariés que ça soit en ligne
directe et cet abattement est quand même
un abattement assez puissant puisqu'il
va jusqu'à 300.000 euros je rappelle que
c'est un abattement par part c'est à
dire qu'effectivement c'est pas la
valeur de l'entreprise qui est
déterminée mais c'est bien la valeur du
bénéfice c'est bien c'est bien ce qui
est reçu à ma connaissance
remarqué il est possible que je me
fourrevois sur ce point là mais je crois
qu'effectivement l'abattement est quand
même assez significatif parce que si
vous un abattement de 300.000 euros même
sur la valeur de l'entreprise compte
c'est une TPE
le la pilule est quand même tout de
suite beaucoup moins amère je vais
maintenant venir au dispositif du Treil
attendez pardonnez-moi on va y revenir
si vous le voulez bien je voudrais
d'abord avoir la réaction des des
entrepreneurs qui ont les mains dans le
cambouis pardon au quotidien
Nelly et moi Johnny donc aujourd'hui
votre réaction à ce que vous venez
d'entendre et puis surtout en
proposition est-ce que vous avez des
propositions à faire vous qui avez
accompagné qui continuait d'accompagner
cette entreprise est-ce que vous avez
besoin d'outils supplémentaires donc
déjà peut-être une réaction d'abord et
puis ensuite quid des propositions et je
poserai la même question à Monsieur
boniou
c'est un débat technique
c'est vrai que ça semble
un petit peu éloigné de la vie de notre
vie de notre vie de repreneur
d'entreprise et d'entrepreneurs parce
que ce qui fait que on a envie de
reprendre une entreprise au-delà de tout
ça tout l'aspect fiscal c'est la passion
de développer quelque chose et
d'entreprendre et cette passion là je
pense que en France on l'a on a des
exemples d'entrepreneurs aujourd'hui si
beaucoup de jeunes ne veulent pas
entreprendre c'est pas parce que c'est
vrai que cette cette capacité
d'entreprendre elle est un tout petit
peu freinée par des débats un peu trop
techniques et un peu trop voilà qui
dépasse la vision de notre
entrepreneuriat que d'autres pays et
pourquoi beaucoup de jeunes ou de moins
jeunes d'ailleurs vont entreprendre
ailleurs parce que c'est vrai que cette
cette vision de l'entrepreneur
aujourd'hui elle doit être mise en avant
voilà on a envie de reprendre les
entreprises on a envie de développer nos
entreprises en France parce que c'est
aussi le sujet
de de
d'investir en France et il faut qu'on
soit capable il faut que la France il
faut que le pays investisse pour faire
comme l'Allemagne aussi permettre de la
souveraineté sur plein de sujets on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure à la fabrication
de masques nous on a un métier qui est
technique on a des soudeurs on est
mécaniciens je reviendrai pas sur le
fait de pas arriver forcément en trouver
facilement mais c'est ces métiers là
qu'on doit et nous qu'on veut protéger
qu'on veut protéger en France et qu'on
veut développer voilà juste pour revenir
gros vous voulez dire que vous êtes face
à l'entrepreneuse que vous êtes et face
à une administration qui est parfois un
peu aveugle et obtenue l'administration
enfin voilà aujourd'hui il y a des
dispositifs les dispositifs
existent je pense qu'on travaille de
mieux en mieux et en collaboration
néanmoins il faut continuer il faut
sanctuariser un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour les pérenniser parce
que c'est vrai que vous l'avez vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure ce sont des
dispositifs qui sont assez nouveaux
quand même sur le le territoire et en
France donc il faut pérenniser il faut
continuer parce que le travail de
reprendre les entreprises et de
transmettre les entreprises en France
c'est un travail qui va durer et qui
doit durer plusieurs années alors en
termes de proposition justement est-ce
que vous avez une mesure à laquelle vous
tenez particulièrement à laquelle vous
pensez vous pensez qu'elle pourrait vous
aider ou aider même les autres
transmissions d'entreprise
on va parler on parler aussi
d'indicateurs nous on vit avec des
indicateurs dans nos entreprises parler
de manque de chiffres et demande
d'indicateurs je porte avec le métier la
proposition de mettre en place un
indicateur de transmission concret réel
cette mise en place là
pour en voir les résultats nous on met
en place des indicateurs dans une
entreprise pour mesurer les résultats
effectivement et pas être sur des débats
de
sur des débats de fonds ou de
philosophie mais réellement est-ce que
est-ce que ces dispositifs aujourd'hui
permettent de transmettre mieux et
permettre une meilleure parce que vous
avez cité les chiffres tout à l'heure de
d'aller vers plus de transmission
d'entreprise en France
parce qu'on est loin on est loin des
chiffres donc la mise en place d'un
indicateur je pense que c'est pas très
coûteux c'est assez facile à faire
déjà pour savoir de quoi on parle et
est-ce que vraiment ces entreprises sont
transmises et vous parliez de
souveraineté il y a aussi la notion de
compétitivité de ces entreprises par
rapport à la concurrence notamment
européenne et allemande
Florent bognou même question j'irai
réaction à ce que vous avez entendu et
puis est-ce que vous avez des
propositions vous en tant que chef
d'entreprise aujourd'hui pour vraiment
mener votre mission jusqu'au bout est-ce
que vous êtes en attente des attentes
particulières alors comme l'indiqué
Nelly je pense que qu'en France toute la
fiscalité
ça fonctionne bien quoi c'est pas le le
premier sujet alors c'est très technique
mais quand on entreprend quand on
reprend une entreprise quand quand on
reprend une entreprise familiale
en fait c'est la passion c'est le le
territoire quoi on va dire que le
l'argent c'est le second moi je vous
cache pas que je
l'argent c'est pas du tout mon moteur et
je sais que je gagnerai pas ce que je
gagnais avant c'est c'est vraiment le
projet il faut il faut donner envie aux
jeunes
de d'entreprendre il faut leur faciliter
les choses je parlais des des banquiers
qui vont pas forcément prêter pour des
des petits de reprises je pense qu'il y
a vraiment quelque chose à faire à ce à
ce sujet moi j'ai pas eu de soucis parce
que je m'étais très bien préparé
mais il y a quatre ans c'était un peu le
flou pour moi il y avait pas comme je
disais tout à l'heure encore il y avait
pas de guichet unique je savais pas où
aller donc avec mes relations j'ai j'ai
trouvé la porte d'entrée mais en fait
pour pour quelqu'un qui est dans une
entreprise c'est vraiment vraiment flou
quoi donc
centraliser les dispositifs d'aide
éventuellement de conseils c'est créer
une nouvelle structure c'est c'est alors
les transmissions sont les les
des transmissions est reprise c'est
assez on va dire assez secret c'est pas
c'est pas en devanture des grands
magasins cherchent
à reprendre une boutique
je pense qu'il y a c'est dès le plus
jeune âge de l'école qui qui va falloir
insuffler
des
dispositifs pour dire voilà il y a ça et
dans quelques années vous pourrez
reprendre une entreprise après moi j'ai
pas d'idée concrètes mais voilà il y a 4
ans moi c'était j'étais dans le fou quoi
donc il va falloir peut-être
rassembler les les les portes d'entrée
faire plus de de pub de publicité sur
sur ça parce que c'est vrai c'est un
c'est un vrai sujet
nous on est on est basé à à la pointe
bretonne aujourd'hui je vous disais
qu'on était la plus grosse entreprise de
logement 5300 habitants c'est vraiment
très important que l'entreprise soit là
20 familles la crainte du cédant
l'ancrage territorial l'ancrage
territorial et c'est très très important
parce que on voit que si les entreprises
ne sont pas reprises localement les
centres décisions vont partir alors ils
vont partir à Rennes ou à Paris et voilà
la casserole à la chaîne donc ça va
casser la chaîne donc il y a un vrai
vrai sujet bon donc ce sont des
chantiers de réflexion mettre début quoi
quelle réforme peut-on envisager
aujourd'hui pour justement aller de
l'avant et faciliter à la fois
transmission et reprise je sais pas s'il
faut faire beaucoup de réformes sur la
partie fiscale de la transmission
familiale parce qu'elle en a déjà subi
beaucoup le pack du trail en fait existe
depuis 2000 donc ça fait 22 ans il y a
déjà eu 17 réforme législatives donc
c'est un dispositif qui est assez
complexe mais à chaque fois on le
modifie ça fait perdre un petit peu de
stabilité ou redevable au Conseil qui
sont obligés de se réapproprier le
système l'administration qui doit à
nouveau le commenter mais ça prend un
certain temps et ça gèle un petit peu
les choses donc je pense qu'il faudrait
mieux raisonnablement attendre
laisser un peu fonctionner tel qu'il est
avant d'ambitionner une nouvelle réforme
sur quel levier on peut on peut agir
finalement si ce n'est pas la fiscalité
parce qu'on voit les attentes des
entrepreneurs si on pourrait agir sur la
fiscalité mais en périphérie du pack du
trail dans l'une des propositions de la
délégation par exemple on a un sujet sur
la holding animatrice qui est un sujet
pour des groupes un petit peu
significatifs qu'un sujet très important
en fait c'est un peu une pierre
angulaire de toute la fiscalité du chef
d'entreprise et c'est vrai que cette
notion-là a subi un certain nombre
d'évolutions
jurisprudentiels etc son cadre
législatif n'est pas très formé c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire et donc ça
laisse du flou sur un certain nombre de
sujets de l'insécurité juridique et
c'est dramatique parce que une société
qui est transmise avec une qualification
de animatrice qui se révèle erronée elle
se fait reprendre tous les avantages
fiscaux qu'elle pensait avoir eu au
moment de la transmission au moment de
l'IFI etc donc c'est un point qu'il faut
stabiliser pour qu'il y ait de la
sécurité il s'agit pas d'avoir une
échappatoire mais avoir un régime clair
pour que à l'avance on sache si on y est
ou si on n'y est pas et puis on a des
sujets d'accompagnement aussi du
paiement parce que les droits de
donation qu'il faut payer c'est quand
même un débours fiscal on a un régime
qui permet pour les entreprises d'étaler
sur 15 ans le paiement des droits de
donation des droits de succession ce
régime est ancien il mériterait d'être
un petit peu amélioré dans un certain
nombre de paramètres et enfin pour
rebondir sur la question dont vous
parliez des chiffres et puis de la
motivation je crois que c'est
fondamentale effectivement cette
motivation je crois que c'est assez
différent dans une transmission
familiale parce que ceux qui succèdent
en fait ce sont des enfants et les
enfants ils ont vécu dans une famille de
chefs d'entreprise ils connaissent la
société ils connaissent leur père il
voit bien ce qu'il fait donc la
compréhension de l'entreprise et du
métier chef d'entreprise elle est
acquise je dirais familialement c'est
peut-être plus facile et plus difficile
parfois parce qu'il y a la relation
familiale qui complique les choses quand
il faut passer le relais Nelly non je
voulais dire c'est pas forcément évident
des parents chefs d'entreprise ne font
pas béni et forcément les enfants dans
ni dans l'environnement alors nous
c'était un environnement technique je le
redis donc pas forcément accessible aux
enfants par contre ce qu'on fait nous
avec nos propres enfants c'est que on
essaye de les intéresser les intérêts à
ce qu'on fait les intéressés au métier
les intéressés à comprendre l'entreprise
c'est pas forcément ce que nous on a eu
comme comme exemple puisque notre père
voulait garder la sphère professionnelle
loin de la sphère privée voilà donc
on les prépare à partir de quel âge vous
dites on prépare mes enfants oui déjà
leur en parler oui parce que parce que
parce qu'il faut après je pense que ce
qui a été c'est comprendre l'entreprise
mais vouloir la reprendre ce sont deux
choses différentes donc il y a la
comprendre pour savoir à un moment donné
si on se positionne à vouloir la
reprendre parce que nous on a eu des
exemples aussi et notamment avec avec
notre oncle qui qui s'est retrouvé dans
une entreprise dont il pas forcément
envie et ça pour la transmission des
entreprises c'est aussi un gros sujet il
faut pas y aller parce que on est
l'enfant d'un chef d'entreprise et que
il faut absolument qu'on reprenne notre
flambeau ça amène à des catastrophes en
termes de résultats vous n'êtes pas venu
avec vos enfants mais qu'est-ce qu'il
vous disent quand vous leur parlez de ça
de la transmission de l'avenir est-ce
qu'ils sont déjà conscients à leur âge
ne faites raison c'est quand même très
jeune est-ce qu'ils ont déjà ce qu'ils
intègrent déjà votre votre discours
entre guillemets enfin vous explications
et votre passion surtout voilà ce que
j'essaie de leur transmettre c'est la de
notre métier la compréhension du métier
de ce que l'on fait de ce pourquoi on se
bat au quotidien et pour lequel on passe
du temps hors de la maison parce que ça
c'est important aussi
après ça viendra petit à petit il y a
aucune obligation moi je me suis on sait
pas senti avec mon frère dans
l'obligation absolue de reprendre
l'entreprise ce qui fait que je pense on
a eu un choix libre
non prémédité et qui se fait justement
parce que l'envie est là la passion est
là et bien sûr les dispositifs sont là
aussi pour nous aider et faciliter cette
transmission dans le temps mais mais
c'est vrai que voilà mettre des bu quoi
vous souhaitiez réagir et après c'est la
parole
sujet très intéressant cette façon de
former les jeunes futurs actionnaires le
plus tôt possible et c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment très vertueux
d'ailleurs que connaissent très bien les
grands groupes qui finissent par devenir
des ETI ou des entreprises de taille
internationales qui demeurent familiales
certaines ont des centaines
d'actionnaires familiaux et ils ont
cette culture en fait de former très
leurs jeunes actionnaires pour leur
apprendre ce que c'est que l'entreprise
détecter les éventuelles potentiels de
dirigeants parce que certains le seront
mais d'autres ont simplement
actionnaires et que tous les
actionnaires tous les enfants tous les
futurs détenteurs du capital soient
assez tôt conscients de ce qu'ils
détiennent de leur responsabilités aussi
quelque part et qu'ils aient pas la
surprise un jour de recevoir brutalement
un bloc de titres ou une fonction et
d'être un peu comme votre oncle
peut-être dans une situation de devoir
prendre mais sans grande préparation
donc cette phase de préparation des
générations suivantes elle est
fondamentales peut-être aussi en parler
avec l'Éducation nationale qui a
certainement un rôle à jouer enfin ça
c'est un autre un autre débat et très
compliqué ça pourra faire l'objet d'une
autre journée des entreprises d'ailleurs
alors Frédéric parona sur l'aspect
fiscal
intervenez je dirais avant de passer la
parole au public pour faire une petite
synthèse les changements possibles et
puis le fameux pacte du trail
effectivement
alors je vais essayer de sommaire et pas
trop technique ça va pas être simple
face au maire mais concis
sur les pactes du trek pour rebondir sur
les propos de mettre des bucquois
sa date effectivement 2000
les 22 changements qui sont intervenus
sont tous intervenus modulo quelques
rectifications strictement formelle du
texte pour alléger le dispositif au
commencement en loi de finance pour 2000
on était quand même un dispositif limité
aux transmission par décès
avec 16 ans d'engagement
ok donc on était limité aux transmission
par décès avec 16 ans d'engagement quand
on voit où on en est aujourd'hui le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on a
gagné en souplesse
avec effectivement des conditions qui
sont qui se sont au fil des ans
effectivement notablement allégés c'est
à tel point qu'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui nous dans une situation dans
laquelle on craint même que le conseille
constitutionnel à l'occasion d'un
nouveau rabot qui pourrait être apporté
au texte
ne viennent censurer le texte parce
qu'il serait en inadéquation avec
l'objectif poursuivi au risque
effectivement qu'on soit amener à
refaire un dispositif qui serait en
définitive moins favorable qu'il ne
l'est aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je
rebondis et j'applaudis de toutes mes
mains et de tous mes pieds sur les
propos de mettre début quoi il ne faut
plus toucher au texte voilà ça suffit il
est en plus de ça rédigé justement au
gré de ces asso successifs de briquet de
broc c'est pour ça que la réponse enfin
les commentaires de l'administration
sont outrageuses ont été outrageusement
longs parce que effectivement le texte
est affreusement complexe à comprendre
parce que il a été modifié un peu à
l'emporte-pièce bah c'est la démocratie
c'est ainsi que les textes sont rédigés
c'est pas l'administration fiscale qui
les rédige tous du début à la fin
cela étant dit le dispositif du trail
maintenant voilà si j'ai vraiment un bon
ordre à passer c'est que le produit n'a
plus vocation à être à être à être en
tout cas modifié dans quelques sens que
ce soit je pense qu'il faut préserver le
carreaux du temple un petit temps
pour rebondir sur le concept de holding
animatrice et le souhait exprimé de voir
la notion de holding animatrice crantée
dans le texte légal
je suis un petit peu on est embarrassé
on est on a conscience de ce sujet il
faut quand même avoir aussi conscience
que les holding animatrice à la base si
vous voulez aller voir
l'origine du concept c'était en 1978
pour les écarts de rive à faire la
réévaluation comptable pour tenir compte
de l'inflation et de la purge qui s'y
était adossée et le concept de ligne
animatrice avait été destiné en
définitive en clair et ça encore plus
prégnant par la suite avec la création
de l'impôt sur l'Impôt sur l'impôt sur
la grande fortune le concept de holding
animatrice est attendre tout une
construction complètement prétorienne
pour prendre en considération les grands
capitaines d'industrie les très grandes
familles à la base c'est ça sauf que
effectivement c'est une construction
essentiellement jurisprudentielle qui
est effectivement complètement
transverse elle est pas propre
transmission un titre gratuit et elle
s'applique dans plein d'autres plein
d'autres situations de la vie et de la
vie des entreprises et de la vie fiscale
qui les accompagnent et
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement
quand on fait de la qualification
juridique on s'affranchit toute
considération financière ou subjective
et par conséquent effectivement on ne
dit pas que c'est pour les plus grosses
boîtes et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le concept de holding animatrice est
devenu aussi un outil de fabrication de
de structures juridique à l'effet de
pouvoir effectivement optimiser les
transmissions il faut quand même avoir
conscience qu'à la base la holding
animatrice structurellement c'était pour
les grandes familles c'était pas c'était
pas un outil juridique et c'en est
devenu
voilà
c'est
historiquement c'est c'est les écarts de
réévaluation et ensuite l'IGF les
holding la notion de animatrice c'est
l'impôt sur l'écran de fortune
c'est à ce moment-là qu'elle a connu son
essor en tout état de cause ça reste une
construction jurisprudentielle et on est
effectivement très embarrassé à l'idée
légiférer sur ce sujet on a aujourd'hui
une définition mais qui n'incorpore pas
les critères je vais vous la citer c'est
celle qu'on retrouve à l'article 966 et
qui est très inspiré qui est assez
commune et entendu un jurisprudence une
activité d'une holding animatrice est
une holding c'est une holding animatrice
c'est une activité qui a pour l'activité
principale consiste outre la gestion de
portefeuille dans la participation
active à la conduite de la politique du
groupe et au contrôle de ces filiales
industriels commerciales artisanale
agricole au libéral
le problème c'est que quand on va dans
le coeur du réacteur le problème c'est
comment effectivement on appréhende la
participation active à la conduite de la
politique
on a même été récemment confronté à une
situation de jurisprudence qui nous
montre que cette préoccupation qui
consiste à savoir en définitive comment
on assure de manière opérationnelle le
contrôle des filiales donc et qu'on les
aide comment on les anime c'est un état
de fête nous avons une décision de la
Cour de cassation dans un dans un arrêt
de 2021 qui s'appelle la racine Naria
qui a censuré le fait que on ne peut pas
avoir une holding intimatrice qui qui
n'est qu'une construction juridique
c'est un état de fait donc légiférer
pour fabriquer des critères sur un état
de fait
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
assez compliqué et qu'il vaut peut-être
mieux effectivement laisser à
l'appréciation des juges ça me rappelle
un petit peu mon expérience de juriste
ce qu'on met derrière la notion d'apport
en industrie c'est du talent mais être
capable de le qualifier la notion
d'apport en industrie on ne sait pas
donc si je fais un parallèle
effectivement à un moment il y a des
critères et en l'occurrence savoir
comment diriger une boîte comment animer
quelque part les personnes qui savent le
mieux c'est vrai que c'est les
entrepreneurs eux-mêmes c'est eux qui
mettent la main qui ont ce talent pour
pouvoir en définitive animée les
structures les structures sous-jacentes
alors tout cela est très intéressant je
crois qu'on va pouvoir en discuter parce
qu'il y aura probablement des questions
c'est effectivement à débat très
technique mais qui est très utile parce
qu'on est au cœur de de la problématique
nous avons une petite demi-heure donc
pour échanger comme sur le principe de
la première table ronde je vous
demanderai simplement de vous manifester
de lever la main je vais essayer de
repérer dans l'ordre vous présentez très
rapidement et vous posez la question
Vous faites part de votre échange
monsieur vous avez été le premier donc
je vous donne la parole vous vous
appuyez sur le micro
je dirige un certain nombre de petites
entreprises dans l'équipement de la de
la personne
je voudrais je voudrais revenir sur le
terrain de transmission parce qu'en fait
on a parlé beaucoup de transmission
patrimoniale mais pas beaucoup de
transmission d'entreprises en difficulté
je suis assez d'accord sur les
statistiques je crois que c'est la
structure même
de la taille des entreprises en France
qui créent le problème
et dans une entreprise de 20 personnes
vous avez forcément trois ou quatre
salariés qui font l'entreprise peut-être
les vins d'ailleurs mais probablement
trop ou quatre
c'est salarié lors d'une transmission
d'entreprise
ou d'une difficulté d'entreprise
ont du mal à reprendre eux-mêmes cette
entreprise
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
on leur demande rarement leur avis la
deuxième parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent
il me semble que ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est de créer un compte repreneur
entrepreneur qui correspondrait à deux
ou trois années de salaire c'est à dire
basé à peu près sur les indemnités
chômage parce que bon au bout du bout
pour l'État ça coûterait pas grand chose
si l'entreprise va au tapis de toute
façon il faut indemniser les gens et qui
permettrait à ses salariés de disposer
d'un capital de les intégrer
intellectuellement
et financièrement à l'entreprise de
permettre au chef de l'entreprise de
parler de transmission de cession de
façon claire et limpide parce que on
sait que la confidentialité est aussi un
des éléments dire à vos salariés que
vous allez transmettre vos entreprises
c'est de l'inquiétude c'est du stress
c'est de la démotivation et probablement
des départs et donc une dévalorisation
de
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est les fermentés au
capital on est en train de préparer
aussi cette démarche là parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on va aussi pouvoir
développer notre notre activité
et je pense que c'est une attente des
salariés de la plupart des salariés donc
c'est vrai que c'est pareil c'est encore
une phase nouvelle dans un cadre
d'entreprise mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire
d'intéresser et de permettre aux
salariés de rentrer au capital d'une
entreprise y compris une entreprise
familiale il faut juste un tout petit
peu s'organiser avant pour pas tout
mélanger mettre au début quoi sur ce
point
j'ai moins d'observations parce que ça
sort un peu du cas de la transmission
familiale mais il arrive qu'on est des
hypothèses c'est pas les plus fréquentes
ou un chef d'entreprise qui veut prendre
sa retraite n'a pas de descendant et pas
de repreneur et il arrive qu'il donne la
société assez salariés on a plusieurs
dossiers au cabinet qui ont été réalisés
comme ça et le pacte du trail permet ça
parce que malgré le taux dont parlait
monsieur barman 60% avec le pack du
treuil il peut tomber à 7,5 et donc il y
a des hypothèses où on a des chefs
d'entreprises qui je préfère ce
sacrifier un petit peu patrimonialement
quand il le peuvent et donner
l'entreprise à un successeur qui est
quelqu'un qui est souvent un
collaborateur à qui le font confiance
pour continuer c'est un peu cette même
logique de poursuivre l'ancrage social
l'ancrage territorial d'une PME et qui
peut mieux qu'un salarié qui est là
depuis 15 ou 20 ans continuer à la faire
fonctionner il y a pas tellement de
rupture en plus dans la connaissance de
l'entreprise dans le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise donc les modes après sont
un petit peu poreux entre la
transmission et la session effectivement
c'est pas toujours aussi tranchée que ça
alors nous restons dans cette partie
madame vous souhaitez intervenir et
Monsieur ensuite bonjour je suis
Géraldine bourgeois je suis patronne
d'une petite entreprise d'une toute
petite entreprise de coiffure et
d'esthétique dans l'Yonne moi en fait je
viens juste par ma parole vous alerter
sur le fait que nous entreprises de
l'artisanat la problématique n'est pas
de comment transmettre notre entreprise
moi j'ai repris l'entreprise familial
c'est pas comment reprendre l'entreprise
mais c'est qui va reprendre l'entreprise
aujourd'hui on a depuis des années on a
beaucoup encouragé les études
supérieures et on arrive à une situation
où nous artisan avons beaucoup de mal à
recruter des salariés mais également des
gens qui vont pouvoir faire perdurer nos
activités donc que deviendront tous ces
gens qui sont diplômés du tertiaire
aujourd'hui quand il y aura plus
personne pour produire
est-ce que quelqu'un souhaiterait
prendre Florent bognou non après on en
revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
l'éducation à un gros sujet à ce niveau
là et voilà donc c'est c'est une autre
session mais il y a vraiment un sujet
Comment comment amener les jeunes à la
ou reprises des petites entreprises
c'est voilà faire de la pédagogie faire
de la pédagogie et c'est vrai que oui
maître de Lucas certainement marginal
mais pour avoir des enfants qui sont un
peu dans l'âge de faire des études
supérieures je me rends compte aussi que
malgré le fait de faire des études
supérieures ça n'empêche pas d'envisager
de faire des métiers quelquefois qui
sont pas du tout de la gestion de
grandes entreprises ou travailler dans
des situations extrêmement complexes
certains retrouvent un goût à retrouver
des activités manuelles de gérer des
toutes petites entreprises d'avoir un
rôle social et un ancrage local
également même des enfants qui ont fait
des études supérieures donc c'est pas
non plus aussi tranché je pense que ça
c'est pas que la faute de ce système
éducatif qui les pousse à faire des
études supérieures
oui bonjour Guillaume Ollier alors je
préside d'un côté bénévole 60000 euros
60 000 rebonds accompagnent les
dirigeants qui déposent le bilan au fond
faillite pour les aider à rebondir alors
aujourd'hui nous en accompagnons 600 je
pense que l'année prochaine ça sera
plutôt 1500 la moitié d'entre eux
rebondissent en avec la volonté de
recréer nos entreprises ou de reprendre
une entreprise
c'est des travailleurs ils sont pas tous
jeunes ils savent ce que c'est que faire
une facture c'est pas mal par rapport au
startuper et on se rend compte on se
rend compte quand même qu'une des
difficultés pour la reprise c'est le
manque de d'informations il y a pas un
fichier qui existe de ceux qui
voudraient transmettre pour avoir un
fichier de ceux qui voudraient reprendre
or je vais rassurer madame ce qui
repartent chez nous ils veulent pas dans
ils veulent pas reprendre d'employés
dans un premier temps ils veulent
vraiment recréer leur structure mais on
compte que même s'ils ne veulent pas
quand ils créent on se rend compte que
trois ans après ils ont en moyenne trois
salariés et demi donc il y avait
peut-être quelque chose à faire mais là
aussi par rapport à la remarque de mon
voisin un problème de financement on
sait très bien que les entrepreneurs
n'ont pas droit au chômage mais si on
pouvait prévoir une cagnotte pour les
aider à repartir ça serait quand même
une bonne idée
merci Monsieur on passe au rang suivant
nous vous écoutons oui bonjour André
kervé à doux je dirige une entreprise
spécialisée dans l'ossature bois dans le
dans le Morbihan on a une petite
trentaine je voudrais juste apporter un
témoignage sur deux transmissions dans
cette entreprise la première c'est il y
a 10 ans l'entreprise avait 60 ans le
dirigeant n'avait personne dans sa
famille souhaitant reprendre
l'entreprise il y a une transmission
salariée comment s'est fait le
financement la réserve de participation
a permis aux salariés de monter au
capital les banques ont suivi pourquoi
parce que le dirigeant s'était reproché
de l'Union des Scop qui a un financement
à terme qui vient en appui du
financement bancaire et le vendeur a mis
en place un crédit vendeur
donc le montage s'est fait très
simplement
les choses se sont bien passées la
reprise c'est super moment passé moi je
prends ma retraite potentiellement dans
un an il n'y a pas de souci de
transmission bien évidemment tout est
organisé la gouvernance est là le
conseil d'administration est en place le
successeur en tant que président de
l'entreprise est déjà nommée déjà connue
et tout roule donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que
si on veut garder un ancrage territorial
si on veut transmettre aux salariés les
entreprises c'est possible c'est
possible parce qu'il y a des systèmes
qui existent ils sont sans doute trop
confidentiels aujourd'hui je sais pas
combien il y a de Scop dans la salle
aujourd'hui je pense pas qu'on soit très
nombreux je pense que c'est un ce
mouvement est un mouvement de fond il y
a que 4000 entreprises aujourd'hui en
France organisées sous le format Scop
mais à mon avis c'est une bonne solution
et je vous encourage si vous le
souhaitez à vous rapprocher de vos union
régionales il y en a dans toutes les
régions des Unions Régionales des Scop
et c'est probablement un bon système
merci et bien c'est noté merci Monsieur
pour ce témoignage alors est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres questions par ici oui
monsieur il me semble bien que vous
aviez le verbe
donc Nicolas Touchard je suis associé de
euralia finance radia finance c'est une
banque d'affaires qui est dédiée au PME
donc nous sommes dans la transmission
d'entreprise nous aidons des chefs
d'entreprise à trouver un repreneur et à
l'inverse nous aidons aussi à trouver
des entreprises quand le
ti ou la PME veut faire de la croissance
externe l'an dernier nous avons fait 56
opérations et nous avons 15 bureaux en
France voilà je voulais insister enfin
revenir sur ce qui a déjà été dit
c'est-à-dire
la difficulté qu'il y a de trouver un
repreneur pour les entreprises trop
petites c'est vraiment un sujet parce
qu'en fait à partir d'une certaine
taille si l'entreprise n'a pas de défaut
majeur on trouve toujours un acquéreur
pour cette entreprise là en revanche
l'entreprise trop petite uni personnelle
ou avec très peu d'employés qui
éventuellement dépend trop de son patron
qui éventuellement n'a qu'un ou deux
clients pour celle là c'est très
compliqué de trouver un repreneur et
c'est si vous voyez dans les 700 000
entreprises on a dit tout à l'heure
qu'il y avait 700 000 entreprises qui
seraient à cédées d'ici 10 ans alors
déjà quand j'ai commencé ce métier il y
a 15 ans on disait déjà ça donc je sais
pas si elles sont céder entre-temps ou
si c'est d'autres qui ont alimenté le
tuyau mais en tout cas dans ces 700 000
entreprises on avait bien les deux tiers
qui sont des entreprises très petites et
très difficiles à transmettre en fait
voilà c'est juste le le témoignage que
je voulais apporter témoignage d'un
acteur à part entière madame vous aviez
demandé et Monsieur ensuite
oui bonjour je m'appelle Elodie Garcia
je suis d'Aix-en-Provence et je suis
membre élu à la CCI et ça se compte que
je vais intervenir parce que je suis
très vexé quand on dit que on ne sait
pas où trouver des entreprises à acheter
parce que alors je sais pas si c'est pas
peut-être pas toutes les chambres des
commerces mais sur Aix-Marseille
Provence on a une cellule exprès pour
les gens qui vendent leur entreprise qui
veulent leur acheter et on a même des
études qui sont faites pour justifier de
le bien-être de l'entreprise
potentiellement à racheter donc voilà je
voulais dire qu'il y a quand même des
endroits et la porte d'entrée c'est la
chambre des commerces quoi voilà je vais
faire une remarque là-dessus autre chose
moi je suis aussi chef d'entreprise j'ai
des enfants moi mes enfants ils veulent
pas reprendre mon entreprise ils ont le
temps ils sont jeunes mais elles veulent
pas parce qu'elle voit que c'est
difficile d'être chef d'entreprise on
n'est pas aidé on a vécu des crises on
rentre tard le soir là je suis en
déplacement à Paris et en fait il y en a
pour beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui qui
se disent c'est pas forcément la vie que
je veux donc peut-être qu'aussi si la
vie de patron de petites entreprises
c'est sûr que sur les ETI c'est un peu
différent on voit aussi la grosse
société et plein de salariés mais sur
les PME peut-être que les enfants se
disent mais en fait j'ai pas envie
d'avoir la vie de mes parents donc voilà
peut-être que si les la fiscalité
l'entrepreneuriat je sais pas il y avait
des aides peut-être un peu mieux sur les
petits chefs d'entreprise il se peut que
nos enfants voudraient peut-être les
reprendre voilà
il faut dire que aussi dans le certains
langages politiques l'entreprise n'a pas
bonne presse non plus donc c'est vrai
que ça n'aide pas en termes de
communication et de pédagogie monsieur
nous écoutons on peut même pas dire que
c'est une on peut pas dire que c'est une
question d'éducation car j'ai des écoles
alternatives donc on peut même pas dire
que on n'apprend pas puisque moi dans
mon école on en parle
d'esprit général dans l'éducation
nationale en l'occurrence monsieur
bonjour Maxime Thibault dirigeant de
acpm et entreprise de plasturgie dans
l'industrie dans les hauts de France et
on a fait l'acquisition en croissance
externes de société à Brétigny en
Essonne aujourd'hui on est 30 personnes
moi je suis en pleine reprise entreprise
familiale également alors je suis un peu
étonné des chiffres comme quoi il y a
pas assez de reprise familiale en France
pour que c'est un gros problème et un
gros problème de souveraineté aussi
également en pleine
d'enregistréalisation ce qui est
également très important aujourd'hui
surtout en sortie de covid moi mon
témoignage là dessus il est il est
important c'est que dans l'industrie
d'autant plus on a des gros actifs les
entreprises valent très cher la plus
grosse problématique elle va être de
faire un crédit pour payer l'impôt de
mon père en fait ce qu'il est prêt à
faire un crédit vendeur donc on peut
espionner des choses mais à un moment
donné ça devient lourd quand on pose la
question à des enfants de reprendre moi
ça fait 10 ans que je suis dans la boîte
je suis passionné par mon métier je suis
passionné par cette entreprise j'ai pas
vu beaucoup mon père parce qu'il a bossé
comme un cinglé pour nous
et à un moment donné c'est un petit peu
tirer la sonnette d'alarme quoi moi j'ai
mon père qui a payé des impôts toute sa
vie toute sa vie l'impôt sur les
sociétés enfin voilà là on doit encore
une fois passer à la caisse encore une
fois derrière malgré les packs du trail
malgré des donations ok d'accord mais à
un moment donné stop on en a marre de
passer à la caisse continuellement là je
reprends une société qui en plus comme
je viens de le dire dans l'industrie on
enchaîne Chris surprise tous les trois
mois on prend des bas dans la gueule
alors vous venez de pour rien c'est sûr
même si je pense que les politiques ont
quand même des choses notamment au
niveau énergétique parce que là c'est un
scandale ce qui est en train de se
passer moi je vais investir dans une
boîte je sais pas où je vais mais j'y
vais quand même je sais que je vais me
prendre des factures dans la tête
monstrueuses que je vais devoir discuter
avec mes clients sur les hausses de prix
des choses comme ça mais le risque qu'il
est là j'entendais tout à l'heure un mot
qui est important c'est résilience et
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui pour
moi caractérise le plus le chef
d'entreprise aujourd'hui si je dois
enfin si je dois justement poser la
question à mes enfants ils sont tout
petits j'ai une petite fille qui a 5
mois et un garçon qui a 6 ans
sincèrement j'ai pas envie de leur dire
vivez ce que je suis en train de vivre
en ce moment je leur dis mettez-vous à
35 heures et en plus ils vont peut-être
mieux gagner que ce que je gagne
aujourd'hui parce que moi j'ai même des
collaborateurs que j'embauche
aujourd'hui quasiment au même salaire
voir si tu es plus avec 70 heures par
semaine un moment donné il faut arrêter
on est épuisé sincèrement on est
vraiment épuisé la fiscalité en France
faut la baisser faut vraiment y aller
drastiquement et c'est en ce moment faut
plus attendre il va être trop tard on
entend dans la presse des boîtes qui
sont en train de crouler les unes à la
présence tous les jours si ce n'est
toutes les minutes enfin sincèrement le
ma parole elle est vraiment sur un cri
de détresse pour moi j'entends le
président de la BPI il faut
réindustrialiser il faut que les jeunes
partent dans l'industrie j'en suis un
exemple je peux venir intervenir je peux
discuter plein de choses pas de problème
mais à un moment donné c'est arrêtons de
discuter et agissons sincèrement c'est
problématique on les connaît depuis
longtemps on peut parler d'indicateurs
on peut pas être statistiques de ce
qu'on veut mais à un moment donné c'est
des sujets qui sont pas que d'actualité
ça fait 5 ou 10 ans qui sont connus
agissons et vite et tous ensemble c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus pour être plus
important
[Applaudissements]
pas de commentaires particulier de
quelques côtés que ce soit alors
monsieur nous vous écoutons et après je
vais aller là-bas et à la tribune
monsieur
bonjour donc Sébastien gindreau je
dirige une entreprise de 45 salariés en
Haute-Saône donc entreprise familiale
que j'ai repris que j'ai racheté donc je
suis la troisième génération j'ai
racheté à toute la famille il y a 6 ans
et on parle donc de faire les
transmissions mais moi je voulais parler
de pérenniser les transmissions c'est à
dire pour que derrière ça dure il faut
aussi qu'on conforme mieux les chefs
d'entreprise qu'on connaît les sociétés
quand on est je parle surtout en niveau
familial on connaît l'entreprise on
connaît pas forcément tous les métiers
de gestion de marketing de tout ça et je
dirais il y a des choses qui existent et
si on veut justement que les gens aient
envie de reprendre faut aussi qu'ils
aient un peu moins peur de lui se lance
donc il y a des choses qui existent il y
a des choses qui marchent et puis
maintenant je dirais on est passé avec
le problème de la formation qui doit
être absolument qualifiante moi par
exemple j'ai fait l'école des managers
c'est pour
les repreneurs d'entreprises sur tous
les enfants de chefs d'entreprise
c'était pas diplômant à l'époque
maintenant pour que ça soit diplômant il
faut faire des choses pas possible pour
que ça soit qualifiant avec finalement
des sujets qui n'en sont pas et je
trouve que on risque de perdre tout ça
juste pour des raisons finalement un peu
administratives donc je voulais juste
parler de ça et je pense que c'est aussi
important que la montée en compétences
des chefs d'entreprise si on veut que
nos entreprises se développent par la
suite voilà oui
ça c'est très important d'autant que les
enjeux que nous avons aujourd'hui
comme le disait monsieur sont tels que
on ne peut pas tout savoir on ne peut
pas tout connaître et le monde évolue
tellement vite qu'il faut se former à
des choses dont on n'est pas forcément
familier alors on parle de
digitalisation il vous parlez de gestion
de marketing mais la digitalisation
c'est des sujets qui vont bientôt nous
dépasser metaves en faisant partie bon
on est un peu parfois embourbé dans nos
problématiques opérationnelles de
gestion au quotidien et de survie de
l'entreprise donc c'est vrai que aider
aussi les chefs d'entreprise au travers
de dispositifs permettant de financer en
sortant d'accompagnement je pense que
c'est une une bonne piste bien tout est
enregistré on part à la tribune avant de
redescendre bonjour messieurs dames je
suis Jean-Pierre Richard je suis
président de Chambre des Métiers de
l'Yonne et vice-président régional
Bourgogne Franche-Comté la transmission
je suis un peu dedans tous les jours
je tiens à rappeler que si vous
recherchez une entreprise nous avons en
chambre de métier trans-artisanat
transcommerce tous les gens qui désirent
sont inscrits sur ces fichiers
maintenant je vais rebondir sur ce que
disait un monsieur en bas oui nous
allons avoir un grave problème de
gestionnaire en France à force de dire
on simplifie la création d'entreprise il
y a plus besoin de faire de stage
d'installation préalable à l'entreprise
nous allons perdre toutes ses capacités
de gestionnaire que nous avions depuis
ces années et ses années
vive l'auto-entreprise j'ai envie de
dire
merci alors Florent boniou va vous
répondre alors vous parliez de stage je
ne vous ai pas dit dans ma
cheminement pour pour reprendre son bref
faire en fait j'ai fait des des stages
je me suis dit tiens je vais je vais
aller chez des entreprises qui font des
armatures donc concrètement
je les ai appelés
j'ai réussi à trouver une une convention
parce que c'était pas simple en fait
j'étais encore salarié et
je voulais faire mon stage quoi et donc
on a trouvé un système j'ai réussi à je
me suis mis en congé un concrètement le
dernier mois et j'ai appelé Pôle emploi
qui m'a dit oui on commence à mettre une
des convention en route pour les gens
qui sont encore salariés qui veulent
reprendre une entreprise donc j'ai dit
bah
très bien je signe et je vais faire mes
mes petits stages donc j'ai fait trois
trois stages trois semaines avec
convention
Pôle emploi
et ces stages ont été alors ça a duré
longtemps trois semaines dans trois
entreprises que j'avais contacté mais ça
a été très très bénéfique donc j'ai été
dans l'entreprise j'ai coupé des barres
d'acier j'ai voilà j'ai suivi ce qu'on
m'a dit de faire et j'ai découvert
leur façon de travailler et j'ai gardé
des contacts
ont certaines entreprises sont venues
visiter sobre et fer et on s'est échangé
des des
bonnes façons et je peux vous dire que
ça
c'est très très profitable donc je pense
qu'il y a il y a un système de stage
peut-être à mettre en place pour les
futurs repreneurs parce que il y a pas
vraiment de
je sais pas si la CCI propose des stages
quand on est salarié mais il y a pas
vraiment de parcours de stagiaire merci
alors tout cela est bien noté également
encore beaucoup de questions
malheureusement on pourra pas toutes les
prendre mais je rappelle que le déjeuner
va être l'occasion de vous rencontrer et
je précise aussi que j'essaie possible
de respecter l'ordre des demandes donc
monsieur il y a longtemps que vous
demandiez la parole nous vous écoutons
bonjour Tony Mirande
je suis je dirige le groupe GUY HOQUET
immobilier en Guyane française et je
suis aussi président de Réseau
Entreprendre il vice-président de 60 000
rebonds anti Guyane
donc je crois que le aujourd'hui la plus
grosse problématique c'est de vaincre
l'isolement du chef d'entreprise et le
témoignage du chef d'entreprise qu'on a
entendu qui venait de
qui ne reprend l'entreprise aujourd'hui
avec toutes les crises que l'on vit
actuellement et toutes les difficultés
il est clair que
souvent le chef d'entreprise se sent
isolé
et c'est pour ça que il est important
que ce chef d'entreprise puisse être
entouré d'autres chefs d'entreprise et
c'est pour ça que les associations
Réseau Entreprendre et sont 000 rebonds
sur les associations qui accompagnent
justement la création d'entreprise aussi
bien financièrement que
dans l'accompagnement ou du quotidien
donc pendant plusieurs années pour leur
permettre justement de
d'éviter d'être isolé et de pouvoir
prendre les bonnes décisions au niveau
de leur entreprise voilà c'est un clin
d'oeil que je voulais faire sur les
associations alors disons qu'aujourd'hui
il faut leur donner plus de moyens merci
je rebondis parce que je fais moi-même
partie de Réseau Entreprendre j'ai
bénéficié d'un prêt à taux zéro de 40000
euros et c'est vrai qu'il y a un suivi
pendant deux ans avec un autre chef
d'entreprise
un rendez-vous tout les mois pour faire
le point et raconter ces difficultés
pour ne va pas être isolé donc ça c'est
un très bon dispositif monsieur
le bouton rouge le bouton bonjour
Christophe masse je dirige un cabinet
d'intermédiation donc je fais la
transmission d'entreprise donc
j'accompagne les cédants qui veulent
trouver un repreneur à leur entreprise
ou comme Monsieur j'accompagne les
sociétés qui veulent faire de la
croissance externe pour justement
trouver une société à reprendre je
rebondis sur ce que disait monsieur
boniou tout à l'heure sur le l'aspect
capital humain de l'entreprise ce qui
fait aujourd'hui beaucoup la valeur de
l'entreprise c'est son capital humain
surtout dans les difficultés actuelles
de recrutement je rebondis aussi sur ce
que disait monsieur sur la
le fait que
les salariés à un moment donné
apprennent que l'entreprise est à la
vente peut leur faire peur peut générer
du stress et dans ce cadre là il me
semble qu'il y a un dispositif légal
aujourd'hui qui est inadapté c'est la
loi Hamon dans le sens où quand on
avertit les salariés de moins avant la
session c'est déjà fait on a déjà le
repreneur donc on ne fait que générer de
l'inquiétude au niveau des salariés ça
peut même générer des départs ce qui
peut remettre en question dans certains
cas l'acquisition puisque le repreneur
souhaite reprendre ce capital humain et
donc voilà je pense que c'est un
dispositif qu'il faudrait revoir parce
que inadapté à mon sens sur dans la
conjoncture actuelle
message
en tout cas monsieur ne vous écoute ah
alors monsieur le rapporteur et je vous
donne la parole après bien sûr oui merci
Monsieur kuni je voulais juste rebondir
sur le dernier intervenant
dans les propositions les 11
propositions qu'on fait dans notre
rapport sur la transmission d'entreprise
avec Michel et Rémi il y a justement une
proposition d'abroger le dispositif à
mon d'informations qui comme vous le
dites et on l'explique comme ça qui crée
de l'incertitude quelquefois un effet de
panique et qui nuit gravement à la bonne
transmission de l'entreprise en question
donc vous avez la réponse immédiate
par la suite
[Applaudissements]
monsieur et ce sera la dernière question
avant le déjeuner oui bonjour à tous
christianiel moi je suis stagiaire
retraité puisque nous avons vendu
l'entreprise avec mon associé à deux
jeunes repreneurs qui sont à côté de
nous là et je voudrais insister sur la
préparation de la transmission justement
de l'entreprise bien en amont de l'acte
de vente c'est-à-dire qu'en s'y est
préparé depuis quatre ou moins quatre
ans
pour préparer nos jeunes à cette reprise
et notamment Geoffrey le plus jeune on
l'inscrit à l'école des jeunes
dirigeants de la Fédération du Bâtiment
donc 800 heures de formation et puis
Maxime qui est un peu plus de bouteilles
qui est notre stagiaire il y a 17 ans
c'est devenu mon patron en début d'année
donc
là on l'inscrit à au même module mais
sur un sujet beaucoup plus condensé un
format beaucoup plus condensé sur 200
heures de formation donc si on
[Musique]
et donc on repasse à la caisse en heure
supplémentaire c'est normal mais ça a un
coût quand même au niveau de
l'entreprise alors si il y avait un
petit levier à mettre en place au niveau
de la reprise des entreprises c'est ce
serait de mettre un peu plus la patate
sur la formation de nos salariés à la
reprise d'entreprise et bon nous on
avait la volonté de faire reprendre
l'entreprise par nos salariés donc on a
on a fait le chèque on n'a pas discuté
mais enfin voilà c'est le témoignage que
je voulais apporter témoignage précieux
et merci à nos jeunes amis et bravo
surtout bravo grand bravo et merci à
vous également peut vous applaudir pour
ces témoignages